in this nine hour course you will learn
how to use flutter and upright to
develop your own Twitter clone complete
with authentication tweet creation
real-time updates and more Revan is your
instructor for this course are you ready
to build the ultimate Twitter clone in
this video I'll be taking you through
the step-by-step process of creating an
app that has all the features you love
on Twitter and more I'll start by
showing you how to install apprite and
set up the flutter project with apprite
in the next section we will add user
registration and login with email and
password along with the logic of keeping
logged in users logged in
then we'll move on to the fun stuff like
tweeting text images and links and even
identifying and storing hashtags next
you'll learn how to display tweets like
the Tweet with the exact Twitter like
animation retweet it and even reply to
the tweets just like keyword on Twitter
after this we will move to the explore
tab where you will learn how to search
for other users follow them and even
display their followers following and
recent tweets
with the notifications tab we will add
the feature to allow our users to be
able to stay up to date on all the
latest activity including replies
follows and likes by others on their
tweets I'll also show you how to edit
your own user profile by editing name
bio or changing profile and Mana picture
we will also add the feature of listing
all the tweets that have a specific
hashtag and finally we can also allow
the user get the ultimate status symbol
Twitter Blue by simply clicking a button
with the help of this tutorial you learn
all about apprise features like
authentication database storage real
time queries and indexes for State
Management we will be using riverpod
even if you are a beginner with no prior
experience with upright or riverpod
you'll be able to follow along and
create a stunning project before
starting this tutorial I'd like to
request you all to subscribe to the
channel now let's start with the video
so the first step is to install apprite
locally in our system to do that let's
take a look at the dogs
and click on installation aware
if we scroll down you'll find that the
easiest way to start running the upright
server is by running a Docker installer
that means we need to install Docker to
install Docker we can just go to
docker.com website we can select the
appropriate system and download Docker
desktop I'm going to select the Apple
chip
and while Docker is being downloaded
I'll tell you what Docker is Docker is
just a way to package software such that
it can run on any hardware in our case
suppose we have apprite with some
version so flutter with app right
project works on my PC but when you try
to run the same flutter project with a
different version of apprite installed
on your PC it doesn't work or works but
with a different Behavior than expected
that's where Docker helps and solves the
problem now that we have understood what
Docker is and our download for Docker is
complete let's click over here I'll drag
this Docker to Applications folder after
the process has been completed I'll
click on command Q to exit this I'll go
to the finder click on applications and
then run Docker from here so this is how
the docker desktop screen looks
we don't have to do anything in here we
can just go back to the installation
website and see what are the next steps
the next step is to copy this command
and put it in the terminal so if you're
on Linux or Mac you can use this command
or if you're on Windows you can use this
command depending on if you're using CMD
or Powershell you can run the following
commands since I am on Mac I'll just
copy this open Terminal and paste the
command over here then I'll click on
enter
after it downloads everything it will
ask you for the prompts so on what port
should this upright server run I'm just
going to go ahead with the default
option so I'll click on enter enter
enter
so after apprite has successfully
installed you can close the terminal and
in the docker desktop you'll see apprite
is now running with lots of things
happening inside you might see some
familiar names like influx GB
all of this is used
with an app right internally if you want
to know more it's written in the app
right documentation you can go ahead and
take a look at it after this we can go
to Chrome open localhost
I already have an account with app right
but so that we are on the same page
I'm going to create a new account and
name myself everyone
enter an email and a password click on
sign up
and here we are on the project screen so
we need to type in our first project
name
so we'll type in Twitter clone
and then click on create project
so our upright project has now been
created the next step is to start a
flutter project so we login go to the
terminal go to the desktop create a new
project called flutter create
and call this Twitter clone
and then click on enter
then we'll migrate to Twitter clone
folder and open a 10 vs code
now we can go to the lib folder and in
the main.dot file let's just try to run
an application so I'm going to open an
iOS simulator
click on run and run without debugging
and while this is running I just want to
mention two important commands related
to app right so we'll again open the
terminal
and if you're on Mac if you just do CD
which is chain directory and go to app
right we can go to the upright folder
which is basically the root folder and
inside of the root folder we have the
upright folder and there you can run
multiple commands two important commands
are for stopping upright container and
another one is starting upright
container to stop upright container you
can just do Docker compose stop and
after hitting enter
upright container in the docker will
stop running so this has 20 on 20
running it will change to 0 out of 20
and it will stop running so after you
click over here
and restart localhost this will also go
away
because localhost is only there as long
as a Docker container of app right is
running over here and after stopping the
docker container if you again want to
restart the docker container you don't
have to run the command that we run
earlier again you don't have to run this
command again
this is for the installation to again
run this upright container you need to
run Docker compose up dash dash dash
remove dash orphans and after you run
this your Docker container of app right
will again start running but you need to
make sure that you are in the upright
folder if you're on Mac you can just do
CD app right from the root and you'll
get into there and if you're on Windows
you can just go to the users folder and
check for the upright folder our app is
also running fine now so let's go ahead
and set up app right for our flutter
project
so we want to add a flutter platform so
we'll just click over here and then we
need to pass in the name of the Android
app
I'll just do Twitter Android and then we
need the package name so I'm just going
to go to the build.gradle in the Android
folder in the app subdirectory copy this
application ID
and paste it over here if you are going
to build this application for production
or if you want to deploy it
on Play Store you'll have to change this
com.example to com dot suppose everyone
if that's your name but since I just
want to demo this I'm just going to have
com.example here
then click on next
then you need to install this app right
dependency so you can just copy this
click on command shift p
click on dot add dependency
paste in upright and install it it will
install the latest version of app right
directly in pubspect.aml file then we'll
click on next and these are all the
steps that are later required but for
now we can just click on next
and we are done now we need to add
another platform which is flutter app
only but for iOS so for iOS I'm just
going to have Twitter iOS and now we
need bundle ID to get bundle ID you can
go to iOS right click and open a 10x
code if you're on Windows you probably
won't get the open index code button
because you cannot build iOS
applications with
Windows platform
so you can skip all the iOS related
steps that we are doing here just follow
along for Android now to get the bundle
ID you can click on Runner
go to signing and capabilities copy this
close xcode paste it over here click on
next we have already added upright
dependency we can click on next next and
we are done
so we have configured for Android and
iOS now if you want to add for web you
can click on flutter app again
you can click on web and go ahead with
this but we are only building app for
Android and iOS so I won't take you
through it now that upright
configuration is done let's close all of
this create a new folder here called
constants
this constants folder is going to
contain all the constants that are in
our application so it can be apprite
constants which is the file we are going
to create now other constants include UI
constants so all the
UI related constants that we have and
asset constants so we have SVG files in
our app so we need to mention that path
just putting them in a widget will not
look good because if you want to update
the SVG file sometime it will take us a
lot of time to go through every single
file and change it over there just
having one single file containing all
the constants is always a good thing so
here in the upright constants file we
are going to create a new file we are
going to create a class called upright
constants
and we are going to have a static
constant property of database ID
database ID is necessary for making
connection from our flutter app to this
upright console we can get the database
ID by going over your databases create a
new database let's call this
Twitter test database
so and then click on create
now we have the database ID we can copy
this
and paste it over here another thing
that we need is Project ID so we'll have
the project
ID
and project ID can be found in the
Twitter clone if you click on copy of
project ID
and third thing that we need is an end
point so we'll have static constant
string endpoint which is equal to http
colon slash slash localhost
colon 80
is whatever Port you put in the terminal
if you just click on enter like me with
the default options it's 80 otherwise it
is what you've mentioned there slash V1
if you want to verify you can click on
command Full Stop open it in the browser
and it is the same thing so we are good
to go these are the upright constants we
need for now there will be other
constants that will be required but
we'll get to it as we move forward in
the application
another thing we need is the svgs file
so for svgs we are just going to go to
the root folder create a new folder
called assets and in assets you are
going to have svgs
now to get the svgs you can just go to
this website github.com
flutter Twitter clone
go to asset slash svgs
and your install all the svgs these are
all the svgs that will be required in
our flutter app go ahead and install
them after you've installed them just
click on copy and paste it in the svgs
folder now we need to register all of
these svgs so we'll go to pubspec.yaml
file
scroll down here in the assets we'll
just have assets slash
svgs slash so this will register all the
files inside of this svgs folder it can
only do this because we have put slash
away or if you remove this it will not
register any of the files present over
here
now in the constants file we need to
create another file called constants
asset constants dot dot then you need to
come to this website linked to it will
be mentioned in the description below
and then copy all of this this is all
the parts of the constants file so it
contains like the Twitter logo home
field icon home outlined icon all of
those stuff I don't want to write this
and waste your time
just writing this mean
thing is to focus on the UI of the
application as well as the backend of
the application not all of this
boilerplate code that we need to write
so this is all the asset constants with
us
now in the constraints folder we just
need to create another file called
constants dot dot and this will export
all of these files so we have it will
export upright constants and it will
export assets constants
why is it exporting and why do we need
this file because
this constants will be used in almost
every single UI file of ours and even in
the repository files that means the
files that will talk to the server we
don't want multiple import lines to show
up over there so we don't want import
dot dot
upright constant sorry and we don't want
import assets constants dot dot to show
up every single time instead of doing
this too we can just have import
constants dot dot
so we have lesser import lines with this
and if you want to add more constants
later on while we are building this
application
as the import lines increase over your
suppose we have these many import lines
now we still have to import this
constants.dot file itself we don't have
to continuously import this and increase
the file length you know any is not to
get confused let's move ahead and add
theme to our application again we are
just completing all of the boilerplate
stuff
so that we can directly dive into the
logic of the application this part might
be boring but but later on it will be
very good for our application so in the
theme first thing we need is palette dot
dot file so we'll go ahead to this link
will be mentioned in the description
below copy this paste it and we have all
the colors that are required in our
application the background color is pure
black blue color is a bit different from
the
real blue color like zero zero two fifty
five instead of that we have this color
extracted from the Twitter website
we have white gray and red color
all of this is saved over here because
in case we want to change the color of
our app the theming of our app even a
little bit you can just control all of
that from one single file file and one
single class which is palette other
thing that we need is app
underscore theme dot dot we are going to
copy this from here so we can copy and
paste this over here
we have to resolve this error of palette
so we'll just click on command full stop
import this palette dot dot and this is
it this contains the theming of our
application so like
what theme is there so we have team data
dot doc so it has
all the properties of dog which is given
to us by flutter itself and we're going
to copy that and make certain changes
for example scaffold background color
will be pure black instead of grayish
which is the original
background color that flutter gives us
so if you want to see a demo we can go
to the main dot dot file
we'll remove the theme from your and add
our own theme
which is present in app Theme dot theme
now if you restart the application you
can see this is pure black
but if I again go to app Theme
comment this line out which is careful
background color and restart the
application
you'll see this is how
flutters background color in dark mode
looks like but we want this since you
are copying Twitter
this also contains app bar theme so
every time the app bar is going to be of
the black color with no elevation at all
and The Floating Action button is going
to be of blue color now that all of this
is complete we'll go to the theme folder
and add theme dot dot so that we can
export these two files so the these two
file are DOT slash app Theme Dot
and export dot slash palette dot dot
now we can save this close it and in the
input here we can just import theme dot
dot so all the boilerplate code for now
is done
I don't think we'll be needing any more
things now is the time to start
designing our application and the first
thing that we need to do is design the
login screen but even before doing that
let's understand the architecture plan
for this project so for the folder
structure we are going to be using a
feature first approach that means in the
folder lib folder we are going to create
another folder called features in this
features we are going to have multiple
features of our app for example
Authentication
home screen so the home feature the
notifications featured the Tweet feature
the user profile feature all of those so
I can just create an auth feature for
now and this auth folder is now going to
have three separate folders called View
controller
and widgets
view is basically the login view the
sign up view all the UI related screens
controller is basically the connection
between View and the database files what
are the database files well we create
them outside of the features folder in
the lib folder we are going to create a
new folder called as apis this API
folder is going to contain all the
backend related code it's not going to
have anything else so since we are using
Riverport we are not going to have any
riverpod package in apis we are just
going to have the backend related code
nothing else
even the model conversion so basically
we'll get our data in a map format we
need to convert it in a model or a class
based format
even then we are going to do that in the
controller folder not in the apis I'll
give you a diagrammatic representation
so that
you understand what we are talking about
but for now I'll just create a new file
called login view dot dot and we are
going to import material dot we are
going to create a stateless widget
actually we need a state full widget
because we are going to have text
editing controllers whenever there's a
text editing controller in the field
it's better to make it stateful widget
because it provides us with a dispose
method so we need to dispose of the
controllers or the text editing
controllers that we have right
so for now we'll just create a login
View and this will return a scaffold
and just so that we can see what we are
developing I'll copy this go to the
main.dart file and remove all of this
boilerplate code we don't need this
counter application
and instead of this we are just going to
have
constant logins View I'll save it and we
should see a blank screen and here we
are after having login view in place let
me show you a diagrammatic
representation so suppose this is our UI
file
this UI file is directly going to talk
to the controller
and this controller is directly going to
talk to the repository files this
repository file is basically the files
that we are going to create in apis so
it's going to be the Tweet API there's
going to be user API
and authentication API so these are the
repository files all the backend related
code but with this architecture this
might seem very simple UI is talking to
controller controller talks to
repository but here's a catch UI cannot
directly talk to repository and
repository directly cannot talk to UI
so in our login view for example we
cannot have any API file being imported
that's the best way to understand this
if you're going to have auth API you're
not going to have the import of auth API
over here because you're never going to
use auth API in our login View
we are going to use all of that in
controller and controller will directly
talk to the login view so you can have
import of
auth controller but not auth API so UI
cannot directly talk to repository and
repository will never talk to UI and
make changes in it but yes UI can talk
to controller controller can talk to
Repository so let's put a crossover
because it's not allowed now you might
ask what is the point of this controller
why can't we directly have UI talking to
repository as I said repository is going
to contain all the backend related code
and it's going to have nothing extra so
it's just going to contain app right
server calls upright might give
something to us we need to send it
across to controller
controller will do all the processes
that are required like model conversion
talking with other apis so that we can
create one function for example
if you want to edit the user profile
you'll send a user model that needs to
be updated to apprite which means we are
going to send a user model to repository
for files the repository files will make
some changes and send it back to
controller but controller doesn't have
to stop there because edit profile also
includes editing the user image and the
banner picture the so the controller
will also talk to the storage API which
is a different API than user API and
then the controller will make changes to
UI maybe pop off the screen so this is
the point of controller it is going to
make some important changes to our
function
and another question you might have is
why is API not in features folder right
why is
controller inside of authentication
feature but why is API not in the auth
feature like it should be there right
and I partly agree with you but
the problem is suppose we have tweet API
and user API they're both very
interconnected so some function or some
functionality in our app might require
user API and tweet API both in the
controller and the logic of feature
first approach is that if you don't want
any feature you just have to
delete that for feature and the app
should still work fine for you that's
the logic of feature first approach if
you don't like anything if you don't
like a certain feature so suppose you
don't want tweet related features you
can just delete that feature entirely by
just deleting the folder so if we delete
this folder and suppose user API or
tweet API is required in some other
feature
that will be a problem
because you have deleted the API folder
along with it right that's why apis
folder is created in the lib folder if
you don't understand it till now don't
worry when we get into the real code
you'll understand this is all
theoretical practical approach will give
you a better insight
so let's go ahead and design the login
view now
so this is what we are trying to develop
now let's break it down and see what all
components are needed first is this
component which seems like an app bar
with
or Twitter icon over it okay we have the
Twitter icon already installed
or downloaded you can see that in assets
svgs we just had the Twitter logo SVG
over here so we don't need to worry
about the logo part the next thing is a
lot of space over here so we need to put
some spacing and then we have two text
fields that look identical that's the
main thing they both look identical so
we need to create One widget for them
because they're identical
if they're identical we don't have to
write the same code again and again
so we can just create One widget for it
and keep reusing it right because this
is just for the login screen even in the
sign up screen we are going to require
the same auth fields
then we have a done button which is kind
of circular in shape and then we have a
text with some part in white color and
some part in blue color okay now let's
start developing it
so in the app bar we're going to have
the app bar but again app bar is going
to be reusable because the login view
has it the signup view has it even the
home screen has it so let's create a
separate widget for it so if we try to
create another widget for an app bar
let's see what we get so we are just
going to have a stateless widget and
we're going to call this reusable app
bar and then we are going to return an
app bar so in the lib folder we are
going to create another folder called
common and in this common folder we are
going to have all the common widgets
that are required in the app so the
first one is the reusable app bar
now we'll import material Dot then we
are going to create a stateless widget
and call this reusable Abba
then we are going to return a scaff not
a scaffold sorry an app bar and in the
app bar we are going to have a title via
title because the Twitter icon logo is
right in the center and now we want to
display an SVG
to display an SVG we can't do image dot
asset or something we'll have to use a
new plugin for it and that is called SVG
flutter SVG
and now to you that we'll do SVG picture
dot asset and now we'll mention the
asset name we won't directly mention
like this assets slash svgs slash
Twitter logo dot PNG no we are not going
to do that because we have already
created an assets constants file here we
have it
so we can just do
assets constants Dot
Twitter logo all right this is another
benefit of having a constraint file if
you have to use it everywhere you can
just type this without the scope of
making any error because we know
whatever we have put there is correct
and if you want to change of course you
can add another logo change the path
over here and it will change everywhere
you've used it you've just used it right
now in your reusable but if you have a
splash screen or something you can use
it there as well now we can just take
this R Bar put it in the login View
and now you can see we are getting this
error because app bar
cannot be of the type reusable app bar
which is a widget it needs something
known as a preferred size widget that's
why we cannot put app bar in a stateless
widget what we need to do for it is
go to the constants have UI underscore
constants dot dot file created we are
going to have class of UI constants
and we are going to return a static app
bar
and now we can return the app bar from
this function because it is of the type
app bar so we can call this function and
it will still work because it's of the
type app bar and app bar implements the
preferred size widget that's needed in
this app bar type right
so we can copy content from this app bar
delete this file
go to the UI constants
and return the app barrier
now we can import SVG picture
import assets constants so make sure you
uh
import constants dot dot and done now we
can do this so we can just call
UI constants
dot app bar we are not creating an
object of UI constants instead we are
just doing UI constants dot app bar
because it is a static property if you
want you can make this a non-static
property and create an object of UI
constants and then call app bar but I
just think
this way is better we can remove this
URL it doesn't exist and restart the app
and nothing shows up so let's see why
one reason is that AB bar is of the
black color because you have mentioned
that in the app Theme
right here the app bar theme background
color is black and elevation is zero
so if we go to the main.dot file app
Theme is this theme that is present over
here so the app bar is black in color so
we cannot see anything Plus
the logo here is black
we need to change it to Blue so we can
just do color
palette dot blue color save it and now
the Twitter icon shows up but it's quite
small so we need to increase its height
so we can just do height 30. save it and
hear the Twitter icon shows up
it looks exactly like this but there's
one problem if you open this on an
Android emulator
this title will go to the left
we need to keep it centered every time
on any platform so we need to
pass in a property of Center title true
aware
it should be outside of the title
property
Center title true now there's no changes
but we are sure that this will work on
Android as well we'll open the Android
emulator when we are working on the
Tweet feature but for now let's just
develop on Android
on iOS 30. another thing that I have
problem with is anytime the login view
is calling set state or when we are
using riverpod you'll see
that whenever the loading indicators are
showing up app bar will keep running
and that's not what we want we want it
to not rebuild even during
the loading indicator so what can we do
well we could have created widget for it
but we tried and it didn't work for an
app bar that's why we are just going to
have final Abba
which is equal to UI constants dot Abba
we are going to create an instant
surveyor so that every time there is a
rebuild
it doesn't call this function again
because we are just having the instance
of app bar with us which we have called
right here so every time the build
function is
recalled R Bar is not built now
and if you save it it works the same
thing but it's just a little bit of
optimization
now we need a body and in the body we
are going to have a single child scroll
view because
we have two text Fields then we click on
either of the text field we can get a
render flow error by the keyboard
so whenever you click on this text field
a keyboard appears and it might minimize
the screen
and give you a render flow error we want
to avoid that so we are having a single
child scroll View and then we are going
to have a child
add a little bit of padding because
padding is needed for all of these
fields you can see the done button has a
bit of padding both the text Fields have
padding
so we need the padding and padding is
going to be Edge insets
dot symmetric by symmetric because we
want it from the left and the right side
so horizontal 20.
and now we need child and the child is
going to be column because we need
four different type of widgets two text
Fields so we are going to have text
field
one
text field 2
button text pan
you'll understand why we are having text
spanner well just to say it simply
because you have two different type of
colors used and we want them in a same
line you can of course use a row widget
for it along with two text Fields but a
text pan widget is better because
we have to write lesser code for that so
for the text field one we are going to
create a separate widget because it's
going to be reused and we are going to
call this auth underscore field or dot
we're not creating this inside the
common widget or common folder why
because auth field is only used in login
View and sign up view nothing outside of
the auth feature
we need different type of fields later
on for example in edit profile we are
going to have a different kind of field
but not this kind of text field
so let's import material dot we are
going to add
a stateless widget and call this auth
field
now we need to return something known as
a text form field
you can even use text field doesn't
matter in this case and then we are
going to have a controller so we'll get
the controller from this Constructor
why are we getting it from The
Constructor because if you use auth
field like this area
we need to reuse it right so we can
again call auth field
and if we use one single text field both
of these will have the same text passed
in so if I write something over here
in this text field it will automatically
type it in this field because they both
have the same controller we don't want
this to happen so we are asking them to
provide us with the text editing
controller themselves so that we don't
have this problem so we'll import this
controller
and pass it in
now we need to add a little bit of
decoration so what is the decoration we
need well
there should be a border and whenever
the text field is clicked on it should
have a blue Highlight
and of course some padding in between
the hint text like email address and the
increase in font size because the
initial or the default one is quite less
so we can do all of that by having
decoration input decoration Focus border
Focus border with outline input bottom
the focus border is basically whenever
you click on this text field what color
should show up so whenever you click on
the text field you want the blue color
to show up and it should be an outline
so we are having an outline input border
then we want the Border radius to be not
exactly a rectangle but there should be
a little bit of curve so we can have
border radius of Border radius dot
circular
5.
then we are going to have a border side
of constant Border Side
with color AS Palette dot blue color so
let's save this
pass in and create controller first of
all so we are going to have final
email controller is equal to text
editing controller
and then we are going to have final
password controller is equal to text
editing controller now we just need to
dispose this off
and then we're going to have email
controller.dispose
passwordcontroller.dispose
pass all of this to the auth field so
we'll have controller
email controller
controller password controller and if
you want to see what I said if we have
both as the same controller they'll have
the same text let's try it out
so I'll just say
AAA and you can see both have the same
text and if I change this to password
controller both will have different text
now but you can see our Focus border is
now perfectly working
whenever we put a focus it has a blue
line
but it's not thick enough so we need to
make it thick and of course there's a
little bit of less padding here so we
need to add the padding as well so the
width is going to be 3 over here
save it and you can see this is much
thicker now this might not look exactly
like this one but when we increase the
padding so let's do that so here we are
going to have content padding which
should be constant Edge insets dot all
22.
this is a tried and tested value I kept
on increasing the value and saw what fit
the best so if you have anything else
you can try it on your own
and this has a little bit of more
padding
now I just need a hint text so the hint
text is going to be whatever the login
view provides I cannot just say this is
email or this is password because it
will show up for both the text Fields I
don't want that
so I'm just going to import that from
here so we have hint text
required this Dot hintex
take the syntax and pass it in we'll
pass in the hint text aware which is
email
and this is password
of course this is a named argument so
we'll pass that in
save it Let's ignore let's put the
warning aside by putting a const
and here we have the password and email
showing up now we just need a focused
border now that we have focused border
we want the border that shows up even
when we are not focused so
we can add that by having enabled border
so we can just copy this paste it
replace this with enabled border
so this will show up even when we are
not focusing on the text field
and this should be of the gray color
we can save it and see there's too much
width so we can remove the width part
and now we can see this looks cool but
it's not quite there
we need to put it in the center so we
can go to the login View
wrap the single child scroll view with
something known as the center widget and
if you're wondering how I got this
option I just clicked over here command
shift R which is a refactoring tool if
you don't have this you can just do
right click
refactor and then click on the center
widget now you can save this and here it
is right in the center
now both of them are very attached to
each other so we want to give it a
bit of height so we can just have
constant
size box of height
so now both of them have some space in
between now you might think that yeah
the text fields are very down below but
as we add more widgets this will keep
going up
so for example if I just take this text
field or sorry size box and add a height
of 40
here we are
even when we click over here
this works well
but you can see
the text field still feels small the
reason for that
is because of the font size you can see
the font size is quite small not as
quite big as this so you can just go to
the auth field
and what do we want to do we want to
increase the font size of this hint text
so we can find something like hand style
and then we can use textile on it
pass in the font size which is 18
and put a constant over
and here it is now this looks proper
now we can go to the login view again
and the next thing we need is this
button the done button so we can create
that in the common folder this is
because we are going to need this
rounded button later on in some other
part of the application
so I'm just going to create it and I'm
going to call this rounded small button
dot dot of course you can name it in a
better way but this is what I'm naming
it I'm going to import material dot I'm
going to create a stateless widget and
call this rounded
small button
and here we're going to have a final
void callback of on tap
and
this is needed because we want to
require this dot on tap from the
widget we are going to use this widget
in similar to what we had done in the
auth field we imported all of this we
are going to require all of this as well
and we are sure since this is a button
this is going to have different on tap
now there are different ways of creating
this more rounded small button but the
way I'm going to use is I'm just going
to have a chip widget I'm not going to
really have any button we're going to
have a chip widget widget label
and this text is again going to come
from the Constructor so we can have
final string label
require this dot label
and pass it in
now I can save this use this rounded
small button in login View
so I can replace this
I'm going to pass in the ontap as empty
function for now and the label is done
save it and let's see what we get this
is the button looks quite similar but
there are a few few things that have to
be changed the background color for
example should be white and the font
color in there should be black
so for the label
or more like first we'll configure the
background color the background color
should be the color here and we're going
to take this from The Constructor as
well if you're wondering why
this is because
if you're wondering why why can I not
directly use palette dot black color
this is because this rounded small
button is going to be used in some other
widget and they might need some other
background color some other font color
so we cannot directly mention it over
here so we can have final color
background color
and since we are here we can create
another one which is font color
or the text color
now we can copy this have required this
dot background color required this dot
text color
now we can pass in the background color
here
and the label or the text color is Style
textile
color is text color
and this should be it so we can go to
the login View
pass in the background color AS Palette
dot background color and font color or
the text color sorry that is going to be
palette dot white color right as we have
decided we are just putting it here so
that we when we have to use this rounded
small button somewhere else
that won't be a problem and if you want
to minimize the code what you can do
instead is just remove both of this
go to the rounded small button and say
this is not a required field
whenever the user wants to change this
background color they can just do that
by having it mentioned explicitly
otherwise it will just be palette dot
background color
or palette dot white color
fifth diff is used in some other widget
and this widget needs some other color
then they can explicitly mention that
yeah the background color should be
palette dot blue suppose
and the font color should be white only
so we have minimized the code that we
need to write over here
so let's restart it and see
here is a button and it's quite the
opposite of what we wanted so let's just
replace them we want the text color to
be black and background color to be
white
sorry about that
so this is what we wanted
now we have this button
now we just need to increase the font
size and there's a bit of less padding
so we need to increase that so the font
size should be increased so I'll just
put it 16 again this is a tried and
tested value
and there should be label padding
so we can just have label padding
constant Edge in such dot symmetric
from the horizontal Direction I need 20.
I'll save it now this looks very absurd
I want an increase in the vertical
padding as well so I can just do
vertical five
save it and here you can see both of
them look similar but this button is in
the center I want it in the right hand
side
so for that I can go to the login view
again wrap this rounded small button and
a widget known as align this align
widget will help us align the surrounded
small button so it will help its child
widget
to get aligned and we want to align it
to alignment
dot top right
save it and here we have it
looks good
now we need to leave some space and add
our text pans
so I can copy the size box
remove this command
and now we are going to have Rich text
while we having Rich text because text
span is not really a widget it is a spam
and in this Rich Text we can add
multiple spans for example if you look
at this this requires inline span this
is where our text pan is going to be
there so we can just have text span
and in the text Pan the text is going to
be don't have an account
so let's see what we get with just this
much
yup we have this we had been referring
to the sign up screen all that
time but
this is going to have don't have an
account because we are on the login
screen if you are on the login screen
and if you want to go to the sign up
screen we don't have an account so don't
have an account then we are going to
have in the children
a text span
and in the text pan we're going to have
a text called
sign up with a space aware the space
should be mentioned over here because
there is a bit of spacing here if you
don't add space both of these texts will
be stuck together
so we have sign up
let's save this much
here we have it we just need to change
the color of this text fan so we can
just have Style
textile
and textile should have a color of
palette dot blue color and font size
should be increased to 16.
and the same thing should happen above
as well the font size for this text man
should also increase so you can just put
it over here that the color is the
normal color what you're showing but the
font size should be 16 and both of these
font sizes should match because they're
on the same
line one having a bigger text and
another having a smaller text would look
very absurd
and here we have it
looks word now we are getting all of
this warning so we can just add a const
but we cannot add a const because
this requires a recognizer so whenever
the sign up over here is clicked we need
to navigate to the sign up screen that's
why we are going to have a recognizer
and this is going to be
tab gesture recognizer
dot dot on tap this is the syntax tab
just a recognizer dot dot on tap and
whenever the on tap is made we need to
call this function this function will be
called and whatever you want to do we
want to navigate from the screen to the
sign up screen so we can add that when
we create the sign up view
now we can just put constant over here
and save it so the login view looks
correct
similar thing will be needed for the
sign up view so let's quickly do that so
we'll have sign up underscore view dot
dot import material dot create a
stateless widget actually stateful
widget of
sign up
View
save it now we'll copy all of this
we're going to import the constant so we
can just import constants dot dot
and I think constants doesn't export the
I constant so we can do that so we can
export dot slash UI constants dot dot
and we can fix this in the login view as
well we want to
import constants dot dot
again coming back to the sign up view
we need to return stuff
so we can just return this scaffold
import the palette so we are going to
import theme dot dot we are going to
import flutter gestures package so that
we have tab gesture recognizer we're
going to import the rounded small button
and actually instead of directly
importing it we are going to create a
common dot dot file over here as well
so we are going to export dot slash
rounded small button for now
so we can come over here import this and
import common dot dot so that you know
we'll import lists of
other features
so if anything else is needed in this
screen
we just have to import
them there because
the common dot dot is already present it
will import all of the things that have
been exported from here
now we'll also import auth field so
let's import it
and this looks good now just to see this
on main.dot let's change this to sign up
view
and let's go to the sign up View and see
what changes need to be made well email
and password are the both the fields
that are needed done is also there
now we just have to change this to
already have an account
so we have already have an account and
we want it to be login
so we can just pass and log in
and here we have it
now whenever the user comes first time
to this application we either want to
show the home screen if the user is
logged in or the sign up screen because
it's the first time they're entering the
application
so this sign up view
is going to be the screen that will show
up in the main dot dot for now when we
have the home screen we'll put the logic
of adding the home screen over there now
what we want to do is whenever we click
on this button we want to go to the
login View
so we can create that right now so here
in the sign up view whenever this is
clicked the on Tab you're just going to
have Navigator dot push and we'll pass
in the context then material route
material page route then we are going to
have context and then we are going to
return the login View
and this is going to be a constant
now this is a lot of code to write the
material page route so what we are going
to do is just copy this or cut this go
to the login view create something like
static route
for this and return a material page
route
right
so now what we have to do is just login
View
dot route so we don't have to use
this long boilerplate code every time we
need to navigate from sign up to login
or suppose we are logging out so we
don't have to do
this in the home screen or the other
screen as well wherever the log out
operation takes place
we just have to do login view dot route
and it works fine
now the same thing is needed for the
sign up view when we move from login to
sign up view
so in the on Tab we are just going to
have this and then we are going to go to
the sign up view actually let me just
copy this route
put this in the sign up view
and just return a sign up view over
now we can go down and pass in sign up
view dot route
now when I click over here nothing
happens so let's restart the app
if I click over here I go to the login
view how do I know that because your
signup shows up and if I go where the
sign up button shows up that's pretty
cool
now that both of these things work the
next part is making the authentication
part work so whenever we enter the email
address and password and then click on
done we need to create a user and then
send them to the login screen and then
the user should be able to log in with
the same credential and if it's a
different credential we should show them
an error but before doing all of that we
need to install the main package
that will drive our entire app which is
the flutter riverpod package because all
of the connections everything is going
to be made through real pod and it's
going to be very easy and I'll explain
every step that needs to be taken and
why we are doing what we are doing so
let's get started with it right now so
let's install the flood arrival pod
package so I'll just add flutter
River pod make sure you have flutter
underscore report not just report
riverpod packages for Dart packages and
Dot code but flutter report is mainly
for flutter SDK
so make sure you install that and now in
the apis you are going to create our
first API which is the auth API dot dot
and first of all we are going to create
an abstract class and this abstract
class is going to be called I API
I auth API sorry and
what is this abstract class for well
this abstract class is going to contain
all the functions that are going to be
present in our main class which is the
auth API class which we are going to
implement
so we are going to have this so whatever
function we pass in here the class is
going to have its implementation present
over here
why is abstract class needed because
this is because for many reasons two
main reasons I create an abstract class
because abstract class contains all the
functions related to a particular
API so example the auth API will contain
all the function signatures of that are
required so for example if I want to
sign in I'll have suppose avoid sign up
function
right now I get an error over here I can
just do command full stop create the
missing override that's needed because
I'm implementing iot API and then I can
do my signup process here
this is required so that
in case I want to change my backend from
app right to suppose Firebase or node.js
I can just delete this auth API class
entirely so that there's no Firebase
implementation and I can just have class
auth API again ex implementing I auth
API right now I will get all the missing
signatures or the missing
implementations I will create them and
write my code from scratch I still have
all the functions that are required for
my application but the implementation
will be different so I can easily change
my backend from app right to some other
database this is very useful another
place where it's mainly used is in
testing so if you want to test a bunch
of
functions and you don't want to forget
which function to test out you can use
this abstract class and implement it and
if you're wondering why this is prefixed
with ie this is basically interface this
is an interface for the auth API class
so this is why we have the abstract
class it's very handy and you
understand its main purpose when you
shift the backend if you want to
anyways let's just delete all of that we
are not going to have this function
signature we are going to have it a bit
differently what is the difference well
this auth API is just containing upright
code there's nothing else going to be
present so we don't know if it's going
to be a success or a failure
and even if we know that we want to send
it to the controller that yeah this is
the
success so if it's a success this is the
data and if it's a failure what is the
error message
so for that we need to return two data
types as of now
that doesn't support returning to data
types
it's a work in progress I'll mention a
medium article where it shows that it
should be out in the mid of 2023
but as of now it's not possible
so what can we do
well we can install a package known as
FP Dot and if we install that
FP dot package will be able to return
two types of
data types
so if it's a success we are going to
send that if it's a failure we are going
to send another thing and that will help
us a lot
and it also provides us a bunch of
functions to handle those
success and error messages so if it's a
success it will give us a very useful
API that we can use
and bypass the
boilerplate code that we need to write
again and again if you don't understand
don't worry
I'll explain it to you right now so
suppose
we want to return a success and a
failure right so if it's a success I
want to return
the account of the user so whatever data
is present like the current account of
the user this is something apprite gives
us and if it's a failure I just want to
return a string so I can do that by
having either this is something given by
FP Dot and then if it's
success I want to return account
and if it's a failure then I want to
return string
so in case
so it will either return account or it
will return string that's the main
purpose and then we can have the sign up
process so we will have sign up and
obviously we need to require the email
and the password of the user so that we
can sign up the user so we'll have
required string email required string
password
and Avia
but this is obviously not going to be
either this is going to be future either
because app right
is going to connect with our backend so
upright client that we have the package
it will connect us with the
app right server
so it will take some time
that's why it's a future so we will have
future either account string because we
are going to use async in there right
this is a pretty big thing to write and
this will be happening even in login
function and several other functions we
don't want to continuously write such a
big type definition it's a time and
resource waste so what we can do instead
is create a new folder in lib called
core and this core folder is going to
contain all the essential things for
example we are going to have something
known as type definitions over here type
def dot dot and this is going to contain
all the type definitions
for our app
so the first type definition we can
create type definition like this type
definition is basically
creating our own type
like future either like them
so we have future
either which is equal to Future
and we'll pass in either just like we
did before but this time I made a
mistake previously
when it's a failure we'll return string
and if it's a success we are going to
return account
this is for the failure and this is for
the success not the other way around
then we'll import the FP dot package
and then we are going to return failure
and in case of success
we want success but what are these
failure and success classes so we are
going to create failure class first of
all so we have failure dot dot so we
left class failure
final string message
and final
string not strings stack Trace factories
so that you know the failure contains
the message what message needs to be
displayed and the stack trace and even
you you can even have the hash codes and
whatever but you're just going to have
two of them and we don't need the named
Constructor we are just going to have
positional Constructors over here
and we can mark this as a constant great
so we can go to the type definition
import failure package from core but
again in the core
we are going to have something known as
core dot dot
we are going to export failure dot dot
video in the export type definitions dot
dot
that's it
and now we'll import failure so let's
import
failure we are not importing code over
here because we are in the same folder
as of now
and for the success it really depends if
it's a success here you can see we have
to return an account but somewhere else
we'll have to return suppose a map or
some other data be
or some other data type app right has to
offer
so this really depends on where we are
using it so we can just do this
we can pass in a generic type T over
and then we can pass T over here
now if you don't understand this no
problem
I'll show it to you over here
now if we use future
either you can see we have this now the
sign up function has a type of future
either failure Dynamic this is exactly
what we had written away a future either
failure but this is now Dynamic why
because we have not mentioned anything
over here now if I mention string over
here the success type over here is now
string
since it continuously varies I have
mentioned the success type over here so
somewhere it can return account
somewhere it can return Maps somewhere
it can return string
and this function will have the
appropriate data type return correct now
let's create a few more type definitions
another type definition is Future
either void
which is equal to future either y
what does this mean
the success data type is void basically
if it's a success we don't want to
return anything we just want to let the
controller know that yeah it's a success
you can move forward
and another data type that we can have
is type definition future void not
future either void just future void
which is equal to Future
void this is basically eliminating the
usage of
future
generate
generic type but if you want you can
keep this otherwise you can just remove
this doesn't matter
so we can remove FP Dot from here we
don't need that because we are importing
type definition and we can even import
code or dot now since we have exported
type definition from code.package
cool
if you didn't understand
I'll again brief you through it
basically we have code. we have exported
type definition and failure Dot
now failure has this class which has a
string message and a stack Trace so that
you know if you want to debug we can
just do failure dot stack trees and it
will give us the correct structures and
then we have the type definition
where we have mentioned two types
and in case of success we have taken it
basically from wherever we are calling
it
now we have returned for success as
account aware but there's one thing to
note in app right there are two accounts
over here one is the account from
models so if we just
remove this and go to the account model
this is the account model and this is
basically a simple model the user uh
account class which requires have from
map two map functions just like we're
going to create our models
and it implements a model right
another one
is from the
service class
this allows us to authenticate and
manage a user account
so this is a service and this service
will help us to call sign up login
functions so we have get function over
here which will help us get the user
account it will get us the create method
which will help us to create an account
and update email and all of those so
this is related to service
but the other one was basically a model
that was returned to us
in case we want to get the username the
user email and all of those stuff you
can see that in the get function it is
returning to us models.account
models.account
is basically this model
right
so this was a difference and this is
very important to note because sometimes
you'll by mistake import the models and
the service both and you'll be confused
as to why we are not getting any
autocomplete features or error so if you
just import models you can see it gives
you an error because it is defined in
both of those places it's the same
account but one is from service and
other is a model what do we need in this
case when we sign up we should be
getting the model of the user right
when we want to sign up the user we'll
be using the account service let me just
simplify it when you want to sign up
or you want to
get the user account you'll be using
model dot account
and when you want to
you'll be using account which is coming
from apprite.dot or service account you
can just call it that and when
you want to access the user data then
you will be using model dot account
so we can prefix this as model so that
there's no confusion
and now we can have model dot account
aware because we are signing up the user
after signing up
after we creating
after signing up the user that means
after creating the user account
it will give us
a model account and we can return that
to the controller but when we want to
get but when we want to sign up or
create the user then we'll be using
account if it's not clear don't worry
we'll see the sun code right now
so I'll again have class auth API which
will Implement I auth API and we are
going to create one missing override it
has everything in it we'll call this
asynchronous
and now let me demonstrate the
difference to you exactly in terms of
code so we are going to have final
account over here which is a private
variable because whenever we do auth
API we should not be able to access
account like this right that's why we
are having a private variable
now we'll create a Constructor for this
which will be required
account
and we'll set this account variable to
account that's received from The
Constructor basically this is a private
variable we are requiring this account
which is a new variable which is not
private
because it named Constructor you cannot
have required this dot underscore
account it will give you an error so you
have this and you're finally assigning
the private account variable to the
account
variable that's coming from the
Constructor I hope that makes sense
the whole point of all of this is just
so that your class
has this as a private variable and its
instance is not available outside of the
class now to demonstrate the difference
to you between account model and account
service we can just have underscore
account which is the service one dot and
it will give you a bunch of options
create create Anonymous session this
means
account service is related to creating
and managing the
data in the server side in the app right
dashboard
but on the other hand if we have model
dot account
let me have model
you can see if we create an instance of
this we get email email verification
these are all the user related data
and that's what I'd said above if you
want to sign up or want to get user
account you can use
simply account which is service account
and if you want to access user related
data there's model.account I hope it's
clear now if you're not just play around
with it a little bit and you'll get a
great understanding of it
now we are just gonna after I catch
because there's a scope of error we
don't know it's not really an error it's
an exception
so we are putting this in a try catch
block and now we'll catch account Dot
create
and then we have three fields to pass an
email password which has already been
passed in and the user ID do we have the
user ID well no the user ID is a
randomly generated unique ID so we
cannot have that
so for apprite to create it uniquely
what I can do is
put a string and have unique type 10
over here
if I do this much
apprite will generate
a unique ID for this account
if there's another Syntax for it called
ID dot unique and this does the same
thing if you just click command full
stop you can see it just Returns the
same string we entered over here before
so you can use either of these
I'll just go ahead with this because
there's less scope of error even if
there is a little bit of error scope and
if you see a wire it's returning to us
an account and this account is
model.account we need to return this to
the controller so we can just have final
account which is equal to await
account.create
now we have account in our hand
we can just do return account right
no
this is because the data type
this is because the return data type of
this function is future either failure
or account
in case of success we have to do
something like this we have to return
right
and then pass in an account variable
inside of it this is something given by
FP dot itself so if it's success we let
them know that they are this is the
success variable and this is the data
you're getting when it's success if you
try to pass in something like a string
it will give you an error because
argument type string cannot be the
assigned to the parameter type account
so you need to pass in an account
variable over here
now in case of failure we'll just do
return left because it's a failure we'll
return left
and then we can pass in
e right no because in case of failure we
have to return failure class and then
we'll pass a message as e.2 string and
stack Trace
which we get from catch function here
we'll pass in the stack Trace as well
so this is it this is the function to
create
a user account in app right dashboard
but there's one other thing you can do
to improve the
exception handling over here which is
catching on upright exception
so we have on app right catch e stack
Trace
and then we are going to return left
over here as well but this time since
it's an upright exception this is of the
type upright exception not object
so we can access some methods given to
us like e Dot message and return that
but it's giving us an error because e
Dot message gives us a string and
failure
has
an acceptance of just string so we can
just have
something like this done
where we say some unexpected
error occurred
and the stack Trace is as it is
so if it is null we are going to return
some unexpected or error occurred
otherwise we are just going to have e
Dot message passed in
so this is the entire function I hope
you understood the difference between
account and model dot account if you
didn't you can rewind it I've spent a
lot of time on it already
I wouldn't like to spend more on it
anyways we are done with this
now let's use the provider package to
provide this class
now let's use the Riverport package to
provide this class so we can just have
final auth API
provider which is equal to provider
this provider class is given to us by
rebapod itself
and realpod gives us access to ref
so what is this thing provider lets us
provide a single instance which is
immutable so if you try to change the
value of this auth API provider later on
in the future
it will give you an error there are
multiple types of providers in riverpod
like provider this one future provider
stream provider
State provider and state Notifier
provider there are two other types as
well Notifier and async Notifier but we
are not going to use that in those in
this tutorial
so what is the difference between
provider State provider and all of them
provider basically provides a read-only
value you won't be able to change its
state anytime so if you return
this auth API class from your
and pass in the account which we will do
you cannot change the value to return
something else later on in the app
it will just be a read-only value
State provider and state Notifier
provider help us to change the value
later on in the
app we are going to take a look at them
but for now
let's concentrate at provider another
two types that I mentioned future
provider and stream provider we are
going to use them extensively in this
application because apprite is all about
Futures and streams
other question that you might have is
why are we using provider here why can't
we just use auth API class
like this
everywhere right now I will agree with
you you can use that but with provider
it becomes better in bigger application
because you don't have to create an
instance so suppose you have to instance
auth API class over here
so if you use this in some place you'll
have to also import account
provider
and now if you have to create account
like this
then you'll have to also pass in the
client and for the client you'll again
have to pass in client like this
there's a lot of things to do and even
in the client you'll have to pass in
suppose like the end point if you want a
different tree or sell sign if you want
it differently
there's a lot of work to do so
instead of doing all of that we are
going to create separate providers for
each one of them including auth API
provider you don't want to include this
auth API class every single time you use
it right it is a lot of code to write
provider will minimize that differently
also provider caches all of this so it
won't create a new instance of this auth
API everyone else every single time it
will just cache it and give it to us so
that helps in memory
efficiency as well so now that you have
understood this we can go in the core
and create something known as providers.
this is going to contain all the upright
related providers or any other provider
in our application
that is not related to a class for
example this auth API provider is
related to this auth API class so if you
want to delete auth API at a certain
point we can just delete this file and
everything related to auth API goes away
so we are not going to have auth API
provider in providers. we are going to
have common kind of providers which is
final app right client provider
which is equal to
provide a
ref ref should be small
this ref is basically provider f it will
help us to interact with other providers
you'll see an example of it in just a
minute let me just first complete this
now we are going to create client
variable so we have client client equal
to client this upright client provider
will be used in suppose account provider
and database provider in a real-time
provider all of the functionalities that
apprite has to offer
so it's important for it to be created
as a provider then we can just return
client Dot set endpoint and we already
have the endpoint with us don't forget
we have apprite constants so we can just
return its endpoint so we have app right
constants
dot endpoint
dot set project
and we need to pass in the project ID
over here so that it can make the
connection with upright
dashboard
so what is the project ID we have stored
that so we have upright constants dot
project ID
dot set self signed
status
of which should be true this is for the
self sign certificate and will be used
only for development this code
can be found on their
documentation or when you complete the
platform part we had this all of this
written so you can copy it from there I
just wanted to demonstrate what every
function means so I just rewrote it
now we will create final
app right account provider
so we have account
provider which is equal to provider ref
and now we will return
account right and this account should be
from upright.not the model one remember
that
I've explained to you why
now we need to pass in the client so we
need this
so what we can do now
is final client
is equal to ref dot watch
app right client provider
so this is where ref helps us I said it
can help you to interact with
other provider
so this ref is helping me to interact
with other provider in the app right
account provider
I'll repeat that this ref will help me
to interact with other providers using
ref dot watch or ref dot read the
difference between ref dot watch is that
it continuously watches for any changes
in provider
and ref dot read is just a single time
thing so it will just read it once the
first time and then it will stop
keeping track on it
I'm keeping watch because in case I want
to change any of the dependencies here
and if I click on save it will
automatically show that on the screen
with the ref dot read that's not
possible we'll have to restart the
entire app from here
but you can use any of them it really
doesn't matter
unless you don't want the hot reload
feature or the hot restart feature
so this is the app right account
provider we'll go back here now
we need to get account so we can just do
ref again and again dot read or dot
watch I'm going to do watch and I'm
going to watch the app right
account provider
if you do app right client provider it
will throw an error
because it gives the type of client
we don't want client we want app right
account provider
so just to minimize the complexity if I
just cut this paste it over here so we
have final account is equal to ref.watch
and check this this has the type of
account
so watching this will give us the type
of account now we can take this account
and paste it over here
so we have the auth API ready with us
and that is why we are using providers
it minimizes the work to be done by a
lot so anyways let's get started with
the controller part we have created the
API we are just having upright calls
over here
now in the auth controller dot I'll call
this function
and print the name and the email of the
user so that we know that yeah whatever
was done was correct and then later on
we'll check in the app right dashboard
as well
and after that we can test this on
Android emulator as well because there
is a certain problem in Android which
you'll face so the auth controller over
here is going to be called auth
controller
but this is not all it this upright
controller is going to extend something
known as a state node F5 as I already
mentioned riverpod has multiple
providers the second one is State
Notifier provider provider was used when
you wanted to provide an instance of the
class or you wanted to provide a
read-only value a value which cannot be
updated but with auth cont this state
node a fire we will expose a value which
can be updated
and which can also be read
so this is an upgrade over the normal
provider and here we are getting an
error because we have extended state
notifiers are press command full stop
create a Constructor to call Super I'll
remove this
because super should be called over here
and what is all of the super and stuff
so here in the state Notifier you might
see that we need to mention a type a
generic type what is the value that will
be changed and for us it is a Boolean
value why because we want to add
something known as is loading so if our
app is loading so suppose we click on
the sign up button and the data is being
stored to apprite server the loading
indicator should show up in that time
and that's why we have the Boolean value
of its loading
so initially the is loading part is
going to be false this Boolean value
indicates is loading variable for us
initially it should be false
now whenever the user creates an account
so we'll avoid sign up
and this controller
is going to require string
name String email
not name sorry it will require a
password so we can have email
password
and also build context
why build context because in case of
error we want to show a snack bar and
the Syntax for snack bar is
scaffoldmessenger dot of context it uses
build context
so we need the build context but note
that we can use build context and
everything inside of a controller
because we don't want to test it but we
cannot use this inside auth API because
this class is what we want to test of
course I'm not including that in this
tutorial but
controllers
are not tested in this application only
auth apis are or anything related to
apis are so that's why I can use build
context here however if you want to test
the controller as well you'll have to
require you'll have to remove the build
context call
anyways since I'm not testing this I can
have build context over here
and now what I'll do is State equal to
true what is State equal to true well
state is basically of the type Boolean
and it is Boolean because I mentioned
over here Boolean
state is basically is loading value you
can consider
state
as is loading
it's just named a state because this is
what a riverpod has to offer
but this is basically our is loading
variable so right now when the user
clicks on sign up button this function
will get triggered and when this
function gets triggered is loading
becomes true so we start to show the
loading indicator and then we start a
process what is the process well we just
call final response is equal to a weight
so we need a thing why are we awaiting
it because we have something known as
auth API
this thing exactly we need to call this
so that we can
create a user account
so here I'm just going to have an
instance of auth API and it's going to
be similar a private variable just like
this one
and we are going to require this as a
named argument so we have required auth
API auth API
and underscore all the API will be equal
to auth API
we have known this already
now we can just use underscore auth API
DOT sign up after we do sign up we have
to pass an email and password we have
already passed that because you're
getting this from the function
parameters
now if you hover over this res
it is of the type either failure account
now how do we get
if it's
failure value how do we get the value if
it's success value how do we get the
success value well for that
we can call response dot fold this is
one good method FP dot provides us so
that we can efficiently handle
a failure and a success L is basically
the left value and R is the right value
so our left value is a failure class and
right value is the account variable or
the account model
so in case of success in Failure we want
to display a snack bar in case of
success right now I just want to print r
dot name r dot email whatever
and in case of failure
um what do we have to do well I want to
have a snack bar so I can just have
scaffoldmessenger dot of snack bar and
all of those stuff but it's a lot of
code to write so I'm just going to
create one function for it so that I can
reuse it every single time
so you can go to the core folder create
a file called useless dot dot and here
have your first function which is Chino
snack bar it is going to have multiple
utility functions as well like other
functions
pick images pick image all of those
functions but we'll create them as and
when we need them so for the snow show
snack bar we are going to require two
things one is the build context and
another is the content
and here we are going to have scaffold
messenger dot of context dot show snack
bar
and here we'll pass in the snack bar all
the code that's required to create a
snack bar
this is all that we need now I can take
this I've not created a class for this
because it's a normal utility file I
just want to call this function
without calling the class
that's why I have created this as a
global function
now I can just call show snack Barrow
here pass in the build context right
here and the content which is the text
and the text is l dot message since it's
a failure class I can access the message
property on it but of course if there's
some problem we can also print
l dot stack trace and it will give us
the entire trace of where the error is
happening and all of those stuff
now I'll create a provider for this auth
controller class
but just creating a provider is useless
because we are extending it from a state
Notifier so we have something known as a
state Notifier provider let's create
that but before creating that you might
think that it's a lot of boilerplate
code to write even with riverpot
to minimize that you can go to the
extensions tab in vs code and search for
riverpod Snippets
and you can go over here and install the
one by Robert Browning
after you install that
you can go to the auth controller
just type State Notifier provider and it
will give you
the snippet for the code now you can
type the name so the name of the
provider is auth controller provider
now you have to mention the type of
error because
earlier it could Auto detect the type
Auto auto detected that this is of the
type auth API with State notify provider
it cannot do that
it can detect one type but we have to
pass in two things first is the type of
the class that we are returning from the
state Notifier provider we are going to
return the auth controller class from
the state notify provider
and another is the type that we have
mentioned over here
which is Boolean so we have Boolean
and now we can return auth controller
and that's it
now we need to get instance of the auth
API class and I hope you know how to do
that you can just do ref dot watch or
API provider and
we are done we have created a system of
efficient technique so that we can just
do some simple lines
and it will work for us so we created a
state Notifier provider because we had
extended it from State nodifier we typed
in the class the auth controller class
and then we passed in the Boolean data
type because that's what we had passed
in over here
if you remove this Boolean
it gives you an error over here because
you'll have to remove that and you'll
have to pass in Dynamic over here
because if you don't mention anything
it's dynamic
but we want it to be Boolean so that we
get nice autocomplete features later on
what is this later on well it's in the
login view itself so if I go to the sign
up view sorry
and call a function
so we'll have void on sign up
and we'll have ref
but we cannot use ref aware why because
there's nothing like ref variable or
anything layer so what we have to do is
come over here press command
press command over here
come over here press option if you're on
Mac
and select all of these three things
stateful widget State and State and pass
consumer to it
now
click on command full stop and import
the flutter evapod Library we have
converted the stateful widget to a
consumer stateful widget
this consumer stateful widget will give
us access to widgetress what is widget
ref well we saw provider ref provider
ref helps us to interact provider with
the provider but widget ref helps us
from widget to a provider so now I have
again access to ref why do I have access
to ref over here because consumer State
gives us access to something known as
ref
if you just come over here you can see
it has something known as widget ref
so I can use that and call read method
on it whenever we want to call a
function from a provider we'll always
use read
you can get a more description over here
reads a provider without listening to it
avoid calling read inside build if the
value is only used for events event is
what I said when you read it you only
have to call functions on it if you use
this instead if you use ref inside of
build function not in any functions if
you use this inside of build function
you need to use ref.watch if you're
using it in any of the functions like
over here you have to use
ref.read now what do I want to read I
want to read auth controller provider
don't do auth API provider because I
said you cannot have auth API files
inside of
a UI file so we have auth controller
provider dot Notifier when you use
nodifier you get access to the class
instance
and then you can use the sign up
function however if you don't use
Notifier
you won't get access to any of the
methods why let's see the difference if
we use final risks is equal to this and
however this this is of the type Boolean
why
when we did this with provider it gave
us the instance of auth controller
provider or the auth controller class
right but when using res it gives us
Boolean well that's because of the
difference between
provider and state Notifier provider a
North controller we have used State
Notifier provider
when we just do ref dot read or
ref.watch auth controller provider it
gives us a Boolean value which is the is
loading value
but when you want to get instance of the
class we have to use ref Dot
read auth controller provider dot
Notifier I know it's a bit overwhelming
but as and when we build more functions
and use more of these Riverport
techniques you'll understand why we are
doing what we are doing
and you'll get an intuition of when to
use what
so as of now we'll just use dot Notifier
because we want to get instance of the
class if you hover over this this is of
the type auth controller now and now I
can call sign up on this method
now we have to pass an email so I'll
pass an email controller.txt password
will be passwordcontroller dot text
and the build context
build context is Prov provided in the
consumer State itself it's like the
state property but it has context as
well as widget ref with it
now I can take this on sign up function
go down and put it in the on done button
so whenever the done button is clicked I
want this to run and it should create
something for us
now before running the app there's one
last thing we need to do go to the
main.file and wrap my app widget with
provide a scope provider scope is
another widget provided by flutter
riverpod package
this provider scope keeps track of all
the providers that are declared because
these providers are declared globally in
our applications
you can see that it's declared outside
of the class
this provider scope will keep track of
each one of them and if you are afraid
of global variables
like
they can be updated from anywhere in our
app and there are a lot of concerns with
global variables don't worry about it
because these providers are immutable
so now I can take this constant put it
beside provide a scope
and remove the unused import of login
View
if you don't put this provider scope it
will give you an error in the debug
console now let's restart the app and
see what we are getting so I'll just
sign up the user so I'll pass in the
test one two three at the rate gmail.com
pass in the password as test one two
three click on done and it doesn't work
the reason for that is in the rounded
small button we have taken the void
callback on tap but we have not added
that anywhere so we need to wrap this
chip with a widget known as Inkwell you
can also use gesture detector instead
but Inkwell will give the nice flash
effect that I need
and then I have on Tab
and in the on Tab instead of passing an
empty function I'll just pass in ontap
which is from The Constructor now I'll
restart the entire application
come over here and start so test at the
read gmail.com pass in test123 click on
done
and still nothing happens here you can
see it's giving us an error missing
plugin exception no implementation found
for all of this
whenever you get this error this is
probably because you've added a new
package a new dependency to perspect.aml
file but you have not restarted the
entire app so you need to restart it
without debugging and now after this is
done let's try it again
alright so our app is now complete let's
come over here pass in the email which
is test
at the gmail.com password test123
click on done
and you can see invalid password
password must at least be eight
characters so I'll just pass in four
which makes it eight characters and then
click on done
no error
and here you can see it's giving us
nothing well that's because
if we go to the auth controller
we have printed the name but there is no
username
there's user email so you have to print
in the email and now let's see if I try
to do it again it should give me an
error because the user already has been
created so if I click on done a user
with the same email already exists in
your project so I'll just have a
different email and then click on done
and here you can see we get the correct
email
now if we go to the app right dashboard
as well
then click over here go to
authentication tab
we have two users created testavery
gmail.com and test one at the gmail.com
if you
maximize the screen you can see the
status the email is not verified
there's no name there's email there's no
phone number you can enter the new
password from the dashboard
the user preferences the key and the
value you can have
the objective for this is written over
here you can read it and you can delete
the user as well
the user ID is also over here and this
is a uniquely generated user ID I told
you it will generate
uniquely if I just mention unique
in the auth API
right here
and if you just paste it you can see
this is a different user ID a randomly
generated one and this will differ from
the test at the rate gmail.com so we can
be sure about it all right now that the
user has been created and everything
works the next step is to log in the
user with the same email and password if
the user exists so we have to create a
function for login but even before that
there's one thing if I click on done
there's no indication of loading
indicators even though in the auth API
we have set in the auth controller sorry
just said state is equal to True is
loading is true
so why is it not showing well because we
have not watched it so in the sign up
view we have to go here get the is
loading value how are we going to get
this we've already seen that we have ref
dot watch
auth controller provider
now if you hover over this this is of
the type Boolean because it's the is
loading value so if the
data is being loaded what do we want to
do we want to show a loading indicator
to do that we are going to create
a new widget in common called as
loading underscore page dot dot
we're going to import material Dot we're
going to have a stateless widget called
loader
which is going to return a center child
circular progress indicator
and this is going to be a constant
and this is the loader widget we are
going to use but why have I named this
loading page this is because we are
going to create another stateless widget
called loading page
we're going to extend the stateless
widget but this time we are going to
wrap it with a scaffold and in the body
we are going to have a loader
and this is going to be a const scaffold
this loading page will be required
in main.dot file when we want to show
the loading page this is just a loader
which can be used in some other pages
but we want our own page of loading to
show up we'll use this
so here we can just have loader
like this so if it is loading we'll get
a constant load up otherwise we have all
of this
and now you can see we are getting the
loading indicator continuously why are
we getting this loading indicator well
that's because we had clicked the button
the
is loading state has started so in the
controller we have state is equal to
true but we have not put state is equal
to false anywhere
that's why it continuously keeps on
loading so here we have to have state is
equal to false
now if we restart the app pass and test
at the rate gmail.com
test123 4 click on done it gives a
loading indicator but as soon as there's
no error or there is an error
it will stop the loading indicator
so I hope you have understood the entire
process we have state Notifier provider
we have state Notifier we create an
account using auth API
we start the state so is loading is set
to true
if a set if is loading is set to true
and we are on the sign up view
we are constantly listening to it using
ref.watch if you just do ref dot read it
will not work for you you have to do
ref.watch ref.read is strictly
prohibited by using
riverpod in the build context
or the build function
now whenever is loading values changes
we'll check is loading if the variable
is loading then show a loader otherwise
the entire widget tree
I hope this process was understood if
it's not I would recommend you to watch
this entire thing or Analyze This code
because this is the very foundations
that we are going to use in literally
every single file
if you're overwhelmed by all of this
don't worry when we create more files
when we create more functions
you'll get a hang of when to use what
and I'll be sharing my thoughts on the
same every single time
so anyways now that this loading part is
also done we are going to create the
login function which is very similar to
the
sign up function so in the iot API we
are going to create a login function now
so similar to the sign up function we
are going to create the login function
here but yeah it's not going to return
account it's going to return something
known as session
whenever you log in you get a session
and whenever you sign up you get the
user account
that's how apprite works
so here let's create the missing
implementation and actually I'm just
going to copy something from the
sign up function here so I'm just going
to copy this entire thing because
everything is very similar I would
recommend you to write this so that you
get a practice I've already written it
before so I don't find the need to
practice more
but anyways we have the Creator
but this is for sign up to sign in you
have to do create session
and create email session you have to
pass in the email and the password
that's all
here you could have passed in the name
attribute as well so that when you do r
dot name in the auth controller here you
don't get blank space but we just having
email and password name is going to be
saved in the database this is the
authentication console nothing is
getting saved in the database
if you just come to the app right
console this is the database part and
nothing is being stored over here
everything is being stored in the
authentication tab as of now
so here we have created the email
session this gives us a session so let's
call this session and we will return
that session
so when we do create
it will sign up for us
it will just create an account in the
upright console but it will not log you
in to log you in you have to do create
email session
and that's all that's needed for login
function pretty similar now we can go to
the auth controller and declare this
so I'll just avoid login and it's going
to be very similar to this so let's just
copy this
paste it in here
this is going to be async then we are
going to have all of this stuff as well
so let's just paste it right up but this
is going to be called login
the state will be true but we are going
to call auth api.login
will pass in the email we'll pass in the
password set state to false show snack
bar in case of error but here you can
see we are getting a session so we can't
use r dot email let's see what
properties it has to give us if we do
this you can see there are lots of
things but none of that will be useful
for us except the user ID so let's see
if user ID is correct or not so I'm just
going to go ahead restart the app
oh actually before doing that we have to
go to the login view create something
similar to what we had done for the sign
up view right we can just copy all of
this function stuff
go to the login View
paste it in and then we have on login
yeah that's pretty much it now we also
need to convert all of this to a
stateful widget or a consumer stateful
widget sorry so we can paste that in
import flood riverpod Library
import auth controller provider and then
call Dot Login
now I'll copy this function
go down below and add it to ontap and
also have the is loading variable just
like we had before so if it's loading
then we'll have ref dot watch
controller provider and that's reaching
pretty much it if we do Notifier
remember we get the instance of the
class we don't want instance of the
class we want the Boolean value which is
the state value but if you want to do
dot Notifier you can do dot Notifier dot
state which will give you the exact same
thing
now I'll copy this as loading
put it in the body
and if it's loading then I can have
constant loader otherwise my widget tree
is just fine
now I'll restart it
and see if it's working so I'll go to
the login view I'll first try an email
that I haven't registered gmail.com
test123 and click on done
invalid password password must be at
least for eight whatever that is then
we'll click on done invalid credentials
please check email and password that
means it's okay now we can have test at
the gmail.com click on done here we have
the user ID let's see if it matches by
opening the app right console going to
test at the rate gmail.com
copying the user ID
and seeing it over here
5B is there that means it's the same
thing
that means our login is also working
so we completed login very quickly we
just have to understand how signup works
and login is very simple
so the now the next thing is whenever
the user logs in
we have to navigate them to the home
screen
so we can close all the folders
in the features create another feature
called home
create a new folder called View and
create the first view which is the home
view dot dot file we'll import material.
import a stateless consumer widget
called home View
import flutter everpod Library put in a
scaffold and see what we get so we can
go to the auth control layer so whenever
we log in
actually let's come here whenever the
user signs up we cannot directly send
them to the home screen because if we do
that
and
when we try to purchase the state the
state won't be persisted because State
persistence will be done by
something like this account dot get is
not equal to null so whatever we do this
account dot get
if it's not equal to null
then we'll show the sign up screen
otherwise the login screen uh the home
screen
so here we'll have home screen otherwise
the login screen but account.get will
only have the account when the user
creates an email session so we have
created an email session over here only
then the account dot get has some value
in it if we just do dot create account
doesn't have any value in it it's just
created it in the app right dashboard
but account variable doesn't hold any
value
only after doing email session create
the account value
account has some value in it
so what can we do
well after signing up the user what I
want to do
if it's a success then I'll just push
them
to login screen dot route so we have
login View
dot route but in case of failure
we are going to show the snack bar and
also over here we are going to show a
snack bar that account has been created
please login
the same thing will happen in login view
as well whenever the user creates an
email session now we have
account has some value in it so I'll
just say navigator dot push home view
dot route so here I'm just going to
create static route
and just copy all of the material page
thing from sign up view so we can copy
all of this from here now we can have
home view passed in and we're done here
we'll just pass in home view as well
now this looks cool so whenever you log
in we go back to the home screen
so let's try
right now
we are in the login screen
I'll pass in the email
and password then click on done
and I shift to the home screen
but here's the catch but here's the
catch if I try to restart the
application
we are back to the sign up screen that's
because in the main.dot file we have
decided that the first screen that
should show up is the sign up for you
but what I want to do is if the account
is not null then I want to show up the
login screen
and how can I do that
well as I said
in the auth API we are going to create
current user accounts account dot get so
we can just have future
model dot account which can be null
current user account
I'll create a missing implementation for
it I'll take this and put it at the top
now if you're wondering why I haven't
used future either I've used future
directly that's because we are going to
put this in a future provider and future
provider can handle the errors for us
you'll see that later on but the point
is since we are using future provider we
have not used future either
just keep that in mind for now later on
when we add future provider you'll get
to know more
and for now we are also going to have
all of this try and catch block
but we'll remove all of this this is not
needed the point over here is just
having a try and catch block so
we want to return
await
account dot get
and we'll also put asynchronous function
here so basically we'll do account.get
it will give us the future account which
is the model dot account we'll await it
and return it if you don't want to await
it it's still fine it will still work
so you can do this as well because we
are returning future account at the end
of the day
but in case of error we are not going to
have any stack Trace so let's remove
that
in case of any error we are going to
return null so we can return null over
here and return null here as well
that's right this is
nullable basically if account.get does
not have any value that means that the
user is not logged in maybe they've just
signed up
even then
it will have no value but this doesn't
return a nullable return data type so it
will throw an upright exception that the
user has not logged in and that's when
we will send out null and later on we
can just check if current user account
is not null
if it is not null that means account.get
has some value if it has some value we
can show them the home view otherwise we
can just show them signup View
so now we can go to the auth controller
I can go at the top remove everything
from here and have Future model dot
account obviously we need to import that
account model
so I can have upright models.dot and
import them as model
and then we have more Future model dot
account current
user and will return
auth API dot current user account
not current user current user account
and this has to be nullable don't forget
that
and now we will create future provider
with the help of the snippet code that I
made you install in the extensions tabs
Riverport Snippets we can just do future
provider
and then have current
user account provider
we don't have to mention the type and
future provider as well
we can remove the async and just have
final
auth controller since we want to call
the auth controller so we'll have auth
controller and you know what will be a
ref dot watch auth controller provider
dot Notifier don't forget the Notifier
otherwise it will give you the is
loading value
right and now you can just do return
auth controller Dot
current user and since this is of The
Future model future account type it will
work fine now if you hover over this
this is of the type future provider
account which is nullable now that we
have this done we can go to the main.dot
file
and in the home
we want to use ref now how do I convert
stateless widget
to something that can give me widget ref
we did that for the stateful widget we
just added consumer before it right
consume a stateful widget but here we
have to use consumer widget not consumer
stateless widget so we can have consumer
widget
we have already imported riverpod
because of Provider scope and here we
will have widget ref
it's not
there in the state here because there is
no State class here and stateful widget
we had State present we had consumer
State present
but here we have nothing like that so
widget ref is provided to us in the
build functions
parameters now I can just do ref dot
watch
current user account provider dot when
and when there's a data
there will be user so we'll do something
we'll return based on that then we'll
have error and stack Trace so I'll just
prefix this with an st
and we have to return suppose an error
page so we'll have to create an error
page and we already have loading so I
can use loader but if we use loader in
material app it will be a problem why
because we don't have scaffold yet
it will give you a very ugly solution of
loading bar what I want to use instead
is a const loading page because we have
already added a scaffold to it
so it will show up the loader in a nice
page we'll also remove the sign up View
and let's see what we have to work on we
have to create an error page so I can go
to the common have error underscore page
dot dot also
you have to make sure that in common we
export
loading page we export
error page
yep and in the error page now I'll
import material dot I'll create a
stateless widget
called error text
return a center child text and we need
error for that so we can just have final
string error
and we'll require this through the
Constructor this is all basic concept
that we have seen earlier since error
texture is going to be reusable we need
this to have a Constructor value and
then we can just pass that in error
now we also need to create another
stateless widget called error page
similar to the Loading page we are going
to have scaffold body and then pass in
the error text over here this is
basically
a wrapper around erotic so that it can
be scaffolded now we also need error
again so we'll pass that in have
required this dot error
take this error password in and it's
done great now we can come to the main
dot dot
return the error page over here
pass in the error
but it's giving us an error that's quite
a thing because we want to use two
string over here this requires a value
of string and this is of the type object
now in the data will be our main logic
so we want to check if the user account
is null
or not so if user is not null if the
user is not null that means that the
user has logged in if the user has
logged in we just want to show the home
View
but if the user has not logged in so we
can put else but since we are using
return
we can just do this return constant sign
up view that means that the user has not
logged in now if I restart the app we
should be landing in on the home View
and that's because
we had logged in once right upright
remembers that and the user account has
some value in it if you try to print the
user value you'll see that so we can
just do print user instance of account
is there so we can just pass in the
email
and we have test other gmail.com so we
can remove this now restart the app and
state persistence is also completed but
we are not done with authentication part
yet because whenever the user signs up
we just don't want to create a user in
the authentication tab we also want to
do that in the databases tab in the
users collection that we have to now
create
so basically we want to save the user
data to app right database so let's get
started with it right now so we are
going to start off by creating a new API
here which is the user API dot dot file
and here similar to the auth API we are
going to create an abstract class so we
will have abstract class I user API now
why is this different because this will
contain all the user API related calls
for example we're going to have save
user data get user data update user data
getting the latest user profile data all
of those stuff those are very different
from auth API because even if there is
no authentication and somehow we need to
store the user data this will be handy
it is independent from the auth API
that's the whole concept if you don't
want anything just delete it and it
shouldn't cause problems in any files or
it should be less work to do in some
other file now in this case we are going
to have this so our first thing is
future either void
save user data
and we are going to have this
then we are going to create the user
API
which is going to implement
I user API
and now we can create its implementation
but before creating the implementation
we have the save user data but what user
data do I have to save I'm not getting
that so I want to get it from the
parameters here but manually getting
required string email password all of
that stuff what I can do instead is
create a model for this so I can just go
to the lib folder create a new folder
now called models and have the first
model which is a user model creator
now this user model is going to have a
bunch of properties and this user model
is exactly what we are going to store in
app right as well so let's note down all
of the properties that might be required
in this user model first is the email
then is the name
we are not going to store the user's
password in this database because it's
not going to be encrypted over here we
want the user's password to be encrypted
all the time
so I'm not saving password here then we
need other things and let's write down
all the things that we require we'll
require a list of string of followers
why is it a list of string of followers
because we are going to store
the followers in the form of their uids
uids is the user's unique ID that we
saved earlier and we saw earlier in the
upright console as well
so we're going to store that as the
followers so we'll be able to get the
list length and all of those stuff with
this and another thing we need is
following similar to the followers one
it's going to contain a list of uids of
the user
following then we are going to have a
final string of profile picture so what
is the profile picture going to look
like then we also have the banner
picture right
that will show up in the user profile
just above the profile picture
then
we need to store the uid of the user
then we have the bio of the user
bio is the description
and finally we have a Boolean of is
Twitter blue so if they've subscribed to
Twitter blue or not so this will decide
if they should have a blue tick mark Or
Not beside the name
and now
I want to create a Constructor a two map
from map functions for this so I can
just click over here and create a data
class generate data class how am I
getting this option if you go to the
extensions Tab and type dot data class
generator
you'll get the extension on this so
install them or install one of them and
just click over here and generate a data
class and it will generate it correctly
for you
now we can remove dot convert let's
remove this go down remove the from Json
to Json function we don't need that
because we are not making API calls we
already have apparite API we are going
to use that app right client
to save data to database
so we don't need to encode and decode
and all of the do all of that stuff
in the two map
now let's go through the functions that
it creates first is the Constructor and
since all of the fields are final I can
put this as a constant and mark the
class as immutable
so it creates a Constructor where every
field is required that's good now we
want to copy with
now we have the copy with function this
copy with function will be used
whenever we want to copy
the class Fields with another field so
example we have some user model and that
user model is something like this so
user model user
is equal to user model and there are a
bunch of fields like name is present
like Revan and all of those stuff
right now I want to update the name of
the user so I can just do user dot copy
with ignore the
case sensitivity and then I can just do
name as a new name so I can just have
ravan like this
so what's happening over here
is basically all the other fields remain
the same but but the name we are trying
to change can be changed to this
function
we need copy with function because all
of the fields over here are final if
they're final that means they are
immutable the values cannot be changed
once they are made so I cannot do user
dot name is equal to ravan like this
it will give an error and that's why we
need this copy with function
then we have two map function basically
whenever we have user model created and
we call user.2 map it will convert all
the fields into a map format we have a
map over here and we just do result dot
add all and it will add email email name
name like this
then we have from map now in two map
there's one change to be made we have to
remove this field because we don't have
to
store the uid of the user on app right
because app right automatically creates
a unique ID for us so we don't have to
create another one we can just have
it present in from map and in from map
we are basically getting the map and
we're converting it into a model
and over here you see we have map at uid
but we don't have any field like map at
uid over here right we have removed the
call because app right automatically
creates the ID so to fix that I can just
have slash
dollar ID why
because when apprite automatically
creates the ID
it is stored with the name as dollar ID
and if we just do dollar ID you can see
it gives us an error it thinks this is a
variable which is trying to get stored
and there is no variable named ID
but if we put slash it will get to know
that we need to ignore this string
interpolation
and
just use dollar ID over here basically
this will retrieve the automatically
generated ID app right gives us and
we're going to do this for literally
every user model that we create
and then we have the two string function
so while debugging if you want to check
the user model if we put user model.2
string it will give us in the print
command in the terminal something like
instance of user model but I want to get
to see what user model is there What
fields are there so I can just overwrite
the tostring method so that I can show
everything else and then we have the
identity property so basically we won't
be using this at all in our application
so you can remove this but basically
what it does is check if two user models
are the same thing or not
and it does this by checking each and
every field
and seeing if their properties are equal
or not
so this was a user model now in save
user data function
I'm going to have this user model
created
now I can create one missing override
for this and now to create
something in database we always have to
have a try and on app right exception
catch block
with E and F T
catch e s t we have already looked at
all of this before
and now how do I create apprites now how
do I create a new document
in apprise database so to do that I have
to import something known as databases
which is a private variable DB now I'm
just going to have user API required
databases
DB
and set underscore DB equal to DB right
now I can take this underscore DB put it
in the try block and have DB Dot create
document you can see it's very intuitive
we want to create a document it gives us
a create document function now we need
to pass in the database ID do we have
the database ID stored in upright
constants yep we do so we can just have
app right
constants dot database ID now collection
ID
collection ID can be users right no this
is not how apprite works it shouldn't
have collection ID as the name of the
collection there is a collection ID
given to it so for that we have to go to
the database we are in click on create a
collection and pass in users now I can
click on create copy The Collection ID
go to Upright constants
and create static constant string users
collection
equal to this thing right here
so I can come to the user API just pass
in
upright constants
Dot
users collection then we want to pass in
the document ID which can be ID dot uni
right we don't know the document ID
and this document ID is also going to be
the ID of the user now finally we need
to pass in data and data is user model
dot to map
we had created two map function in the
user model and that's what we are using
now we can await this
store it so we have final document is
equal to this
we can also put async over here
and then return write null so everything
goes fine
yep we don't have to return anything so
we can also remove this final document
equal to because we don't have to store
it
in case of failure though we have to
return left
failure will pass an e Dot message
otherwise some unexpected error
occurred
and stack Trace will be St
we can put the same thing for the catch
block as well
but your e.2 string and this part is not
required
great now save user data function is
also created let's create a provider for
this I'll let you try this on your own
pause the video and try it on your own
so that you start developing the
confidence to do it on your own
if you are able to do it great we just
have to create a provider like user
API provider
then we can have provider and we'll
return this user API class now we need
to pass in the database to get the
database of course
we'll have to create a new provider in
providers.dot which is final app right
database provider
we created one for account we created
one for client now it's the time for
database so if you get confused on when
to create provider if I have to create a
provider or not you just have to ask
yourself is this a dependency if it's a
dependency you have to create a provider
as it will help you in testing
so yeah upright databases is a new
dependency
and that's why it's being stored over
your we are not creating an instance for
this we're directly injecting this in
our class
so here we can just have return
databases
now we need to pass in the client so we
can get the client like this pass in the
client and we are done
and in the DB we'll pass in ref.watch
app right database provider
that's it
user API is now created
now I have to go to the auth controller
import the user API here so we have user
API underscore user API
we'll require this so we'll have
required user API user API
and then we'll have underscore user API
equal to
user API
just what you have done before here it
gives us an error because user API is
required what do you think will come
here exactly where F dot watch user API
provider
now we can scroll down
and let's think what we want to do
whenever the user signs up we want to
store that data in the database but when
the user logs in do we want to store the
data no because the user just has to log
in he has no data that we have to store
we have already stored that in the sign
up process so we just have to do it over
here so what we'll do is
create a user model here I said user
model is not going to be created in user
API or any of the conversions are not
going to take place it's purely for app
right
so that's why
we are creating the user model here
so user model user model is equal to
user model now we'll pass in the email
now we have to get the name the name in
the sign up process is going to be
extracted from the email only so we can
go to the utilities dot dot
create a function that will return to us
a string
of get
name from email we'll pass in the name
and now we'll just do return
actually we'll get an email here right
we'll get email and we'll just do email
dot split
by at the rate and take the first
element of the list basically what we
are trying to do is if I get Revan
ranawat the rate gmail.com
I'm just going to split this email
by at the rate so we'll get a list which
which is something like this it will
have rivandranavat at first
and at the read gmail.com
as the second element
so after we get this list by doing split
by at the rate
we'll take the first element which is
because that's the name of the user
right
so we get the first element and we
return that so we get a string
now I can just put your get name from
email pass in the email followers in the
initial part are going to be empty list
even following is going to be empty less
profile picture is going to be empty
Banner pick is going to be empty
uid
is going to be empty because it doesn't
really matter because you're not doing
Dot 2 map uid we have removed two map
uid property bio is also going to be
empty and is Twitter blue false
obviously when the user signs up why
will we give them Twitter blue
and of course we'll put both of them as
constants
now I can take this user model and pass
it to user API dot save user data
pass in the user model now let's see
what we get we get future either and all
of those stuff so I can just have final
res is equal to await save user data but
we're getting this error because this
function is not asynchronous so make
this function asynchronous
we get result now we can again do
result.fold but not to get confused with
the previous result we can name this
final result 2 and we can do result 2.4
if it's a failure then we want to show a
snack bar
with l dot message and if it's a success
we can copy this
go to the right value and paste this end
R doesn't return to us anything so we
can mark this as underscore but
basically what we did was created a user
model
so that we could store all of this data
in the database then we can have user
API dot save user data which saves it to
upright and then we check if it's a
failure if any error occurred if any
error occurred show that in a snack bar
otherwise we can just go to the login
view and say that the account has been
created try to log in
easy now we can restart the entire app
and it will work now this is the beauty
of separating your code into separate
layers
you see we don't have to go to the view
file at all we had all the work related
to the database and user creation user
model creation all of that was done
between controller and repository we
didn't even have to touch the UI file
this is what makes the code more robust
if you have a work in certain file you
only do that in one file it doesn't
affect other files at all now
understanding this let's try to restart
we are still on the home screen because
you have put the logic like that and we
don't have a sign out button as of now
so
let's try to ignore this logic as of now
we'll put this back in but just so that
we need signup view so that we can see
the
data is being stored or not we can
create a user so I can just have test
one two three at the rate gmail.com test
one two three four click on done and you
can see the current user is not
authorized to perform the action now
that's because we have to make some
configurations in upright console as
well
in settings you have to go down and you
see update permissions you have to add a
role so that someone
can create a user update a user or
anything so I'll click on add a role any
and anyone can create a user and I'll
update that I'm not giving them read
update or delete properties why is that
because when the user is not a user you
can see the role has all users all
guests select users
when the user is not really a user that
means that the user has not logged in or
signed up or anything
they can just create a user so that you
know we can put that in the document
right now the user is a guest right now
the user is anyone it's not really a
user
so he can create
the user document but he cannot read
update or delete that would be a wastage
of calls they can just create
so this allows us to restrict certain
people from using certain features of
our application
now if I try to do done
a user with same email already exists
so we can have one two three four click
on done and you can see invalid document
structure a known attribute that means
the role part is now completed we are
getting a different error message and
that's because in the attributes we need
to add all the attributes a user can
have that means all the properties a
user document has so in the create
attribute we have to pass in basically
everything that's mentioned in the user
model except uid
so basically everything that's mentioned
in Tuma
so let's pass in and create those
attributes so the first attribute is
email which is of the type string the
size you can mention which is the
required field I'll just pass in 255 and
put it as required
so this is the email attribute now we
need
the name attribute so I'll pass in the
name String 255 is the size I'll click
on Create and I'll do that for all of
the fields for example for followers I
can pass in followers which will be an
attribute type of string size will be
255 or you can just extend this because
a user can have more than 255 followers
let's just put thousand ten thousand
anything I'll put thousand and I'll say
that this is not required this is an
array
then click on create
I create another attribute for following
so I'll copy this
paste it here
click on string array create
the next attribute is profile picture
which is a string so I'll have string
but this is not an array this is a
required field so the size can be 255 or
1000 again because the URL can be long
but since we are going to store the
profile pic in apprite storage itself
the link value will not exceed 255 so we
can just put that
then we need the banner picture as well
so I'll pass it in string and require
that's it
then I have bio I'll pass in the bio
which will be a string but the size can
be a longer than 255. so we can put 1000
as the value
and last thing we have is Twitter blue
so if it's Twitter blue the value is
Boolean
the default value
it is a required value so we don't have
to pass in a default value and then we
can click on Create and now all the
attributes are there all of the
attributes need to be mentioned
before you make the call to the database
for the user's collection later on we'll
have tweets and notifications collection
even that time you'll have to manually
add all of these attributes now this
attribute feature is quite good because
in case you roll out your app to certain
users and later on you decide that you
want to have more attributes in your
application for example you are try to
add one more field like a link attribute
to the user so you can add link
select string and just click on create
and it will add it to the attributes now
this is helpful because it will also add
the link attribute to the already
existing user documents this is an
improvement over Firebase Firebase
doesn't allow all of this
Firebase gives us a merge property but
it's very hidden in the docs many people
don't know about it with this attributes
feature it's quite good because it will
add it to all the documents all the
users present in your application
so there's less possibility of your app
breaking
anyways now that we have done this done
let's minimize this
and click on done
user with email exists so we can have
one two three four five click on done
account created so I'll just try to
refresh and here it is test12345 and
name is test12345
this function which is
present in the utils.dot get name from
email works fine for us because it's
given us the correct name
so we have followers following profile
pic Banner bio and if it's Twitter blue
it gives us a check mark so we can set
it to true or false
pretty neat now I'll try to login from
the same users account so we have test
one two
three four five at the rate gmail.com
test12345 click on done
Actually the password is just test one
two three four
and now I'll add this logic again
restart the app and we are still on the
home screen now our entire
authentication process is completed
of course let's just change this to
Twitter clone now too late for this but
let's change it and now what I want to
do is run the same app on Android
emulator I know many of you
might be coming to this timestamp right
now I'm just going to run Android
emulator and show how to fix the problem
you'll face while using Android emulator
sorry to not do this before it just
skipped out of my mind so let's do this
I'll close this iOS emulator for now run
the Android emulator
and I'll see you when the app loads so
our app has started on the Android
emulator if you see here it tells you to
upgrade the compile SDK version which is
just a warning but might not work later
on so you can go to build.gradle Android
app
in the compile SDK version you just have
to change this to 33 and the error will
go away
now another thing is if we restart the
app you can see upright exception null
config connection refused and this error
occurs because Android emulator doesn't
know what localhost is so if you just go
to Upright constants you can see it
doesn't know that localhost is there and
is unable to get resources from there
so to fix that you can
come here and change it to your IP
address so you have to pass in your IP
address like this so if your IP address
is like
191.2.3.4 you know anything like that
just put it here and it should work
another solution is just to type in the
command ADB reverse TCP colon 80 TCP
colon 80 and after you press enter it
should fix the error for you
I'm more comfortable putting my IP
address so I'm just going to put it here
and see you
after I put it and restart the app after
you followed either of those steps let's
restart the application
and you can see apprite exception
General unauthorized scope user rule
guess missing scope account and now we
are getting this error the reason for
this error is basically if we go to the
auth underscore API and see this
here actually we don't need the catch so
let's remove that and another thing that
you might notice is when we do current
user account we do need to put a weight
earlier I said that you cannot put a
weight and if it's it's fine if you
don't put away but it's actually needed
because you need to avoid it so that you
get the account and then you want to
return that account doing this and this
is not the same thing so after you do
this restart the app and here you can
see this works fine now so if you got
this error that was my mistake I said
you cannot put this but you should put
this anyways now that our app is working
you know let's try and
create a user so I'm just going to call
this user number one at the rate
gmail.com
test1234 click on done account has been
created so let's
login so we have test one two three four
again and click on done
and now we are signed in everything
seems to be working if I restart the app
this works now so there were two changes
to be made one is this one return a
weight account dot get not just return
account.get and other thing was app
right constants either using the
terminal ADB command I'll mention it in
the description below or you can just
use your IP address and put that in now
that you have both of these things done
and
our app is working on Android and iOS
I've expected the next thing we can do
is design the home screen with bottom
navigation bar down below a feed screen
a search screen and the notification
screen so let's get started with the
bottom app bar
and see what other things that are
needed there so for this we will go to
the lib folder and again in the home
view we are going to create our
scaffold now what all things are
required we need an app bar and the app
bar is going to be the same app bar that
we have in UI constants so we are just
going to use this and even before doing
all of this there's one thing we have to
convert all of this into a stateful
widget so we have home view here
now we need to return a scaffold here
as well as take the route from home view
consumer widget and put it in home view
stateful widget
now we can remove this we have done this
because we need access to set State
because we are going to have a bottom
navigation barrier and whenever a icon
on bottom navigation bar is clicked on
we need to change the page that is being
displayed
so now again we are going to have final
app bar is equal to
UI constants dot app bar
now we can take this app bar and put it
right here
next thing is a body but we'll figure
out body later on but before that we
need bottom navigation bar and bottom
navigation bar is Cupertino bar
now we have that you can also use
Cupertino you can also use bottom
navigation bar not just Cupertino tab
bar
I just prefer this style of Cupertino
tab bar
now I need items an item will be a list
of bottom navigation bar item
so I can just have bottom navigation bar
item pass in the icon and icon is going
to be SVG picture dot asset and pass in
assets constants dot home fill icon
correct now if I want to see this on the
screen
we are getting this error so let's
restart the application
and we are getting another error the
reason for that is there are not two
bottom navigation bar items which is the
bare minimum so I can just put another
one
and this one is going to be search icon
now I can save it and here we have it
this looks good but there are many
changes to be made for example
the color of this bottom navigation bar
item should change we can do that over
here by having active color and active
color but since these icons are a 3G
picture asset we can pass that color
here
so we can have palette dot white color
and the same thing can be passed in a
way up
now this looks good the third bottom
navigation bar item that we need is
notification icon so we have
notification filled icon and we can pass
that in
okay
now we also need to change the color of
this so that it matches with our
scaffold color so we can have background
color AS Palette dot background color
you can also change this in the theme of
the application
so you can go to the app Theme and add
this
it works either way and now this looks
good
now we want this toggle to happen and
based on the toggle we want to show the
icon so if we are on the search icon
we don't want to show the home filled
icon and notification field icon we want
to show their outline the icon so to
make that happen we are going to have
int underscore page equal to 0 and this
is going to contain the page index we
are going to be on so I can copy this
and pass this as the current index of
the Cupertino tab bar
and on tap I can have
a function created which is void on
tap on pay change let's call it that
this will give us some index which will
be the index the user clicked on and
then we can set States so that the build
function rebuilt and have underscore
page equal to index
now I'll take this and pass it in I can
directly pass this in because
the function signature that ontap
requires function integer and parameters
is exactly what void on page change is
and now based on this page I want to
show the item so if we are on page 0
then I want to show filled icon
otherwise I want to show assets
constants dot home IO line icon the
similar logic will go over here so if
you are on page one then we want search
icon otherwise it's normal search icon
because search icon is not bolded but
this logic will come over here as well
fifth page is two
we want notification field icon
otherwise assets constant dot
notification outline icon now we can
paste this in and this works you see
this this is an outline now if I click
over here this is not this is outline
not filled and this is also outline if I
click over here this is filled and both
of them are outlined so that means this
is working now we want to display the
appropriate
body so in to display the appropriate
body we are just going to have body
and password index stack why are we
using index stack instead of a page view
or another widget like that that's
because index stack helps us maintain
the state so example if some tweets are
shown here and we scroll down and then
we decide to go to the search screen so
that we can search something and come
back this will not rebuild the entire
widget this will keep its state
maintained and will be
on the same screen
or the same tweet we were earlier
watching so it maintains the state
you'll see that in action when we get to
that part I'll highlight it to you but
for now this is what it does
so now the index is the page and
children we have to pass in a list of
bottom top bar pages so I can go to the
UI constant so that I can create this
constant
and create static
widget actually list of widget
and call this bottom
tab bar pages and this will be equal to
let's say the first one is a text widget
and the text widget is going to say feed
screen because we should see feed screen
over here
feed screen is basically a screen that
shows us the latest tweets
then the next screen is the search
screen
and the third one
is the notification screen
now I can come here and have UI
constants dot bottom tab bar Pages
restart the entire app and here we have
it feed screen is showing up if I go
here search and notification screen now
the last thing we need on home View
widget is a board
a floating action button so we can have
floating action button
and in the on press right now we are
having nothing but basically it will
navigate us to the create wheat screen
and in the child I'm going to have
constant I can ikins dot add
now if I do this much you can see we're
getting this this blue color is because
in the app Theme we have specified The
Floating Action button theme to be
palette dot blue color exactly like
Twitter
but we want the color to be changed so I
can just pass in here the color AS
Palette dot white color
this looks good another thing that I
need is its font size to be increased so
I can increase its size by let's say 28
and this looks good
now what I want is whenever I click over
here it should open a create tweet
screen
so I'm going to close the home feature
as well
create a new feature here called tweet
and this is going to contain all the
Tweet related features like create tweet
screen
tweet list which is basically the feed
all the repository for all the
controller files related to it and of
course the repository or the API files
are going to be mentioned here so coming
back to the Tweet we want
views and in the views we are going to
have create
tweet
view dot dot
so I'll import material Dot
and then we are also going to import
flutter riverpod package
and after that we are going to use the
stateful consumer widget and call create
to eat screen
this consumer stateful widget snippet is
provided to us by Florida Riverport
Snippets
extension on vs code this is a stateful
widget because
we are going to have a text editing
controller we are going to have the
ability to share images so we need all
of this
so now let's start by designing this
screen so we have scaffold and let's see
how we want the create tweet view to
look like
so this is what we are trying to build
we have a close button here
we have our small rounded button here
then we have this long text field and a
bottom bar beneath also here we have
some space for our profile picture which
is right now empty but if there is no
picture then you want to show some
default picture
so let's start designing it the first
thing we need is an app bar and in the
app bar
the leading icon is icon button
where onpressed is required
and icon is required and icon is icons
Dot
close and the size should be bigger than
normal so we'll pass in the size as 30.
we're not really getting anything
because we have to click on this and to
go to the create tweet screen so first
of all let's create a route for this so
we can go to the home View
copy this route line
paste it over your
and pass in create tweet screen you can
also name this create tweet view
whatever you like
then in the home view you should have on
create tweet
so whenever the oncreate Tweet button is
clicked so we just want to do Navigator
dot push and we need to go to the create
tweet screen dot route
now we can copy this and paste it in the
on press offloading action button
let's restart the application and if we
click over here we have the button
showing up that's good now I need the
Tweet button to show up so I'll just
pass in the actions property to the app
bar and I've rounded small button
where on tap is going to be empty and
label is going to be tweet
I'll save it and you can see this button
shows up but I want the color to be blue
and the font to be white so to do that
I'm going to have background color
property which is not a required field
remember
and then we can pass in palette dot blue
color if we save this much it looks good
now we just need to change the font
color so the font color or the text
color is palette dot white color
and there we have it looks good
now in the body let's get out of the app
bar and in the body we are going to have
safe area widget
and then pass in a child the child is
going to be single child scroll View
and in that we'll pass in a child of
column path in children and the first
child that I want is
a row
to make you understand why we need
column is basically we add this
entire thing
so this is in a row format the profile
picture and the text field but this line
is also included right this line is
below this row that's why we need a
column so that we can paste this divider
in but even before that we need a row
so we'll pass in a row as
children
and the first child is circle Avatar
we'll pass in the background image and
background image will be Network image
and network image the image that we want
to show here is basically the user's own
profile picture
so to get that we have already created a
provider for that which is final user
which is equal to ref.watch now to get
the user data we'll have to go to the
user API and create a new function for
it so we'll go to the user API and
create
a function called future document now we
have called this future document not
future either document is because we are
going to use this in the future provider
so that it becomes easier for us to get
and
display the data so we can have get user
data
and then pass in the uid so we need the
uid of the user and based on that we can
get the user data this get user data
data is basically the data that's stored
over here in the database it's not the
authentication data we have already
created a provider for that which is get
user account data
provider or something like that now we
need to get the database data
right so now let's import
document so for document
we are going to have model dot document
and we'll import
app right with models.dot
and obviously import this as model
so we have modeled our document now I
can create one missing override I can
copy this function for the try and catch
block
actually we don't need the try and catch
block future provider will do that for
us
in case of any error it will give that
to us so now I just want to return DB
dot get document
we need to get one particular document
right to get one particular document we
have to pass in the document ID
and we are very sure that this user is
only going to have one document because
they have a particular uid and this uid
is automatically generated and is only
present once in the upright dashboard so
I can just pass that in as the document
ID confidently and for the database ID
we have upright constants dot database
ID and collection IDs upright constants
Dot
users collection
so it will give us the document
you can see that document
and it has the correct collection ID and
the document ID which is the uid of the
user now I can go to the
auth controller because that's where we
are going to need it later on
and we are going to create a function
called future user model
so whatever data we get here
the get user data function it's going to
return a document now we need to convert
this document in the form of a user
model I said all the model conversions
should take place in the controller not
in the user API
so that's why we are creating this
function over here and we have get user
data
string uid async
and your final document is equal to
await underscore user API dot get user
data and we'll pass in the uid we are
basically calling this get user data
function that was defined in the user
API class
now we can just have final updated user
is equal to user model
Dot from map
and pass in document but this is
document I want it in the form of a map
right so I can just see if it has
anything and yep there's data
so you can just have dot data passed in
which is in the map format and it will
give you the output now I can just
return this updated user
again we've not put try catch here
because now we are going to use this in
the future provider so we are going to
have future provider
user details provider
it's not going to be asynchronous it's
just going to have auth controller
and then we are going to return auth
controller Dot
get user data now
to get data
we don't know what is the uid of the
user right now
because this is just user details
provider not current user data is
provider basically this future provider
will be used even in future when we want
to view the user's profile suppose that
some other user I'm user number a
there's user number B showing up when we
search up the user or we click on the
profile of a user when the Tweet is
shown we want to be able to see their
profile right this is when getuser data
is going to help us this is a reusable
provider so I want the uid to come from
the UI file
so to do that I'm just going to have dot
family after this future provider and
now I can have string uid taken from
here
now whenever I call this user details
provider I need to pass in this uid like
a function I'll show you a demo right
now we are going to create another
future provider called current
user details provider this is for the
current user this is the provider we are
looking for in the create tweet view
this
provider is going to be used inside of
this provider
so now I can I'll not have family over
here I'll just remove the async call
I'll have
final user details
which is equal to ref dot watch
current user details provider I'll pass
in the uid and to get the uid of the
user not current user sorry we want user
details provider don't get confused
and here you can see it looks for a
uid
and we need to treat this as a function
when we use family
now I want to get the current user's uid
to get that
we can do final current user ID is equal
to ref.watch current user account
provider which is
this account as I said this account only
exposes one useful API for us which is
the uid so we can access that by doing
Dot as data now we have to do all of
this because this is of the type future
provider when we hover over this this is
giving us async value of account
so to remove async value from us and get
the value of account
we need to do dot value
and this cannot be null because it's a
current user ID it cannot be null
Dot
ID which is dollar ID and that's why in
our user model if you see we had passed
in this because dollar ID is basically
what the value of this account is dollar
ID now I can pass this current user ID
over here and return
user details dot value
now we'll go to the create tweet View
and in the build function we are going
to have current user which is equal to
ref dot watch
current user details provider
dot value
again we cannot do just this much
because current user is again async
value because current user details
provider is also a future provider and
we just now saw how to handle the value
of a future provider which was the
current user account provider
this might get a bit tricky so try to
understand the code and move forward
or you can just
rewind the video and watch it again
so now that we have current user with us
we can get its value and then check if
the current user is null or not so if
the current user is null
then we want to show a loader so we'll
have constant loader otherwise the safe
area widget
and your background image is going to be
current user Dot
profile pack and now we're getting this
loading indicator the reason for this
loading indicator is because we have
made a big bug in our application that's
because if we go back to our
auth controller you'll see that the uid
is empty I told you that uid is not
being used in two map but when we try to
save the user data the ID should not be
unique it should be the same as the
account ID
so right now if you see I tried to print
the current uid of the user account and
the same account
in the database is having a different ID
they both shouldn't have the different
ID the reason for that quite simple
because when we try to retrieve the user
ID we are passing in the account ID
that's the only account
ID that we have access to we have
nothing else to get data and that's why
both of them should not be different so
to correct the changes what I'm going to
do is in the uid I'm going to pass R
which is account dot ID
and then in the save user data function
the document ID is not going to be
anything unique it's going to be user
model Dot uid
so that was a mistake I made
now I'm going to erase everything all
the data from the database and even the
auth console so that we can have a fresh
start and see if you're not making any
other errors or not I'll see you when I
stop finishing the delete process
so I've deleted everything now let's try
to sign up the user so we have test at
the rate gmail.com I can reuse this
because we don't have any user now and
then test one two three four the user
has been created test one two three four
at the gmail.com test one two three four
done
I put in the valid invalid I just have
to get done and here we are now I'll
just restart the app
go to the screen
and there is no error
except this so that means everything
else is working fine now I'll explain
this error to you but before that let me
just remove the print statement that I
had put for my own debugging if you want
to make sure you can check that the
ID in the users collection right now and
the ID in the app right auth console is
the exact same thing
please do not forget that and now
talking about this error we got this
error because
our Banner pick is empty and still we
are trying to show that so it's not able
to show an empty URL image right
so to fix that what I'm going to do is
temporarily just add a profile pic over
here by searching for one over here so
I've copied an image address I pasted it
away or clicked on update and now if I
try to refresh the application go back
to the create tweet screen our image now
shows up that's pretty good now after
resolving all of these bugs which I
apologize for if it's not clear why we
did what we did please let me know in
the comment section it's an important
concept now in the circle Avatar I'm
just going to put a radius and the
radius is going to be 30.
so here we have this image now I'm going
to leave some space
so size box but this time a width of
let's say
15.
and then we are going to have a text
field and in that text field I want to
pass in a controller which is going to
be tweet controller so we have final
tweet text controller we are naming this
tweet text controller not tweet
controller because tweet controller is
going to be the name of the controller
we create for Twitter tweet text
controller is the text editing
controller now I can take this dispose
It Off
and pass that tweet text controller over
here
now I want the style so we have constant
textile
of font size
and decoration of constant
input decoration
where we mentioned hint text which is
Watts
happening
right
now we are not able to see the text so
what I'm going to do is pass in a hint
style and the hint style is going to be
textile with a color of palette dot gray
color
and we weren't able to see it in fact
because the text field and circle Avatar
are in a row and text field has a
tendency of occupying all the maximum
width it can get but since it's in a row
and circle Avatar is also there it's not
getting the maximum space therefore we
are getting this error so to resolve
this I can just wrap this widget with an
expanded widget
after I do this you can see we are
getting this
expanded gives us the maximum available
space in the screen
so expanded get gets all the remaining
space
now I also want to increase the font
size to let's say 22
and the font weight so that it looks a
bit bolded as font weight dot w
and this is looking good now the last
thing I want to do is basically give it
n number of lines
and also remove this border so to remove
the Border this is going to be quite
simple border is input border dot none
we don't want any border
and then we want Max lines to be null
because if we don't do this you can see
I'll try to type I'll try to type and it
keeps on moving in the horizontal
Direction when I overflow this line
basically I want to go to the next line
so to do that I'm going to pass Max
lines
which is outside this decoration Max
lines as null once we pass in null it
gets unlimited lines so if I try to do
anything you can see I have n number of
lines
so this is it now at last what I want is
a divider to be there
so that I can start showing my bottom
navigation bar which contains a list of
icons so if you want to add image you
can add image Emoji Emoji gifgf so in
the bottom navigation bar we are going
to have bottom navigation bar and this
is not necessarily going to be a bottom
navigation bar in fact it's going to be
a row where we'll pass in the children
the first child
is
SVG picture Dot
asset and I'll pass in assets constants
dot gallery icon and now if you see over
here there is an icon
we can see that but there is one problem
and that's
because we haven't added any padding so
to add a padding we are going to wrap
this with a padding widget
so that it has eight now this looks good
but other thing that I want is this to
be padded from the left and right
direction so I want it to be
having
padding of eight from all the sides and
copy with I want left
padding 15 and right padding 50.
so from all the sides it's 8 except left
and right left and right is 15. so we
have the icon showing up here and we
want left and right because we are going
to have other two icons which are also
going to be left and right 15.
so that's going to be GIF icon
and there's going to be emoji icon all
of this mentioned in assets constant and
here there is
look great but now what I want is a line
to be present over here so to put a line
I can do two things I can pass in the
column a divider right here but other
thing I can do is wrap this row with a
widget known as container and this
container will give us
decoration of constant box decoration
border and Border should be border from
the top as Border Side and pass in the
color which is palette dot gray color
and now if we see here is the Border but
it's quite thick so I want it to reduce
the width so it will be 0.3
and this looks decent enough
last thing I want is it to have a margin
from below so what I can do is add a
padding property of constant Edge in
such Dot
only from bottom 10. now save it and
here we have it the icons are raised
from the Bottom by 10. now all of them
are visible
the next thing is now whenever I click
on this this should pop off the screen
should pop off and whenever I click over
here I should get the ability to add
images so now what I can do is just have
navigator.pop so that it pops off the
screen and goes to the
home screen so if I click over here I'm
back to the home screen if I come back
you're back over here now whenever I
click over here I want to pick images so
to do that we are going to add a plugin
known as image picker and then it will
give us a list of images we can select
from and we will get the images over
here
displaying in the form of Carousel and
then we should be able to tweet that so
this is the plugin we'll be using for
image picking image picker plugins I'll
just add that dependency and another
dependency that we need is Carousel
slider I'll install both of them
together
basically Carousel slider will help us
with displaying the images in a carousel
format
and image picker as the name suggests is
in image picking
now there are certain installation steps
to be required for iOS if you're on
Android you can skip through this part
for iOS what we need to do is add this
key to n4.pls files so let's go to iOS
slash Runner and add the info dot PLS
and add this key sorry
so there are two keys NS photo library
usage description
and NS camera usage description
you can also add the third key which is
the NS microphone but you won't be
needing this because this isn't related
to camera
this is for video recording
and you also need to mention the
description of this but since I'm not
uploading this to App Store I don't want
to waste time writing something and
making something up but if you're
deploying on place app store it's very
important otherwise your app will get
rejected anyways coming back to this I
think the whole process of installation
is done I can restart it on Android
nothing else is required the compile SDK
version should be 33 and we've already
changed that to version 33. and while
that is happening let's go to utils.dot
we'll close all the other files and here
we are going to create a function for
future list file so that we can pick an
image so we have pick images function we
are also going to create a separate
function for picking one single image
and this will be required when we'll be
using
profile picture and banner image we just
want one image that time but right now
we can pick multiple images
so you'll get a knowledge of having both
you can either pick one single image or
multiple images
now here to pick multiple images what we
need is a list of file we'll call this
images and will be an empty list for now
and then we'll instantiate the image
picker plugin
which is equal to image pickup
now I'll take this picker
pick images and you can see we have
option to pick image and pick Multi
Image we're going to go ahead with pick
Multi Image and save this to a final
variable called image files
and now we'll check if image files is
not equal to null and it's never equal
to null so you want to check if image
files
dot is not
and actually we need to await this
before we can do anything else and now
we want to check if image files is not
empty then what we need to do is for
final image in image files
so we are running a foreign Loop
basically we'll go through the image
files and we'll get
an element from this list called image
and we'll add that to our images list
that we created over here so we can have
images dot add
file
image dot path
so this is in an X-File format we
basically get its path convert it into a
file and add it to the images and now we
can just return this images
so this is the entire pick images
function now I'm going to go ahead and
bind this to our create tweet screen
so I'll scroll down and find a bottom
navigation bar item the gallery icon I'm
just going to wrap the SVG picture with
a gesture detector so we have gesture
detector and we'll pass in the on Tab
and just to mention this gesture
detector is wrapped over here instead of
the padding because if we wrap it over
the padding
whenever we
click over here not on the icon over
here it will still get selected I don't
want that I only want it to get selected
when I click on this
icon
that's why I've wrapped it around SVG
picture not the padding
and now on the top I'm just going to
create an image of function for it so we
have void
on pick images
and here we are going to call our pick
images function from util.dot file
this is going to be asynchronous we'll
await this and then we are going to have
a global variable basically we want to
be able to show these images live on the
screen to show them on the screen we are
going to have list of file
images which is equal to an empty list
and now I want to import dot IO and now
what I want to do is set images equal to
await this and set state
I'm not doing such State you know like
this because I'll have to make such
State asynchronous function instead of
doing that I'm just
doing this above such State and then
calling such state so that the build
function rebuilds
and then I'll be able to show an image
so to show an image actually let's just
link this on pick images function right
here
and see if we are able to
select images so if I click over here
select photos
I'll select this image this image and
this image click on done
and I think it should show up so
now what I want to do is if the image
list is not empty initially it's empty
if the user doesn't select anything it's
empty if it's not empty then I want to
display the carousel over here that's
why we have added the carousel as well
so now what I want to do is in the
column we are going to have if images
dot is not empty so the image is not
empty I want Carousel slider to be
present
and what are the items of this Corrado
carousel
images
right but this items requires a list of
widgets so we need to map this
why do we have a mapping image because
the items are based on images and we
will map each image so that we can
return a network image
not really a network image image dot
file
the reason for that is
here we have selected images from our
memory
created that in the file format and now
we want to display them in the file
format so now instead of e we can name
this file and pass in file to this over
here
and so that the error goes away we can
convert this to a list
next thing I need is options and option
is going to be carousel options
height 400
and enable infinite scroll false so you
cannot continuously keep scrolling and
finitely like even if the last image
gets over the first image will show up
after that we don't want that if this is
the last image we won't be able to
scroll further
so we have image.file returned but there
are some modifications to be made so
let's convert this in a block
and we'll return image.file from here
and have this now let's just see what we
have till now so I'll just select an
image
here we have a list of images they look
good but there are certain modifications
to be made for example
we want them to occupy the entire screen
with we want them to have a margin from
the side so we can wrap this with a
container Widget the width will be
media query dot of context dot size dot
with media query
width is basically the entire screen
width and then we need the margin and
the margin is constant Edge insets dot
symmetric
horizontal 5.
so we are having a margin of 5 from left
and the right side so that the images
don't stick together and this looks
pretty neat so we have the Carousel and
this looks good
we are not going to add any more thing
over here this can be more beautified
later on but you can do that by yourself
the main point now is whenever we click
on the Tweet option we should be able to
tweet
depending on if the image is present not
present if the text is present not
present anything so to do that we'll
have to do multiple things let's close
all of the features here in the Tweet
we'll need a controller which will be
tweet controller.dot
and even here we'll need something like
a tweet API but first let's figure out
how the Tweet controller will work
I'll explain it to you how the Tweet
controller will work we'll write the
boilerplate code for tweet controller
and then we'll get to the Tweet API
which is a very simple function but we
have to write all the boilerplate code
over there as well so let's get into it
so let's create the basic state Notifier
and state Notifier provider so we have
state Notifier so this creates the whole
code for us now we can just type tweet
controller remove the nodifier from here
so let's remove this and we have state
node file now what is the type going to
be well it's going to be Boolean again
nothing different
and this is going to be false we have a
lot to import over here but we'll import
that later
now what I want to show over here is
basically what are the functions that we
are going to have over here
now the first function we are going to
have is share tweet function pretty
simple and you might think that this is
the only function that's required but no
controller is doing the heavy lifting
here
tweet API is also going to have just one
function the shared tweet function it's
just going to receive a tweet model that
we are going to create in function
and based on that it will be able to
convert it to map and upload it to
Upright that's all uh tweet API will do
but in our case the Tweet controller is
going to do a lot of tasks first it has
to determine whether the Tweet has an
image
or it's just text and it will also
determine other things like hashtags
link so that we can display them
appropriately
so this is a share tweet function it's
going to require many things so let's
require them first thing that's required
is a list of file of images
we will check here if the images are
empty if the image is empty that means
we are sharing only a text based tweet
otherwise it's an image based to it so
we are also going to require text
is always needed
we also require build context so that if
K is of any error we can just display
them we also need I think for now this
is all that's needed when we come to the
reply section we are going to need much
more than this
now inside of this as I said we are
going to have some functions for example
first we have to check if text is empty
so if text is empty we'll not be able to
move forward we can just say show snack
bar
please enter text so the user should be
able to enter text
and then we'll return from the function
then we'll check if images
dot is not empty so the images file or
the images list is not empty then we
want to share a function
or we want to create a function called
share image tweet
and here we are again going to require
many things so let's just copy these two
paste it in your
and when we come to the reply section
again we need many stuff I also forgot
the build context so let's put build
context here
and then we can call share image tweet
and we'll pass in images text and build
context now if the image is not empty or
the images dot is not empty is false
that means that the image is empty then
we want to share a text based tweet so
we can just create another function
called share
text tweet
and we can paste that in similar to the
share image to it so we have shared text
to it but this time we will not have
images here because it's a text waste
tweet why do we need images
now notice that we have made both of
these functions private this is because
they shouldn't be used outside of the
controller
only share tweet should be pushed
outside of the controller that's because
we want to do heavy lifting and
controller we don't want to expose all
of this logic like share image to it is
if images is not empty if image is empty
all of that we don't want in the UI file
let the UI file be clean we want the
controller to be present and controller
can do all the weird tasks that are
there right now either it is
image tweet or text-based tweet we want
two things to happen we want to get
hashtags from a text and we want to get
links from a text
so we'll create the functions right now
so we have the first function which is
string
get link from
text
so we have a text over here and we want
to get link based on it so now first of
all we are going to get
the words in the sentences so we have
list of string words in sentence
which is equal to text Dot split
so we are finding the words and putting
them in a list format so suppose
the sentence is
YouTube
okay
so it will convert this in a list format
like this Revan
of course with a string like a
inverted comma like this but just for
demonstration rewind on our YouTube
okay so we have this inverse in
sentences now what I want to do is check
that if each word
starts with https or www dot so I'll
just do four
just like we did earlier string word in
words and sentences
and then check if word
dot starts with https colon slash slash
or word dot starts with
www dot then it's a link
right so none of these are links but if
I add h w w
www.youtube.com
it identifies it because we got this
word
in the list
it looped through it and checked yeah it
starts with www dot correct
so now we can just say link is equal to
word and where is the link well I can
just create a link variable right yeah
and then we can return the link
so this is the get link from text and
this is also private because they
shouldn't be outside the Tweet
controller
we'll use this function inside share
image tweet and share text to it now
other thing that we need is getting
hashtag and this is going to have a
similar logic like get link so we can
just have get hashtags from text then we
are going to have a string text and then
we are going to have similar logic so
I'll just copy paste this but instead of
string this is going to be list of
strings hashtags which is equal to an
empty list as of now
now we get the words in sentences and
then we just check if the word starts
with a hashtag so if the word starts
with hashtag we are just going to have
hashtags dot add
word
and then we are going to return hashtags
so let me give you an example so if I
have
something like this but this time we
have rewind
as well now this is in our list format
okay now we Loop through it and then
check does the word start with hashtag
yes
we'll add it to hashtags
have yup it has let's add it YouTube has
nope www dot has nope so we are just
going to have two hashtag words so they
are in the list right now and we will
return the list
and this is also a private function
shouldn't be outside the controller
great now after having both of these
things done let's create a tweet model
so we have tweet underscore model
dot dot and now we are going to create
this tweet model
and then we can jump into this function
and call all of this and interact with
the Tweet API so now we can have class
tweet
and let's decide what all properties
should be there final string text final
list of string hashtags
final string link
final list of string
image IDs this image IDs are not image
IDs they are image links sorry these
image links will basically be the links
that we receive after storing our images
in the storage facility of app right
basically in this section storage
so we get a file over here we take all
of these files uploaded to storage get
their URL and then we upload it in our
tweet model and based on this tweet we
can check if it's empty if it's not
empty then we can display them on the
feed screen when we have to display the
Tweet then we have final string user ID
so the person who created the tweet and
then we also need the Tweet type so we
can go in the core
create a new folder called enums
and in your create a first enum which is
tweet
type
enum dot dot this enum will basically
help us decide which tweet to be used
right I mean which tweet type it is so
that we can
easily display the Tweet onto the screen
so it can either be text so we have text
or we have image so we have image here
and then we are going to have final
string type constant tweet type
this Dot
type so here we basically have tweet
type
tweet type
right
so it can either be text image and if
you later on decide to add some more
options like GIF sharing and just emojis
or whatever you can add them then we
also need final
date Time created at
so what time the Tweet was created
or we can just name this tweeted at
then we need a final list of string of
likes
comment IDs so whoever comments on this
tweet their IDs a final string
ID so this is the ID of the Tweet not
the ID of the user the user ID is this
so the basically the user who tweets
this will have this uid and ID is
basically the Tweet ID
and this is final and reshare count we
don't want to keep track of who we
shared it and stuff we just want to keep
a track of number of how many people
have re-shared it
then we have other things needed when we
get to the replying part but let's just
ignore it for now now we can generate a
data class we can remove dot convert
we can pass in at the rate immutable
and pass in constant aware now we can
scroll down
and here you can see when we want to
convert tweet type to a map format like
we want to upload it to database we have
two map but it's giving us an error
because there is no two map so you want
to do tweet type
DOT type
and this will give the correct type
because that's what we have mentioned in
the enum text and image this is the type
of this enum then we have tweet type Dot
from map kind of message so for that
we'll have to create an extension on
this enum
this was using enhanced genomes and now
we are just going to create an extension
on this enum called this convert
to eat and this is an extension on
string this will return a tweet type to
enum and we are just going to switch
this so when we are having this so
whenever two enum is called on a string
that string
is
text
then we want to return
tweet type dot text
if it's image so if it's case of an
image we want to return
tweet type
dot image and if it's none of these
there's default and then we want to
return
tweet type
dot text
so it's either a typo mistake or
anything then we just want to return a
text type
so basically
if we have something like
text mentioned in a string format and
then we call two enum function on it
this will return to us a tweet type
dot text
easy
so now we can go to the Tweet model
remove all of this it's not needed we'll
take map of tweet type as string because
it should be a string and convert it to
an enum
or you can specify it more
efficiently by saying
to tweet type enum because in case you
have other enums on the string format
later on an app you don't want to mess
things up
and then obviously we'll remove the two
Json and from Json
similar to our user model
now we can come to the Tweet controller
and first thing we are going to have a
look at share text View
so here we'll set State equal to true
that means is loading as started then I
want to get a list of hashtags a final
hashtag equal to get hashtags from text
and we'll pass in the text that we get
from here then we also want to get the
link so link is equal to get link from
text and we'll pass in the text then we
are going to create a tweet model so we
have tweet tweet equal to
to eat
and now we'll pass in text hashtags
links now we need to pass image links
image links is going to be
empty for your
then we need uid the uid of the user so
we need to get the current user's ID
so we'll have to do that tweet type here
is going to be tweet type dot text
because we are in a
share text tweet functions obviously
it's a text
tweeted ad is going to be datetime dot
now you can either use date time dot now
or you can use the one that's given by
apprite itself then we have likes like
says initially going to be empty comment
IDs comment IDs is going to be initially
empty ID
so the ID is going to be empty for now
because we are not adding that to two
map and of course we need to remove that
before we forget so in our tweet model
we'll go and remove map of ID we don't
need that
actually in two map not from map
so we'll remove from here
we don't want this line
and over here we are just going to have
map slash dollar ID this is the same
thing that we did with user model we
don't want the from map to have just ID
it's going to be slash dollar ID
and this is not going to have a map
returning ID
okay
so we can go to the Tweet controller
again now the ID is empty and the
reshare count should be zero
one thing that's needed is the uid so to
get the uid we are just going to have
final user is equal to now we need
access to refs how am I going to get ref
inside of this state notify so to do
that I'm just going to ask it from here
I'm just going to ask it from The
Constructor that yeah please give me ref
I don't mind it being
a widget ref a provider ref or just ref
so I'll just ask it so we have required
ref ref
and then we have underscore ref equal to
ref
now I can take this underscore ref
put it away or another ref dot read
current user
details provider
dot value
and then we'll pass in user dot uid so
we get the user's ID and we pass that as
a uid because only the current user can
tweet from your account I hope that
makes sense now we have the Tweet model
ready and everything good to go only
thing that's required is to create the
Tweet API so that we can send it
to the database so again let's come to
our apis and create tweet underscore API
dot dot we're going to create an
abstract class for I
tweet API
and this is going to be future either
document
share tweet and we are just going to get
tweet model
and based on that tweet model we are
just going to convert it to map and send
it across pretty simple this is actually
very similar to the user API we did that
for the save user data we got the user
model we created a document
the data was usermodel.2map and we
returned right that's it and that's
exactly what we are going to do here
we're just going to have class
tweet API
implements I tweet API
create one missing override this is the
share tweet function
so I'll have async and now I need a try
and a catch block we have added future
either here because this is not going to
be enough future provider obviously we
are just sharing a tweet which is a
normal future return data type we
obviously don't want to encapsulate
everything that has a future with future
provider it really depends on the use
case if you want to get some data and
display it on the screen only then would
I use a future provider
otherwise State Notifier provider is
always good so here what I want to do is
a try and catch block so I'm just going
to go ahead copy all of this
I would recommend you type so that you
have a good practice but I've already
had a lot of practice with this before
creating this video
now I'll just have final databases
underscore DB
so that you know I can inject it through
my provider we've already talked about
it we're just repeating the logic I hope
you're getting the hang of it
so we're requiring this and then we are
going to have underscore DB equal to DB
I'm going a bit fast way here because
this is already the logic we have
covered
anyways after creating the document
let's import this app right constants
but this time it's not user's collection
we need tweets collection so we name
this
tweets collection and then pass in the
appropriate tweet collection ID so let's
go ahead create a new collection called
tweets
copy The Collection ID don't forget it
and paste it over here and now I want to
get started with creating the attribute
surveyor so that we don't get the error
so the attribute here is going to be
everything that's mentioned over here so
I can just take text pass it in
select the attribute type as string 255
required and go ahead and create now you
can do this for everything I'll just
fasten this process really quick
while creating the attribute one thing
is the Tweet type the Tweet type here
should be of the string format because
when we are converting it to map you can
see over here
we are having tweet type DOT type and
this is a string this tweet type is
basically what we had mentioned over
here okay and another thing is the
attribute key of tweeted ad this tweeted
AD should be an integer why
because if you see over here in the two
map function we have tweeted at dot
millisecond since Epoch and this returns
an integer so you want an integer to be
present over here
we unmarked this as required and click
on create
and make sure to not add ID property to
this tweet
model or this attributes don't add the
ID property you can add uid but don't
add ID because this is a tweet ID that
is being automatically generated and
this tweet uid is basically what we are
passing it the current user's ID when
they tweet
now in the Tweet API
what I want is database ID correct
collection ID should be tweets
collection and the document ID should be
tweet Dot
ID right no why because if you come to
the Tweet controller you'll see that the
ID over here is empty we don't want an
empty document ID so this is not going
to be tweet.id just like we had for
user.id for our user model where we made
a mistake this should actually be ID dot
uni because every tweet should have a
different ID
so that they don't merge with each other
right
and finally tweet.2 Maps should be the
data now of course we'll return right so
import fp.library and here we have to
return a document so we can just save
this so you have final document is equal
to this
and we can return this document so this
is our function
that's all that was needed now I'll just
create a provider out of this so we have
final tweet API provider
we don't have to mention the type
the real part is very smart to identify
that and then we can return tweet API
and pass in the database which is
ref.watch app right database provider
I hope you are understanding what we are
doing
we are continuously repeating the same
things and that's what the whole
tutorial will consist just many
repetition of things one or two unique
concepts are left about real time and
storage otherwise it's just about
creating reading updating and deleting
every single place you just need to have
the correct logic and understand what to
do when
now we can go to the Tweet controller
except from The Constructor a tweet API
so we have final
tweet API underscore tweet API
required tweet
API tweet API
and underscore tweet API should be equal
to tweet API
now I can take this underscore tweet API
and use it here so we have underscore
tweet API dot share tweet we'll pass in
the Tweet model
it will give us some response of your
final response is equal to await this
and you also need async so we'll async
this now we have a response now you know
how to handle failures and success right
we've done this in the past in the user
in the auth controller we just have to
do
res dot fold
we'll either have left or right in case
it's left we'll show a snack bar with l
dot message and if it's right
nothing as of now later on when we add
reply part
things will change
also to ignore the warnings let's put a
const at the places it's required so
this is the text based tweet let's see
if it's working just based on text tweet
so I'm not going to enter any image here
I'll just say hey
and actually I have to bind this
function I forgot it so we need State
Notifier provider
tweet controller provider will pass in
tweet controller and a Boolean value
so tweet controller is a class name
Boolean is what we are returning over
here and now we need to return to it
controller we'll pass in ref and then we
need tweet API to eat API is ref.watch
tweet API provider
and that's it there's no dot notifier on
provider that dot notifier on state
notify provider and state provider State
provider is a simplified version of
State Notifier provider but you're not
going to use that because
it's hardly ever needed because it's so
simple
like the value it consists and its use
cases are so simple that it's not needed
ours is a more complex topic
I know I've been rushing through so if
you're feeling under confident I would
recommend you to watch it again or code
it on your own don't just watch it
because this is a bit complex now what I
want to do is just go to the create
tweet view we'll create a function for
share tweet so we have void share tweet
and then we are going to have ref dot
read tweet controller provider because
we want to get access to this tweet
controller right once we get access to
this
instance of the class we can call the
share tweet function which will later on
check if it's image or text we are just
going to text for now and then it will
upload it to the database
so we have tweet controller provider dot
Notifier dot share Tweet now we need to
pass in images we have passed that in
text text is basically tweet
textcontroller dot text
and the build context and we are done
now we'll also check if it's loading or
not so we have final is loading is equal
to ref dot watch
tweet controller provider
now if it's loading
so I want to show a loader so if it's
loading or the current user is null then
I want to show a loader otherwise the
widget tree
and now if I click on tweet nothing
happens so I'll just restart
also I'll bind the share tweet function
to the done button right in the app bar
since the function signatures match you
can see I can put that in correctly
so I'll come over here I'll say hello
and then click on tweet the current user
is not authorized to perform the
requested action and there's continuous
loading there are two things to be fixed
so I'll go to the settings of the tweets
collection I'll scroll down and add a
role where all the users can create read
update not update
and not delete because Twitter doesn't
allow deleting I hope
as far as I've seen I don't get the
option to delete so we can either create
or read there's no updating the Tweet or
reading the tweet and also we have to
set state is equal to false I can remove
the comments these are basically useless
comments now I'll search state is equal
to false now
and then
restart the application
come back here I'll say
hello and click on tweet
you can see invalue document structure
unknown attribute hashtags so I think I
forgot to put the hashtags list I'll put
that in
and the size of the hashtag list is
going to be 100 or 50 or whatever you
want we'll click on create
now we'll click on tweet and the Tweet
has been uploaded so if we go to the
documents refresh there's one document
with a text of tweet the correct uid of
the user tweet type as text that's right
Twitter ad is also correct there's likes
comment IDs and image links reshare
count and there's no hashtag now I'll
try to add hashtag hashtag
rivonawat and also a link so I'll just
write www.youtube.com
and now I'll click on tweet
so it got updated now I'll come back
here we have it here's the text here's
the hashtags correct
and the link is also correct that means
everything is working fine in the Tweet
type text format now I want the same
thing to happen in image but things
might change a bit differently in
share image to it why because we have a
list of file images to be uploaded to
storage we'll have to create a separate
API for that
so I'm just going to go ahead copy
everything from here paste it in and
definitely make some changes
first make this asynchronous share tweet
is going to remain same tweet type is
now image we have a list of image links
to be put in I'll do that and nothing
else is needed so now I need to go to
the storage API API folder and create a
new API called storage API
we cannot do that with the Tweet API
because it might
congest
a lot and also this storage API is not
just going to be used in tweet right
it's also be going to be used in user
profiles when the user wants to update
their bio profile picture and all of
that stuff
they will be able to access storage API
again
so let's create storage API I'm not even
going to create an abstract class for it
there's just one function
so yeah final storage underscore storage
and we have storage API required storage
and underscore storage should be equal
to storage simple now we want to upload
future list of strings while list of
string because
we are going to get a list of files we
are going to upload that to storage it
will give us a download URL not really
give us a download URL it will give us
image IDs of that URL we can convert
them in the form of links I'll show you
how
and send them out so that's why it's
going to be a list of string and then we
want to upload images and we have list
of files right
so we have list of files
this is going to be asynchronous
I'll get file import the dot IO Library
and now I'm just going to have list of
string of file IDs or file image links
let's just call it image links which is
equal to nmt list
then we'll run a foreign loop again
so we have for final file in files
then we want to upload it to the storage
so we have final uploaded image
equal to await underscores storage dot
create file this is the API of apprite
it gives us a method known as create
file get file all of those stuff we just
need create file
so if the user creates a file then we
need their bucket ID file ID file
so we know file ID is going to be unique
so we can have unique like this or we
can just have
ID dot uni then we need the file the
file is going to be of the type input
file so how do I get input file well you
can just do input file
and pass in the path path is going to be
file dot path simple
basically we are looping through all the
files in this list we get this file we
are converting it into an input file
using its path and now we just add file
to the image links so we have image
links dot add uploaded image which is a
file but this is not the file from dot
IO you see this this is not a file from
dot IO that we are using
over here this is a file model that's
created by apprite itself so if you do
dot on this you'll see a list of
different properties because this is a
different class altogether this is not
the file coming from dot IO it's coming
from app right slash models.dot the same
place we got account and session
classes
so here we have dot dollar ID we can add
that and then we just want to return the
image links from this function easy now
to get the bucket ID what we need to do
is go to the upright console
go to the storage create a new bucket
let's call this images
copy this bucket ID go to Upright
constants and register it
so we are just going to call the static
constant string images bucket
which is equal to this
and now we can pass an upright constants
Dot
images bucket
easy enough now we will just create a
provider for this and call this
storage
API provider
and we'll return storage API but we need
to pass in the storage and for that
we'll have to create another provider
because we don't have anything for
Storage storage yet so we can go to the
providers.
create
another
provider and call this app right storage
provider
will pass in storage over here and it
will also require a client that's it
all the upright
dependencies are similar to each other
that's a plus point
and now in the storage we can just pass
in
ref.watch
app Right Storage provider now you might
ask one thing if we are returning the
file ID
how is this a link and you're totally
right this is not a link so we need to
convert this in the form of a link
so basically if you try to upload any
file I'll just select a file
I just uploaded a file from here
and you can copy this
you'll get a file URL right now you can
see this but the point is the URL is not
exposed over here so if you try to do
dot URL or something try to find
something it's not really there
so what I'm going to do is just examine
this URL I'll copy this
go to the upright constants and create a
static function for this so we have
static string image URL it will return
this function will return a string of
image URL by taking image ID as a
parameter and return this
if I want to make it work on Android
I'll have to pass in my IP address over
here so I'm replacing all of this
with dollar
endpoint
slash storage
because my endpoint doesn't have a slash
at the end so we have dollar endpoint
slash storage slash buckets then there's
the bucket ID so I can just have dollar
images bucket which is this one
slash files slash dollar image ID
view question mark project and then
we'll pass in the project ID
and mode is equal to admin
so this is how we are able to retrieve
and see the image URLs pretty cool
now I can go to the storage API
I can add this so I can just do image
links dot add
app right constants
dot image URL pass in the image ID which
is uploaded image dot dollar ID
and with this we have image links added
a proper valid image URL is there great
now I can go to the Tweet controller go
to the share image tweet
and here just a final image length is
equal to
underscore storage API so I want to get
access to storage API
so I can just have
similar to tweet apis storage API
underscore storage API
and now I can again have this past tense
so required storage API storage API
underscore storage API equal to storage
API
now that app storage API I can just have
underscore storage API dot upload image
then I'll pass in a list of files and
the files are images I'll await this
I'll take the image links which is a
list of string and add it over here
now I think this is all about image
Tweet now I can go up in the storage API
I'll just pass in ref dot watch storage
API provider
and we are done now let's try to run the
application we have already configured
the UI file everything over there now
I'll select some images
I think these three work well now I can
just say hashtag Revan this is so cool
and I can tweet it out
we are getting this error because
the current user is not authorized to
perform the requested action and that
might be because we are not allowing
the user to upload images
so to upload the images we can go to the
settings add a role all users can create
or read I don't think reading is also
allowed so let's just allow creating
the users cannot read update or delete
anything that's for
our admins
so I can just restart
let's just select images again
this is beautiful
and then click on tweet
now it says that the attribute has
invalid type
valid worst valid string must be more
than 10 characters so basically
in the databases I had earlier said
that the Tweet attribute of
hashtag
should be 10 but that's not the IRA
value it is the number of characters in
the string
so your hashtags
should have a string they should be a
list but the size of this list can be
you know
50 60. this is not the size of the list
this is the size of the characters
present in a string
so my hashtag rivan should not be like
10 characters it should be like 60 70
whatever should be the maximum size of
the hashtag okay now I can just click on
create
now I'll try to post
this error is basically
if I scroll down we have to delete this
image links attribute
they cannot be 10 why I'll tell you
because
image links should have
a string attribute there should be an
array but their size over here is not
the size of the list it's the size of
the characters so how long is the link a
link cannot be just 10 characters right
so here they should have suppose
255 characters or something like that
you can calculate it whatever is the
size of the link and put that in
if it's something else then perhaps
something is wrong in your project or
apprite SDK has changed I'll just pass
in 255 and see what happens this is the
character size of the string of the
image links not the size of the array
okay now I'll click on create then I'll
click on tweet and I think the Tweet has
been made so I'll just go to the
documents and we have hashtag everyone
this is beautiful
we also have three image links but they
contain my IPS I'm not showing it to you
so this is working well
now the next part is after two eating
you know image links correctly
identifying all of them
and uploading them to database we have
covered a lot of tasks in this section
now the next part is to
display those tweets
over here on the screen and we already
have the foundations for it we have the
Tweet model which is going to help us a
lot but we still have to make more
functions like getting the tweets and
creating a UI card for that tweet so
that you know it looks good just like
the Twitter
so let's get started with it and we have
to start off by creating a new view not
a new view it should be a new widget and
that is going to be a tweet list widget
so let's create a folder here named
widgets and now we want to create tweet
list
this is a widget name so we'll have
tweet underscore
list dot dot and now I'll import
material dot I'll create a stateless
consumer widget
and I'll call this tweet list
also I'll import the flutter evapot
library and now I'll create
I'll tweets provider so basically I want
to create a future provider that will
get me all the tweets from the apprite
database so I can go to the Tweet API
and now I'll Define another abstract
class function which is going to be
future either
not future either since we want it in
the form of a flood River pod from
provider the future provider we are
going to have future list of document
get tweets
now I'll just do command full stop
create one missing override and now I'll
do asynchronous and now I want to get
all the tweets now how do I get a list
of documents so for that I'll just use
underscore DB Dot and see the function
for it create documents create the
documents delete get list
list documents will give us a list of
documents as their name suggests
so I want the database ID the database
ID is upright constants
dot database ID collection ID is upright
constants dot tweets collection
and now I'll just save this in a
variable so the final documents is equal
to await DB dot list documents now I can
just do return
documents but this is document list not
doc list of documents so what I can do
is documents dot documents and it will
return to us a list of documents correct
now I can go to my tweet controller so
let's go over there
and here I'll create a separate function
called
future
list of tweets correct because I want to
get a list of tweet here we are
returning the documents in a list format
here I'll convert all of those documents
in a list format so I'll call this get
tweets
this will be asynchronous and then I'll
get final tweet list is equal to await
underscore tweet API dot get tweets
now this tweet left in the list of
document so I'm just going to map
through it and convert every single one
of them into a tweet so we can do that
by doing tweetlist Dot map
and this will give us a tweet
now I'll convert this to a map so we'll
have tweet Dot from map sorry I'll
convert it to a model from a map so I
can do tweet Dot from map this will
convert it from map to a tweet model
and then I can pass into it dot data
like we've done before for
user model but this time we are just
mapping through it and converting
everything to a list so basically we
went through all the documents mapped
through each one of them we got a single
document
and we convert it to a model
now I can return this thing because it's
now a list of tweets
and since there's asynchronous it
becomes future list of tweets and now I
just need to create a future provider
out of this so I'll just have future
provider name this get tweets provider
then remove this and then I'll have
final tweet controller is equal to
ref.watch tweet controller provider dot
Notifier now I can return
tweetcontroller Dot
get tweets and now this is of the type
future provider list of tweet
why I was insisting on future provider
now you'll get to know because future
provider gives us a very good thing so
if we come to the Tweet list and do
return ref dot watch
and then we do get tweets provider
you can see we have earlier used dot
value to get the value of the list and
then we could use this value we did this
for the user provider so if we come back
to our
create tweet View
we can see here we did this since this
was a future provider we had dot value
but now what we are going to do is not
value but dot when I said you can
easily transition between the data error
or the loading state
that's why we never had
future either in there because if
there's an error we'll get to know it
over here
so now if there is data we have to do
something if there is an error we'll
also get a stack Trace you have to do
something about it and in case of loader
we have to do something about it so
first two are very straightforward we
have already created something for them
there's load up for loading there's
error text for error so we have error
text and we'll pass in error.tostring
and for data we are getting tweets
and this is in a list format so if there
is a list of tweets and we don't know
its numbers so how many tweets there are
going to be we don't know that so for in
that case we can use list view Builder
and now we can mention the item count
which is tweets dot length
and now we'll extract each tweet so this
item count is the number of items that
are there so there are tweets dot length
number of items
now I want to get a
access to a single tweet so I can have
tweets at Index this index is provided
over here so I'm getting one single
tweet by doing tweets index in the item
Builder property
and now if I just want to test I can
just have tweet dot let's say text pass
to it and see if I'm getting the right
thing or not now I can take this tweet
list go to my UI constants file where
I've already created text feed screen
now I'll just replace this with a normal
tweet list
and obviously this has to be constant
now I can restart and here you can see
there are three tweets and there are
three tweets over here as well that
means our tweets are being retrieved
successfully now I want to create
another widget which is the Tweet card
so let's create that so I want to design
how my tweet card is going to look like
so I can do that in a separate way
separate class because it has a lot of
stuff going in it and this is also going
to be a stateless consumer so we have to
eat card and we'll import the flutter
riverpod library now I can return this
tweet list
from the Tweet list I can return this
tweet card but obviously we'll have to
pass in the Tweet over here
I'll accept it through the Constructor
over there so I have final
tweet tweet and I'll require this
through the Constructor
so we have required this dot Twee so the
error goes away now let's get to the
main thing what do we want to return
well first of all we want to return a
column
and in that column we are going to have
children and in that children the first
thing is a row why a row because we want
to have a circle Avatar to demonstrate
to you I'll show you one year is a
circle Avatar the profile pic of the
user then we have the name of the user
here we are going to have reply so if
there is any reply we will have that if
there's a retweet there it is going to
be above the username and then we are
going to have the text of the user if
there are any images the image of the
user
at the last we are going to have a
divider
so that there's a great division between
the next tweet as well
so we need a column so that we can
accommodate the divider and then we need
a row so that we can have the user
avatarp or use a profile picture along
with their name
so now I'm just going to return a row so
that I can have
a circle Avatar and this circle Avatar
is the users
image
and we'll pass in the background image
but now we need the image of the user
who has tweeted this we cannot do final
current user is equal to ref dot watch
current user details provider dot value
we cannot get their value by doing this
this is not
the image of the person who's tweeted it
it's the image of the person
who's handling the app right now so it
will vary for every person we want to
get the details of the person who's
uploaded the tweet
so to do that we'll have to create a new
provider and actually we don't have to
create it we have already created it and
that is ref.watch
user details provider here we just have
to mention the uid of the user and that
is tweet.uid dot when
it will give us data error and all of
those stuff in case of data we'll do
something in case of error and loading
we can just go over here copy both of
these things
come to the Tweet card and
paste it
now I can copy the column
and here return
column
now to get the background image it's
just going to be Network image
and let's call this user so there will
be
user Dot
profile picture
now if I save this much you can see we
are getting these profile pictures now
they're the same ones as this user
because it's the same user
we created the tweet from here and we
are viewing it over here
but if you try it on a different device
with a different login you'll see
different images
but if you used current user details
provider it would have given you
something else on a different device it
would give you the same thing over here
but it would be different on a different
device because it would use their
profile picture it wouldn't be the
person who tweeted that their profile
picture won't be available so you have
to do this it's very important and don't
mess it up because I've messed it up
while I was developing this application
now I just want to increase the radius
so I'll just have radius 35
save it and this and this looks much
bigger that's great
now I'll just put a margin here so I can
just have a container
and put a margin of constant agencies
dot all
10.
so there's a margin of 10 everywhere and
this looks super cool
the next thing we need is a column we
had a column first so that we could put
in a divider then we add a row and
inside of that row itself
I want to put a column
why because here we are going to have a
list of things there is going to be
username the text of the user if they
are replying to anyone their reply tag
if they're retweeting to anyone the
retweeting tag and that
images so it's all going to be in this
column and then we are going to have
children and then there's going to be
retweeted thing but we are not going to
focus on retweeted thing right now we'll
focus on that when we add the retweet
feature
so you can just put a comment for now
that we want retweet it to be there next
thing is the row
and this row is going to contain the
username the user name with other rate
and the number of hours it has been
since they posted so it's going to be
again row this is a bit complex design
then we need a container because we need
to put in a margin so we have margin
engine search dot only
from right side we want 5.
and this will be constant
and the child will be text user dot name
because we want to display the name of
the user who has posted it
and now if we see this is test this is
good as well now I just want to style it
up a bit so we have constant
textile and then I'll pass in font
weight as font weight dot bold
and font size as 19.
if we save this much and come over here
this looks good
we have put a margin of 5 here because
the next thing that we are going to have
is the user name with at the rate as
well as the time ago it was posted
so here we are going to have
a string and there is going to be at the
rate but this is going to be
interpolated
like this so at the rate is there then
the user name that's a variable and thus
we have this but now we have to change
this a little bit
so here the font size should be 17 and
color should be
palette dot gray color
if you save that much this looks good
the font weight should go away
and now this looks nice
now we want to put the time ago it was
posted and to do that we are going to
use a package known as time ago this
will calculate the time ago it was
posted so we have tweeted at property
which will give us the time it was
posted and time ago will calculate the
time from right now to when it was
posted and give us give it us in a
format like four hours ago five hours
ago something like that then I have the
dot with me and then I can use
dollar
time ago dot format now I want to import
time ago so I can just do import time a
go dot dot as
time ago
now I can go over here and have time ago
dot format tweet dot Twitter Dot
and if I do this much
and see a wire you can see test user was
three hours ago
now I just want to reduce this to 3 H so
that there's not much space taken so how
I can do that is just by adding which is
en underscore short
so this will shorten it and now we just
have three h over here not three hours
ago that's a very big thing now the next
thing in the column so we'll get out of
this this column as well
this row sorry we'll get out of this row
and then we'll have another thing
which is replied to
so if there is any reply to we want to
add that tag but we will do that later
on when we add a reply feature
then we need
a text so we can just have
a simple text right but we also want to
identify hashtags or links in that case
so how can we do that well for that we
are going to create a separate widget
called hashtag underscore text dot dot
we're going to import material lot we
are going to create a stateless widget
called hashtag
text
we are going to have final string text
and require it through the Constructor
so you have required this dot text
and here since we want some parts
colored in white which is a normal text
and we want some part to be colored in
blue so for that we'll have to use text
man so we'll have a list of text span
over here
so we have text spans which is equal to
an empty list
and then we can do text Dot split so
that we split all the words in the
sentence
we've already looked at this logic and
we'll run a for loop on it we can also
run a map for each whatever you prefer
I'll run a for each Loop and here I'll
just check if the value
or the element so if element dot starts
with
so if it starts with hashtag I want to
add a text pan to this text spans list
second I have text pans dot add text
span the text will be there which will
be dollar element
and in a string format and we leave a
space here why have we left space we
have left space because you have left we
have split the sentences by spaces so we
have a list of words so if we add ribbon
awat
as a sentence
and then now we have Revan
in a list format with ranavat now we are
just adding them so we have driven added
together so we have everyone and then
run over there's no space between them
right so we have to leave a space then
we can have style which will be constant
textile
color will be palette dot blue color and
font size will be 18. bigger than the
normal and let's also bold it so that
you know it looks a bit different so we
have font weight dot bold
now as if the value Dot
not value element dot starts with let's
say www dot or http
so we have https
colon slash slash then we will have
something similar so we'll have text
pans dot add this this is also going to
be blue color and bold and all of that
stuff
let's just remove both so that there's
some distinguishing Factor
and else will be the normal text so we
have text pans dot add
we add the value but this is just going
to have a font size of 18. it's not
going to be blue color
it's just going to be the same size as
these two three or these two
and now what I want to return is a rich
text because it requires a widget to be
returned and here
I'll pass in
the text as text pan
and it will have children as text spans
so you have returned a rich text widget
with a text pan having its children as
it expands that we just created over
here
and now I can just have hashtag text
pass in the text which is tweet Dot
text and now if we come over here you
can see the UI is totally dismantled but
we are getting our hashtags and links
colored this is great now to fix this
what we can do is wrap the column widget
over here with expanded widget
since we are in a row container takes
this much and then we have text that's
overflowing so we want text to get all
the maximum space and if there's no
maximum space it can just go down
so we'll just wrap this and if we come
back yep it looks fine now
but you can see this text is not in the
center is in the center we want it to
start from here so we can go up here
again wrap the column widget with cross
access alignment as cross access
alignment dot start
paste it and everything starts from the
left side now the next thing that I need
is images to show up so if tweet dot
tweet type is equal equal to
tweet type dot images
so if we are having an image as the
tweet type then we want to do something
braces are not allowed while rendering
this this is an if collection so to have
that we are going to create a separate
widget on its own and that is going to
be called Carousel image dot dot we can
import material Dot
we can create a stateful widget because
there's a lot of stuff going on here
basically we have an options button so
if the user wants to
know which
image we are on or if it wants to click
over there and go to a certain image
they can definitely do that
and this is going to be final list of
string image links
will require this through the
Constructor
and now where we are going to create a
variable called in current is equal to
zero this means the current index of the
a match to be displayed is zero
and now we are going to return a stack
and there is going to be children why is
it a stack
you'll get to know
our first child is now column
the column is now having children and
the first child
is the carousel slider
the carousel slider is the same thing as
what we had in create tweet view so we
can go there
copy the carousel slider mentioned there
and paste it in the children now I can
import Carousel slider I can map through
the image links
or widget dot image links
then do image.network
where we'll get
a link
and based on that link we have to do
image.network
and this will have a fit of box fit dot
contain and here the margin is going to
be in all the sites so we are going to
have margin dot all 10.
now just to see if it's working we'll
have Carousel image we'll paste it over
here pass in the image links which is
tweet dot image links and save it and
when we try to see the surveyor we are
getting this error this is because we it
is not able to fetch the images and for
that we have to give them a proper
permission so in the storage we'll have
to go to the images tab go to settings
and here add a role for
any user that they can create grid
update delete and then click on update
now if you restart the application
you can see all of the images showing up
so the error is now gone
now let's beautify this further how can
we do that first of all
in the carousel slider
we want the viewport fraction to be one
we want to disable the infinite scroll
and this looks much bigger already that
is nice and in the stack we want
alignment as alignment Dot Center
so it's right in the center also the
width will be removed here and the
decoration of box decoration
border radius
border radius dot circular
25 will be added let's see if this much
and here we are going to have one more
thing on page changed we will get index
and reason and then in the search state
we are going to set current variable
that is global equal to index so
whatever Index this Carousel options
give us we'll set that to the global
variable current
now the next thing after this is row
widget because we want to display a
bunch of circles so that we know how
many images are there and stuff
so when the children
we are not going to return a list wire
we are instead going to have widget dot
image links Dot as map
dot entries so we're going to treat them
as map and get the entries and map
through each entry
and return a gesture detector
we also convert it to a list so that we
don't get any error
right now we are getting entered because
we're not returning anything so we have
to return
a container
which has the width as 12 the height as
and margin will be Edge insets
dot symmetric in the horizontal
Direction we'll have 4.
and this will also be constant
and now we want to create a circular
shape so we are going to have box
decoration
shape as box shape dot Circle
and color will be
colors dot White
dot with opacity and the opacity will
differ because if it's current
so basically if current is equal equal
to e dot key
e is basically this one so if the
current matches the current index we are
on then we want the opacity to be more
right so it will be 0.9 otherwise it
will be less
opaque
so we'll have 0.4 and here you can see
we are getting this thing looks good and
this was the entire Carousel image we
had Carousel slider and then we had a
row depending on where we were so now if
I just try to you know go back and forth
you can see we are getting the correct
highlight on this
now in the Tweet card we have to make
certain changes again so we'll go at the
top in the row you can see we have cross
access alignment we have to pass in
Cross access alignment dot start so that
you know our Circle Avatar moves at the
top not in the center then we will have
another thing which is if you want to
display the link so if tweet dot link
not likes link dot is not empty so if
tweet.link is not empty that means we
can display a link
and it has identified a link for us to
display then we will leave some space
from the top so if we have constant size
box height 4
and then we will install a package
called any link preview this will open
up a preview of any link as the name
suggests of the package and to use this
we just have to do any link preview
we will get a link so we have to pass in
the link which will be https colon slash
slash
dollar
tweet dot link
let's import the any link preview
package save it and here it is and it's
not displaying as of now because we have
to restart the application
so let's restart it and while that is
happening let's get on to the next step
which is the icon buttons to show up
below the
tweet so basically like comment all of
those things so here we are going to
have another feature or another widget
called tweet icon button
dot dot we will import material dot for
it we are going to create a stateless
widget called it tweet icon button
then we are going to have final string
path name the path name is the name of
the part to the flutter SVG icon that we
are going to use
then we are going to have final string
text so what is the counter how many
tweets have happened so how many
retweets have happened how many likes
have happened all of those stuff
and avoid call back tab so we avoid
callback on tap
now we just need to
generate a Constructor for all of this
and now we are going to return a gesture
detector so any of this is Click what
should happen
and in the on Tab we'll pass in the on
Tab and in the child we are going to
have a row and in that row we are going
to have children of SVG
picture.asset.first
and what is the path name well that will
be decided from The Constructor whatever
value is passed through the Constructor
then we need a color and color will be
palette dot gray color
then we need text
and the text will be text that's from
The Constructor again and style will be
constant textile
font size 16. so it should be smaller
than the
tweet text that is showed up
and obviously we need some margin so we
can have a container
and have margin constant Edge and such
dot all
six
save this much
you can see our links are also showing
up but I don't want my link to show up
like this I want it in another format
which is
which can be changed through display
Direction which is UI Direction dot UI
Direction horizontal
and now
it's in a different format I like it in
this format so after this link we need
to pass in our tweet icon button that we
just created and before that we want a
margin from top and right so we are
going to wrap it with a container so
that everything doesn't stick together
right so we have container
then we have margin and then we are
going to have constant Edge inside dot
only from the top I want 10 and from the
right I want 20. and the child will be a
row and the row will have children and
the first child in this is going to be
tweet
I can button there's going to be path
name so the path name is going to be
assets constants Dot View icon
the text is going to be 0 as of now
and the on tap is going to do nothing
let's see how this looks here it is
looking good
also I can have main access alignment as
main access alignment dot space between
so that when you have more icons it will
look better not congested
now also in the text I just realized the
views can be counted like tweet dot
comment IDs Plus
not plus comment ids.length Plus
tweet.reshare count dot length
this doesn't require link because it's
just integer and then tweet dot likes
dot length
and convert all of them to a string and
display it out so this has zero right
now
now the next tweet icon button is
of comment so we have comment icon
and this is just going to have
tweet dot comment IDs dot length Dot
tostring
so let's remove this and this looks good
now the third icon we need is a retweet
icon so we can have retweet icon and
this will be
reshare count
dot to string
great now the third fourth button that
we need is a like button for now we are
going to have this but like button it's
going to be a little bit different
because of the animation we are going to
add to it and the text is going to be
likes dot length dot to string
and the final button we are going to
have here is not going to be a tweet
icon button it's actually going to be
just an icon button because I didn't
find the need to find
an icon for it and it's going to be
constant I can ikins Dot share
underscore outline now if you see a wire
this looks good you can change its size
by having size as 25 and color AS
Palette dot gray color now let's just
leave a space after this container so we
have constant size box of height
1 and at the end of this column you see
this was a big row I told you that we
added the parent column so that we could
add a divider at the end so I'm just
going to have a constant divider over
here and this divider is going to have a
color of palette dot gray color
sweet and now we have this this looks
superb if you put this divider over here
instead this will only cover this part
of the row
that's why we didn't add it over here we
added it right below the last column and
this looks much more better
and this also concludes the entire UI
right
now other things like the like animation
replying part the retweeting part we'll
add them as and when we get to it right
we just don't want to mess everything up
and put everything together
the next focus of this app is going to
be making
stuff real time so basically if I try to
you know tweet here like hello
and tweet it out
come over here you can see Hello is not
shown
this hello is the previous hello three
hours ago not the current one only when
I restart my app
can I see the hello here
so I want this
hello to show up real time so we'll have
to use real Time That's provided by app
right over here and it's going to be
very fun so let's get into it but before
that let's see why our UI looks so off
with this part right here we have three
buttons over here we have an image but
this looks very weird because it takes a
lot more space than expected one problem
is the high touch taking so if we come
back over here we remove this height and
come back you can see it takes only that
much height that it's needed it doesn't
require
all the height correct
and these buttons over here they are not
centered we want them to be centered so
we can have main access alignment as
main access alignment Dot Center and now
they're right in the center and this
looks more Compact and better
now let's get started with real time so
to get started with it we are going to
go to the Tweet API create our abstract
class which is to get latest tweet so in
the abstract class here we are going to
create a stream this real time gives us
a stream and it will give us a stream of
something known as a real-time message
and it is going to give us one latest
tweet so let me just type it out get
latest tweet it's not going to give us
you know a list of tweets that are new
or anything like that it will give us
one single tweet that just came in real
time works like socket so it is just
going to give you the latest event that
it has and just present it to you so
that you can display or do whatever you
want to do with that so now I'm just
going to create one missing override
Come Away up and now
we have to use real time now to use real
time of course we'll have to import it
from The Constructor so let's have final
real time underscore real time here
then we are going to require this so we
have required real time
real time
and then underscore real time should be
equal to real time that we are getting
from the parameter here
easy now we can go down also let's see
why we are getting this error we have to
provide real time now real time is
provided by app right and for every
single app right
dependency we have created a provider so
let's just go over there and create a
last provider which is the app right
real-time provider you can see how our
work is getting reused every single time
we use a provider we don't have to
continuously create instances
only one time we have to create this and
it works well for us in the entire
application
here let's just provide real time which
is ref.watch real time
app right real-time provider
now we can come down here and return
something so we need to return whatever
will be returned so let's just call real
time and see what it does so if we do
real time and if we do subscribe you can
see we can subscribe to a list of string
of channels so let's just first have a
string and then just see what subscribe
method gives us it gives us a real-time
subscription but here we want to return
a stream of real-time message
so over here we have something known as
dot stream it will convert this into
this format
now we need to subscribe to a particular
Channel now what are these particular
channels you can find a list of them on
the app right documentation it's present
over there
or otherwise if you want to understand
it logically from
the point of view of database so let's
just go over there
we are going to use real time for
databases so if there is any changes
made in the database in a particular
collection or in a particular document
we're going to track it through this
subscribe method of real time but if you
want to do the same for storage so for a
particular file or a bucket you can do
that and
the channel name for it is present in
the description below
basically you'll find the app right
documentation where you can find
literally everything well written
so let's just go to the database now
let's understand what we need to track
we need to track the tweets collection
and see if any tweet is being created
right
so for that what are we going to do to
understand that let's go to the main app
right dashboard
the first thing we need to do
when we are in our project is go to the
databases so we need to enter a database
ID right so here we can just have
databases Dot
so it will go to the databases and then
we want to go to the particular database
ID so now when we go to the particular
database ID we need to enter that as
well and a database ID is present in app
right constants dot database ID now
after databases where do we want to go
to a collection and that is the tweets
collection so we can just write dot
collections over here
and after that dot dollar app right
constants
dot which collection the tweets
collection because we want to see if any
tweet is being created
and then
we just want to keep track of the
documents we don't want to track any
particular document because we want to
track if a new tweet is being created or
not so here we are just going to have
dot documents and that's our entire
Channel we go to a database by and then
pass in the database ID then we want to
go to the collections pass in the
collection ID and then we keep track of
the overall documents not just one
particular document if you want to do
that you can do document dot dollar app
right constants with a particular
document ID but not that for my case
right sweet so our get latest tweet is
now done it will give us the latest
tweet that it gets if it doesn't give
any latest tweet there will be a loading
indicator
you'll understand that when we write the
code for it in the UI file but before
that we need to convert
we don't even need to convert it
actually
I was going to say that we need to
convert this real-time message that it
gets
in the form of
a tweet but we don't need to do that
because in the UI file we need to check
some things we need to check that
if the Tweet is being created or it is
being updated or it is being deleted
whatever
here we have just told we need to keep
track of the documents don't forget to
put the S over here
we need to keep track of the documents
but we don't know what event is
happening on it it can either be
creation deletion whatever
so for that we are going to create a
stream provider
and let's just call this get latest
tweet provider
will remove the async star we are going
to get an instance of the Tweet API
directly we're not going to get an
instance of tweet controller what we
have been doing till now because we are
not going to register this function in
the Tweet controller because we don't
have any job for it
so now we can just have final tweet API
is equal to ref dot watch tweet API
provider and now we can return tweet API
dot get latest tweet of course you can
put this function
get latest tweet in the Tweet controller
as well and just call underscore tweet
API Dot
get latest tweet and then use the
controller over here but why do we have
to do so much when there's literally
nothing happening in the controller for
it
so we just have this now of course if
you want you can add Auto dispose Auto
dispose
will Auto dispose your provider and it's
always a good thing to add beside every
provider I forgotten to do that so go
ahead add Auto dispose everywhere it
will be mentioned in my GitHub
repository so if you are referring to
that I'm sure you'll find
Auto dispose over there it's similar to
dot family so these are two modifiers on
providers
you'll get them on stream future
providers you'll also get it on the
normal provider anyways now let's go to
our
create tweet View
not create tweet view sorry the Tweet
list and here we are also going to watch
for getting the latest tweet so right
now we are just watching the get tweets
provider which is a future provider now
we want to do it real time and if there
is any changes in real time
we are going to display it in the UI if
you don't understand this I'll explain
it to you through a diagram so we have
our device over here
a very slim device
and we have a list of tweets that are
showing up okay now these tweets are
powered by Future provider as of now
they are not real time they basically
build only once when the app is loaded
and since we are using stack even if we
go here and come back it's not going to
change what I mean by this is since we
have used index stack and if we scroll
down it will process the state and it
will come back
to where we had scrolled basically it's
not rebuilt in this entire project
so the future provider is not going to
get rebuilt anytime
but now what we want is our app
look real time now to make it look real
time you had added real time which is
something provided by app right and no
external configurations are required for
it
so after we get those latest tweets we
are just checking if another tweet is
being created or not if it is being
created we can get it from the real time
so here instead of returning list view
Builder directly
what we are going to say is have
basically another real-time provider
here it constantly listens to any
changes in our mentioned channel the
channel what was what we had mentioned
over here
so it continuously listens
and if there is any change so if there
is create update
it will directly affect in our
application that's how we are going to
create it
so the data from future provider shows
up but the data real-time provider gives
us will be added to our data to be
rendered on the screen if you don't
understand this let's write the code and
I hope you'll understand after that
so right now what I want to return here
is not a list view Builder I'll just
comment it out I want to return
ref dot watch get latest tweet provider
dot when
and when we have data when we have error
along with stack Trace
and when we have loading we have to
handle all of these states
so this is what we want to return now in
case of error and loading we add this
but in case of data what do we want to
show well that's the point we are
getting a real-time message here so
let's see what real-time message gives
us it gives us channels so the channels
we subscribe to
events so what events are happening
payload so what data is there inside of
the real-time message so basically what
exactly is the data that got modified
that will be mentioned the timestamp so
what time was it updated or created
whatever
so we have all of this now what matters
to us is first we want to check if the
data was created or it was updated so if
it was created then we want to insert it
into our array and our array is
tweets.link we want to insert it into it
but if it was being modified then we
want to send the modified data inside of
this tweets array
so let's write the code for this we are
just going to check if data dot events
so what was the event was it being
created or updated
so
this gives us a list so you want to
check if data.events contains some event
so what is the event we are looking for
well it's very similar to this let's go
to our tweet API
so we have this and then we pass that in
so we have if database dot
events.contains databases and here we
are going to have dots tar that means
anything any database and the collection
should be apprite.tweets collection so
let's have that
dot documents
Dot
any document dot create now I'll explain
this code to you but let me just
format this a little bit so what just
happened here so if data events contains
this part so the data that we got right
now
if it was being created
then what do we want to do so to check
if it was being created we went to
databases dot star so it can be any
database I've done this any because
right now we just have a testing
database that means a debugging database
if you release this app on production
you'll create a new database how will
you do that if you go to the app right
console go to your Twitter clone
application
in the databases tab you can create a
new database you can see that so I did
dot star so that it works everywhere dot
collections
and then the upright tweet collection
dot documents.star so we want to check
for any document not just one document
any document and if create
is there then what do you want to do we
want to update the tweets because that
is being returned in the list view
Builder correct
so let's just take this and put it right
here outside of the if condition inside
this get latest tweet provider
so if it is being created what do I want
to do I just want to show it up in the
list so we have tweets that is being
used
to display
the tweets over here right
so I can just have tweet dot insert now
we can do tweets dot add or we can do
tweets dot insert we are using tweets
dot insert not tweets Dot
add because tweets.ad will add the
tweet at the last of the list we don't
want to add it in the last of the list
we want to add it at the top
so here we are just going to have twitch
dot insert 0 so if we do it at 0 it will
come right at the top of the list and
then we want to specify the element
right
don't worry using insert will not
replace any element all the other
elements will shift and insert will just
add
the latest tweet
to the start
and now we can just have tweet
Dot from map and then we'll pass in data
dot payload I told you payload contains
the data
the actual data so we can just use
payload so every time this happens
we are going to insert 0 comma
data dot payload and this is cool so
let's restart our application
and here you can see we're continuously
getting the loading indicator now if you
want to check which loading indicator is
this this one or this one
you can go ahead and print it but I know
that this is coming from this loading
because earlier this works fine now why
are we getting this loading now how
Real Time with upright works is
it keeps on loading until we get a
trigger so basically until an event gets
created so until this create or update
or anything happens
we keep on getting the loading indicator
and if you don't use riverpod you won't
even get to know that it is being loaded
you won't get anything in the terminal
you won't see anything on the screen
but inside of it it's not actually
loading it's just saying that it doesn't
really have any data right now
so it just keeps on loading over here
because data loading is the state where
there is no error and there's no data
right so how can we fix this problem
well my solution to this was just
returning a list view Builder away up so
the exact same listview Builder that we
are having over here can be passed in
the loading indicator and now if we
restart
we get the Tweet showing up
correct
and now if you want to test our logic
over here
we can go ahead create a tweet so I'll
just say hello what's
up
and I can click on Tweet now if I go
back you can see in real time hello
WhatsApp shows up
if I remove this line these two Logics
and try to
rerun the application you'll see that
real time doesn't work we'll have to
reload the entire application but with
real time everything works well real
time
now if you're still not clear about the
loading indicator and how this entire
process work let me brief you through it
if you have understood make sure to skip
forward
to the next part
so basically what we're trying to do
here is just
getting the tweets provider first so we
have a list of tweets with us
after we get the list of tweets with us
we are continuously checking if you are
getting any latest tweet provider or we
are not getting any latest tweet
so once we get the latest tweet
we are going to get a data and you have
your checking if the create
is being triggered on a document if the
create is triggered on a document we
just convert it to a tweet model using
the data.payload which consists of the
tweets data
and insert it to the top of the list
and since this has changed our list view
Builder will also change and it will
rerun this part
but what about the loading part what did
I mention there well you saw
continuously the loading indicator was
being run
that was because there was neither any
data nor was there any error because
real time gives us
data
only when a certain event is triggered
so if a create function is triggered
update
delete
any of this is called only then will
data have some value otherwise it will
have no value it will
no have no error it will just keep on
loading
so to fix that what I did was add a list
view Builder here
so as long as it's loading just show a
list view Builder
but anytime we get some data over here
which is a stream provider right so it
can continuously listen so as soon as we
get some data this will get triggered
and this entire function will run so
we'll come over here now if you still
don't understand I would recommend you
to print
the loading over here
and print data aware and see how it's
working by restarting the application
that will give you a sense of what's
Happening
okay so now the next thing that we need
to work on is if you see when we restart
the application our hello WhatsApp goes
down I want my latest tweets to show up
right at the top
so what I can do is go to my tweet API
in my get tweets function I'll add
something known as queries queries will
allow me to add like queries to my
application through which I can make
many changes to add queries you can just
do query Dot and you can see a ton of
options it gives you closer after
because of before these two are used for
pagination and they are very efficient
there's limit also used with apagenation
offset also used for pagination their
uses can be seen in the
upright documentation or if you want I
can create a separate tutorial on it I'm
not going to cover pagination in this
tutorial
then we have order ascending or order
descending so basically in what order do
we want to arrange our tweets well for
us order descending order ascending is
what is showing up here the
last weeks
or the older tweets show up first
but we want it in an opposite order
order descending and what is the
attribute so what is the property
According to which we should
put it in the descending order well it's
because of the time so we'll just have
tweet it at So based on tweeting ad I
want my documents to be listed other
queries here are equal to greater than
search we are going to use some of them
later on in the application when we go
to the searching users part
but for now let's restart our
application and here you can see we are
getting this error we're getting this
error because whenever we create an
attribute
or a query we need to register it in our
database so here you can see whenever we
have a new property to add we can add it
over here but whenever we have some
index to be added this is all index
so whenever we add indexes to add we
need to click away our create index so
what is this index
going to be called
tweet defending
then the type of this index is key
the attribute here is
tweeted at and the order should be
descending now I'll click on Create and
our index is now created now if I try to
run my application you can see this
works six minutes First shows up then 17
hours 20 hours 21 hours
now if I again try to create a tweet
let's say hello
with many exclamation marks but other
thing is whenever I click on tweet I
don't pop off the screen so to pop off
the screen I have to go back
to the create tweet view where we have
created on
sharing tweet we just have to call
Navigator Dot
pop
we are not adding pop in the share tweet
over here right after here we are not
adding it over here the reason for that
is
this shared tweet will be reused in
another
feature which is replying to tweets
anyways now let's try to tweet it out
and our screen is popped off and if we
just go up you can see Hello with many
exclamation marks showing up our app is
now real time now the next thing we need
is this like button we want this light
to work so the first thing we are going
to do is animate the like button to
animate the like button we have to go to
the Tweet card and here first of all
I'll just add a dependency of like
underscore button this button gives us
the nice
animation of Twitter
and here we want to scroll down and we
want to replace the like outlined icon
with this like button so we have like
button over here let's have that
and now we'll give it a size of 25 so
that it matches with every other icon
then you have to have a like build up so
basically if it is liked what do we have
to build
I'm based on this like so I'll have is
liked so if it is like let me just have
this so if it is like then I want to
return so I'll just have return is like
and if it is like then I want to return
SVG picture
dot asset and I want like filled icon so
I can just copy this
and just have like filled icon
and obviously if it is not then I'll
have
this thing but with like outlined icon
okay now I just need to mention the
color and stuff
so if it is filled we are obviously
going to get the red color
so I'll have color palette dot red color
mind if it is not then I want color to
be palette Dot
gray color
all right now let's see if I try to
click over here nothing really happens
let me just remove this
and now if I try to do this you can see
we are getting the nice
effect
now after this we also want to show the
like count so we'll have like count and
like count is basically tweet dot likes
dot link
we'll save it and here we see the
counter but now I also want to change
the color of this counter so now how can
I do that I can just have count Builder
passed in
it will give me these three properties
like count is light and text so here I
can just pass in
a text I'll return text and pass in the
text
with a style and the style is going to
be textile
and really depends
what should be the color so the color
can be
red if the
to eat as light and if it's
not like then it should be white so we
can have
if it is liked so is like so if it is
like then I want to have
palette dot red color otherwise palette
Dot gray color and obviously mention
your color
I also need the font size so we can have
font size and person 16 over there
because right now it feels very small
now I can save this much go away
it still looks out of place because this
should be white color now after having
this it matches with the rest of the
things
but still let's just add a little bit of
padding from left so I can just have a
padding widget
and from the left I want two to be
present I'll save it and this matches
with other things now
so if I click over here
the counter increases and if it's not
then it doesn't
now we want to get into the actual
liking part so I'll go to the Tweet API
and here we are going to create our next
function in our abstract class which is
going to be
liking the Tweet so we're going to have
future either document we are having
future either not future because as I
said not everything that our future
needs to be in the future provider and
we'll get like tweet over here and we'll
just accept tweet from the model aware
now we'll create a missing override for
this go down
pass in async then we need a try catch
block all of those stuff I would
recommend you to type it I'll just copy
it and paste it down here
okay great now after having this now
let's understand how this liking feature
works well basically I want to go to my
particular document the particular tweet
that has been clicked on and liked I
want to go there I just want to increase
the likes over here so basically I want
to add likes to this array
and this should work I like tweet is now
complete this is exactly what's needed
so I want to update this document
so let's find if DB has anything like
that and
it does have an option of update
document so we are going to use this
we'll pass in the database ID The
Collection ID the document ID the
document ID is not going to be ID dot
unique anymore because we want to update
a certain document the document that was
clicked on and we are getting the
document ID from this tweet that we are
accepting from the parameter so we can
just tab tweet.id
for the data we can pass in a map
and here just say that you want to
update one certain
attribute over here which is the likes
field and here I just want to pass and
tweet dot likes okay
if you're wondering why are we having
tweet dot likes won't the likes be the
same as before then well no because when
we use this like tweet in our controller
we're going to update this tweet model
so when we are on this tweet we are
going to update the user model to have
the users like
so the user's ID in it
and then only we are going to send it to
the API so basically we'll just go to
the Tweet controller
we will have a new function created
which is like tweet and here we are
going to get the Tweet model so
basically whatever tweet we are going to
have over here this is going to be the
old tweet before the updating what does
the Tweet look like
and the user model of the current user
we can get that from ref.watch as well
but if we use it right now over here
when the user clicks we will get an
error because
it will think
that the uid is null you can try it on
your own by using ref dot read current
user provider
dot value but you will get
the error so we are directly getting it
from the tweet
card itself
now we are going to have list of string
of likes so what is the likes well it's
just tweet dot likes right why are we
storing this in the likes variable
independently well because there's a lot
of logic to put in here so if the Tweet
is already liked suppose it's this way
and the user again clicks on the like
button we want to remove the like and if
the
like is not already there and we click
on it we want to add it to the likes
array so here we are going to check if
tweet dot likes dot contains
user.uid so if the Tweet like array
contains the user's ID
that means that the user has already
liked it and it he has already clicked
on the button so the case is right now
like this the user has liked the tweet
and we want to click on it so basically
we want to remove the tweet to remove
the Tweet what can we do we can just do
likes dot remove and what should the
value be well the user.uid
so you want to remove the current user's
ID else the Tweet dot likes does not
contain the user ID and we want to add
that user ID so we can have like likes
dot add user dot uid simple
now we will set tweet equal to
tweet.copy with
remember that copy with function that we
created
since the likes field is immutable so
basically tweet dot likes as immutable I
cannot update its value
actually for an array I can do that
but
this cannot be done for
another field so example tweet Dot
ID
you cannot set it
to something else you know it will give
you an error ID cannot be used as a
setup because it's final
so you cannot do this
but you can do this for an array
because we have not returned an
unmodifiable array or mod unmodifiable
list
anyways
we are going to have copy with so
basically what we are doing is setting
tweet equal to tweet.copy with so we
want to update a field and the field as
likes
because we have updated the likes field
according to our logic here
and we are updating the Tweet
accordingly so now the tweet
has updated like number or the updated
like array
now I can just do final result is equal
to await so let's put async over here
and have a weight underscore tweet API
dot like tweet and then we'll pass in
the street and that's why we have
directly put in like
likes is tweet dot likes we do not have
to do
tweet dot likes dot add or remove all of
the logic has been put in the controller
over here
and then we can just do res dot fold in
case of a failure we don't want to show
anything in case of a success we don't
want to do anything
why do we want to show nothing in case
of failure because it's a like button
that's clicked on have you ever seen a
message that when you click on a like
button you get any error so you don't
want to show any error even if it is
there and also you might notice that we
have not
set status equal to true and state is
equal to false because whenever we like
a tweet we don't see a loading indicator
right
that's why now we just need to bind this
to our like button over here so we'll
have an ontap function
is like and now we are going to have ref
dot read
tweet control of Provider dot Notifier
dot like tweet we know all of this now
we have access to tweet as well which is
the user tweet we are getting from the
Constructor and we also have access to
the user model
which is
the user who has created the Tweet but
we don't want the user who has created
the Tweet we want to
have our own current user right we don't
want to check with this logic that
if the Tweet dot likes contains the
person who has created the tweets their
ID we don't want to check that we want
to check if the tweet. likes contains
our own uid
so that's why this user won't work we
have to get final current user which is
equal to ref.watch
current user details provider
dot value and now we are going to check
over here so if current user is null so
if current user is equal equal to null
then I want a loader to show up
otherwise this or even if not a loader
we want a size box to show up
anything works now we can just come over
here
I have this and see why are we getting
this error we're getting this error
because it requires a future Boolean so
to make a future we love ad async and
now we want to return a Boolean
so on tap should the like change so yeah
it should change so vlab is like this is
like variable gives us whether the Tweet
was liked or disliked here we are just
saying if it was like then we want to
return opposite of Light which is not
liked and if it was not like now it is
liked right now we can restart the
application
and let's find this particular tweet the
hello tweet
it's this one only
so now I'll click on
like button over here
I'll click on restart
and we're not getting anything in our
likes array the reason for that it's
very simple if we go back to the
settings
the current user is only allowed to
create or read it's not allowed to
update or delete so you want to allow
the updation as well now after updating
let's go to back to our documents
restart the app
now if you click on hello
you can see it was updated and if we go
to our hello document
the likes is present over there and if I
again click over here the likes was
removed if I reached fresh the light
source remove this works fine but there
is a problem if you see we're not
getting the circled over here why
and also if you see the view counter
increased in real time
no other tweet increased its view only
this particular did so to make this
animation work let's
go to the like button and see
there seems to be some problem with the
is liked part so here we'll just add an
is like the option so when is the like
is light
it requires a Boolean field so when it's
like it is liked initially only when it
is when tweets dot likes so let me have
tweet
dot likes dot contains my user ID so we
have current user dot uid so if the
Tweet dot likes contains the user ID
then is light will be true otherwise it
will be false and right now it contains
it so if I remove it it doesn't contain
it now if I put it back it contains if I
remove it it doesn't if I put it back
you can see it contains otherwise it
doesn't now to give you the second
answer that is
why does this work why does this real
time work well this is because of how
the Tweet like button works this is not
really happening real time because of
our real time tweet list call over here
the thing we've put here it's not
happening because of that this is
happening because this is how the like
button package works it automatically
updates it listening a task
and since this update this will also
update because tweet dot likes dot
length increases now that we have this
the like button also seems to be working
the next part is now clicking on the
retweet so whenever we click on the
retweet this counter should update
and a new tweet should be added with the
same user's ID so this should be there
the same tweet but above should be
written that test retweeted or some
other like Revan tweeted retweet it
sorry so you want that tag to be
appearing so first of all we'll start
off by closing all the save files
we'll again come to the Tweet API and
here we're going to create a new
function in our abstract class and this
is called
update reshare count because we only
want to update the reshare account
so this will be the exact same thing
future either document but this time
update reshare count
we'll get a tweet
this is exactly similar to the like
feature but instead of adding a new
likes array we are going to update the
reshare count
and this should be asynchronous and
after updating the document we don't
want to update the likes array we want
to update the reshare
count so if we go to the Tweet model and
see what the name was it was a reshare
count
and this should be tweet.tree share
easy now similar to the like feature we
are going to update this reshare count
counter in our tweet controller so we
can go over there
we can copy this void like tweet and
avoid
re-share tweet
so we get the current user so let's just
type in that we want a current user and
we also need a build context because if
there is a problem while re-sharing
because it is a big process
we basically want to create a new tweet
and save it to our database
we will display an error in case of any
error
so what do we want to do here well let's
just remove everything
we will call reshare update reshare
count and pass in the Tweet but now we
have to perform the updating logic and
after updating we also want to share the
Tweet again right
so that this retweet appears
now here there's also another thing to
be done which is updating the Tweet
model
here we want to add two important fields
we want to add a field called final
string
retweeted by
so who whom was this tweet retweeted by
so we'll have required this dot
retweeted by
then we'll have string
retweeted by sorry but it tweeted by
let's copy this field so that we don't
make any error
then we'll pass it over here so it will
be retweeted by retweeted bias not null
then we want this dot retweeted by
then we add it over here as well result
dot add all
retweeted by in a string should be equal
to retweeted by
then we'll have retweeted by map
retweeted by
otherwise an empty string
we'll also add it to the tostring
function retweeted by is Dollar
retweeted by
we'll add it to r equal equal to
operator retweeted other dot retweeted
by is equal equal to retweeted by
and finally over here tweeted by dot
hash code
to be added now if you click over here
and again try to generate the data class
it will work for you no doubt about that
but again you will get the idea
over here like a normal ID we want it to
be slash dollar ID so make sure you have
that
okay now coming back to this tweet is
equal to
Tweet now what we want to do is update
the field over here not the likes part
but the retweeted part so now initially
the Tweet wasn't retweeted by anyone now
it is retweeted by
current user dot name so this is a guy
who retweeted
also way up in our share image tweet
under share text tweet we get this error
because we made it a compulsory field to
be added so of course we'll have to add
it over here as well but when there is
no retweeted by so basically it is our
own original tweet it is going to be
empty and later on in our uiv will check
if retweeted by a DOT is empty so if it
is empty we don't want to display
anything but if it is not empty there's
some username then we will show that
this was a retweeter tweet
now we'll again put it here now we can
go right at the top where our research
tweeters
and here what we want to do is set likes
to an empty field
so since this tweet is getting reshared
we want to set the likes to an empty
field the comment ID should be empty
field because we don't want any comments
or likes to be present now
and the reshare count should be
tweet dot reshare count plus one so the
new reshare count is going to be the old
reshare count plus one
now we'll update the reshare count and
send it across then we'll have rest dot
fold in case of any error we want to
show snack bar saying l dot message and
in case of any success which is r
we have to do one more task so we'll
pass this as async right now we just
updated the original tweets
reshare count correct
so we have updated its
reshare count now we want to create a
new tweet saying that this tweet was
created and retweeted by so earlier when
we added retweeted by likes and comment
IDs they were not required when we were
doing this part I just added them so
that I don't have to do it over here
here what I want to do is
just have final rest 2 equal to await
underscore tweet API dot share tweet
so I want to share the tweet
with this but of course I have to make
one more chain your Tweet
should be equal to tweet.copy with and I
want to update the ID of the Tweet
correct
so the ID is going to be ID dot uni
we are going to take this from upright
only and the reshare count should be
zero here we have updated the reshare
count now we are again putting it back
to zero after this updated reshare count
function has been called
and we are setting ID to a unique ID
because earlier what we did was use the
idea where we use the reshare account so
this was original tweets ID and
reshare.com now since we are creating a
new tweet and a new ID on its own we
need to update these fields
so basically all of these three Fields
weren't even needed here they can be put
here but I just wanted to show that you
can also put it over here it doesn't
matter because the only things that are
being called in update reshare count are
the reshare count and the tweet.id so we
cannot update the ID over here as ID
dot unique
okay you have to do it right below after
this function is called
great now after all of this is done we
can just average 2 dot fold in case of
any error so show the snack bar
with l dot message and in case of right
we don't have to do anything as of now
now reset read functionality has been
created I'll go to the postcard or the
Tweet card and here where I have my
retweet button
I'm just going to call ref dot read
tweet controller provider dot Notifier
dot reshare tweet I'll pass in the Tweet
the current user the build context and
then get done don't use user aware
otherwise it won't work for you it will
actually give a very weird thing and you
won't understand why
I would recommend you to always use
good names over here not just user and
current user
something more appropriate but it serves
my understanding
anyways now that you have this done
let's restart
now here I'll try to reshare a tweet
actually once the reshare has been done
here let's just say show snack bar
it
tweeter
so what we have done over here is
updated the reshare count on the
original tweet and we have shared the
Tweet again so that it appears on Opera
file now if I click on one of this I'll
click on hello
you can see we are getting invalid
document structure because we have added
a new tweet I always forget to do this
thanks to the error messages they always
tell you the right thing so now I just
want to add a new attribute called
retweeted by which is going to be a
string
with size let's say 255 required
create
now I can restart
and since we're getting this error I
can't seem to resolve it to be honest so
I can just delete all the fields let's
just delete every single thing
so I can have my database empty now I'll
restart my app
this is all empty I can just type hey
over here I click on tweet I have this I
can click on like so like is there
I can click on retweet and the retweet
has taken place
and if I like it and then retweet you
can see there is retweet happening the
original likes are maintained new tweets
are being created and they show up real
time because of our app right real time
configuration and logic
but the counter is not updated on the
tweets you are retweeting
but if we restart
the counter is being updated
you can see one is over there one is
over here that means it is updating in
app writing we want to update it your
real time and another problem that I
have is retweeted by not showing up so I
want these two things to happen first
we'll work on the Tweet card where
we will add the retweet part so you can
see there we have added a comment of
retweeted we will replace this with our
own retweeted by and here again we are
going to have a row
and in this row we are going to have
children and the first child in this is
SVG picture dot asset
where we show the retweet icon so we
have asset constants dot retweet icon
color will be palette dot gray color and
the height will be 20. we'll increase it
from the normal height
after this we will leave some width so
we have constant
sized box of width
let's say 2
and then we are going to have a text
saying that this guy retweeted
so here we love dollar
tweet Dot
tweeted by and we have to put all of
this in a string because you want to
type this username guy has retweeted
and now you can see we are getting all
of this but
there are some problems
this retweeted shows up even for the
people who have not retweeted so here
we'll just add if tweet dot is retweeted
or the retweeted by sorry
is not empty so if this is not empty
only then we want to show this otherwise
just remove this
and this doesn't show up for this time
now the next issue I have is the font
size so let's increase it so we'll have
style constant textile
where the color will be colors or
palette dot gray color
font size will be improved to 16 and
font weight will be font weight dot w500
a little bit bolded so that you know it
differentiates from the username below
and this looks good so whenever we
retweet it shows up
now if I try to retweet something you
can see retweeted
he shows up test retweeted is also there
but now we want to update the counter
over here in real time
why is it not being updated
even though we have something present in
the Tweet list right we have added the
create trigger but that's the problem we
have added the create trigger it doesn't
listen for the update trigger we have
updated the like count we have updated
the retweet count correct
so here we'll just have an else block
so else or else if
else as if the data dot events so let me
just copy this correctly
else if data dot events dot contains
databases dot star all of this but this
should be update
so if this is updating then what do we
want to do
so to update what do we want to do in
case of create we directly insert it but
in case of updating we basically want to
get the ID of the Tweet we want to
remove that tweet
and then we want to replace it with the
updated tweet so for that we need the
Tweet ID we need the index of the tweet
in this tweets array and then we want to
update it okay so this should be fairly
straightforward first we want to get ID
of tweet so to get ID of the Tweet we
can just have final tweet let's call
this variable tweet equal to
and we can just have tweet Dot from map
and then we'll pass in data dot payload
and now
tweet ID will be final tweet ID which is
equal to tweet dot ID
this is final because its value is never
going to change after this but this is
variable because later on we're going to
replace this this is the old tweet
correct
this is a new tweet sorry this is a new
tweet so we're going to update it so
anyways now that we have tweet ID with
us what we need to do is find the index
of the tweet in this tweets array so now
what we are going to do is find the
Tweet so we have tweet equal to and
that's why we have put variable we are
going to change this value right now
this is the updated value again we are
going to set it to update value but
right now we are not creating another
variable you can create another variable
to not cause confusion
but here I'm just using this variable so
now Tweed is going to be equal to tweets
dot where
and where do we want to
get like which where do we want to get
which tweet do we want to get so we just
want a tweet where element.id should be
equal to tweet ID
okay so you want to get a tweet in this
tweet list where the element.id we are
looping through it essentially so we
want to get element.id equal to tweet ID
which is this ID
so in the tweets list we'll get
the tweet and then we'll just call First
on it because we know there's only going
to be one tweet with this particular
tweet ID correct now that we've got this
tweet we just want to
remove this tweet but even before
removing we need the Tweet index so that
we can insert our updated tweet into
that tweets position so we have final
tweet index is equal to
tweets dot index off and then we pass in
the tree so this is a tweet
now that we have stored the Tweet index
we have this tweet ID now we can just do
tweet dot remove where
element
dot ID is equal equal to tweet ID so we
have removed the old Tweet now
so let's remove the old Tweet now we
just want to insert the updated Tweet
now to get the updated tweet and insert
it it's going to be very simple for us
we just want to do tweets dot insert
our tweet index and that's why we add
store tweet index earlier because after
we remove the tweet and then find tweet
index like this so if we do this much
right if we do this much we won't
get the Tweet index because we have
already removed it if we have removed a
tweet and then find the index of that
tweet will we get any index no that's
why we want this logic to be above this
and we have got the Tweet ID over here
so that we could get that particular
tweet we are getting the Tweet by ID
essentially over here
and now we are inserting a tweet index
the element which is tweet but this
tweet is the old tweet itself right
so now we want to update the Tweet Again
by doing this tweet is equal to tweet
Dot from map
now I know this is a lot of logic so I
would recommend you to pause it
go through it on your own I'll do
one dry run after this after we get to
know that it's working if it's working
then I'll do a dry run so if you want to
follow along you can follow along but I
would highly recommend you to
use your own logic to understand this
now we'll restart the app and after
restarting it let's try to retweet and I
just realized the error in our
application even if you try to retreat
the retweet count won't upgrade and
that's because the tweet.id that you're
getting here is the updated tweets ID
and the updated tweets ID and the old
tweets ID on the same thing right we had
added that logic on our own and we
forgot about it
so now how do I get the ID of the tweet
so now if you try to print
latest
let's just call it data dot events at
zero so now if you restart your
application click on retweet over here
you'll see over here this is the event
now this is the document ID to get the
document ID what we need to do is get
this thing
so to get this thing we can just find
this full stop at the last so you want
to get index of this full stop
so let's just get it this is not the
Tweet ID we had made a mistake so let's
just get rid of it to remove the error
we can just do final tweet as equal to
this
to get the Tweet ID now we are just
going to have first of all the starting
point or the starting index and this is
going to be latest
data dot events at 0 dot last index off
and we want to get last index of this
documents Dot
so let's have
so we'll get the starting point now to
get the ending point we want to get last
index of dot update right so now we can
just repeat this and have final end
Point equal to
dot update
okay now we want to get the Tweet ID so
we'll have final
tweet ID is equal to latest data dot
events at 0 Dot substring
so we have the starting point we have
the ending point so you want to get a
string from the starting point to the
ending point done but this is not it
because starting point
is last index of
this will also consist documents dot we
don't want it to consist of documents
dot right we want to remove that
so how can we do that well we can just
calculate the number of characters in
documents dot which is 10 and we can add
it over here so starting point doesn't
start from documents dot it will ignore
them it will do starting point plus 10
ignoring documents dot which is 10
characters long
till the end point dot update won't be
used in the
end point this is because it doesn't
contain dot update our index of is still
here only
so now we'll get this ID and now based
on this
everything will get updated and of
course we are getting this error so you
want to convert it to a tweet variable
sorry if we convert it to a variable we
can use it later on to reassign
so now what we have done is get idea of
the original tweet see we got the ID of
the original tweet we are finding that
element
by using element.id is equal to tweet ID
then we are getting the Tweet index
before removing the Tweet then we
finally remove the tweet
get the new data so get the new latest
data and insert it at the particular
tweet index
and at a particular Tweet now we'll
restart the entire thing
I've retweeted many times here just to
test
so just to reduce complexity what I've
done is just deleted all the tweets now
I'm going to come here I'm just going to
type a new tweet new tweet and then
click on Tweet now another problem that
I face right now while retweeting is
that whenever I tweet both the dates are
the same thing we don't want both the
dates to be the same thing whenever we
retweet we want to update the date as
well so here we can also update the date
by just having tweeted at
with the date time as date time dot now
so the tweeted had
is now updated now we can just go and
restart the app now if I try to retweet
it's over here there is an update
if I retweet again it's now 2 and it
shows up right at the top now if I
restart the application this
configuration doesn't change so now
finally our retweet is also working the
earlier logic did not work because of
the
new tweet ID that we were getting we
need to get the ID of original tweet I
hope that is clear if it's not I would
recommend you to go through this
I'll
I've already gone through gone through
the dry run we've got the starting point
we have gone got the ending point by
index of now we are substring them so
that we can get a particular section of
the string
then we are getting the tweet
the original tweet we are getting its
index before removing it and then we
later on remove it
and then we are just having tweet.form
map and inserting it easy so the
retweeting part is also done
and it is working real time
if I also try to like or dislike it also
works
the next feature we want to work on is
whenever I click away I want to go to
the new screen which is the replying
screen or the comment screen whatever
you want to call it and the specialty of
this
replying feature is that whenever we
reply this is going to be there in the
comment section of this tweet but it's
also going to be there on our feed
because we are replying to some person
so it is basically our tweet that is
present in other persons
tweet
so this is a really cool thing to work
on so let's get started so we'll start
off by creating a reply screen so we are
going to go in the Tweet folder in the
views we are going to create uh Twitter
reply screen or review whatever you want
to call it dot dot and here we will go
into import material dot we are going to
create a stateless consumer widget
and we are going to call this not
stateful we are going to get stateless
consumer
and we are going to call this Twitter
reply screen this is nothing else but
just a simple reply screen and now you
might think that yeah if this is a reply
screen this is going to have text
editing controller and I said if you
have text editing controller we need to
use stateful consumer and you're right
but we are not going to have text
editing controller we are simply going
to use the on submitted property in the
text field
anyways here in the app bar we want a
very simple thing to show up which is a
title saying text
that this is a tweet
and this is how the original one looks
as well
now in the body we are going to have a
column widget and in that column we are
going to have children and the children
the first child we want is a tweet card
so for the Tweet we are going to have a
final tweet tweet over here
and then we are going to require this
through the Constructor
so we're going to have required this dot
tweet
so first we want the original tweeted B
displayed and then in the list view we
want a list of reply tweets to show up
okay so now let's see how this is
looking so we are just going to create a
static material route function so let's
go over to the create tweet view grab
the route thing over here and paste it
away up now we need to import not import
we just want Twitter reply screen to
show up over here but this requires a
tweet property so we need to pass in a
tweet property and this tweet property
will get it from here so we have to it
tweet and then we'll pass it over here
sweet now just to see this I'm just
going to go to the create tweet view I'm
going to wrap
not create video sorry we are going to
go to the Tweet card and what I'm going
to do here is just wrap the entire
column widget with a gesture detector
widget so whenever we click over here
we want to
go to the Twitter reply view screen so
we have Navigator dot push and then we
are going to the Twitter reply screen
dot route and then we pass in the
particular tweet and we get this tweet
from here through the Constructor
great now we can restart the entire app
now if I go here click over this tweet
we are in another screen and I can see
the Tweet over here
now the next thing I want is first of
all I want to be able to write a tweet
reply right so now to get a tweet reply
I'm just going to use the bottom
navigation bar property on this scaffold
and then I'm going to use the text Field
property and this text Field property
just needs to add a decoration of
input decoration and there should only
be a hint text which is tweet your reply
that's easy
and here it is it shows up pretty cool
that's the only decoration we need and
now we need the on submitted property so
we get a value this is going to be const
obviously
and whenever it is submitted that means
whenever we type something over here and
click on enter what do we want to do
well we just want to submit this tweet
like a normal tweet right so we can just
use ref dot read tweet controller
provider dot Notifier Dot
and let's see what tweet we use what
function we use to share a tweet and it
was called share tweet so we can just
add that what are the images no images
what are the text well the text is the
value that you are getting from here
from the on sub method
then we pass in the build context and
that's all we are not adding images
property over here so you can add a
bunch of options down below the text
field
but I'm not going to do any of those the
reason for that is
I've already covered this so I don't
want to make this video any longer I've
already covered this in the create tweet
view part so you can just copy the logic
and if you've understood it I would
recommend you to retype it and try it on
your own
and now what do we want to show now I
want to show all the replies but wait is
that all that we need in the share tweet
logic because we are saying that we want
to share a tweet but nowhere are we
specifying that this is in response to
this tweet
so how can we list them over here
correct
it just knows that it is a tweet sent by
the current user that means us with no
images text is there and if case of
error it's going to show us a scaffold
or a snack box
but nowhere does it know that it isn't
reply to this tweet
so what we need to do is in the share
tweet we need to add some logic and we
have to go down into every function the
share tweet all of those function and
here we have to require one field which
is required string replied to so whom
are we replying to we'll copy this and
put this in the share image tweet as
well
so if you are replying to anyone we need
their
tweet ID this is not the user ID this is
a tweet ID because we are replying to
this tweet yes we are replying to this
user but user can have many tweets we
are replying to this tweet ID of the
user so you want to store the reply to
will be the Tweet ID of the
user basically whatever tweet the user
posts that ID
so in the Tweet model we'll have to add
another one which is final string
reply to ID
or applied to now I'll get this through
the Constructor so we have required this
dot replied to and now I can generate
the entire data class I'll remove the
two Json from Json functions
I'll remove dot convert
I'll fix all of these issues like this
tweet type shouldn't be a map it should
be two
tweet type DOT type and this should be
tweet type
removed
we'll treat this as a very simple string
and convert this to
a tweet typing
also here the ID should be slash dollar
ID don't forget that okay
so now we are getting a bunch of Errors
so let's go there in the Tweet
controller we need to add the reply to
property we will add that because we
have just now got it from the parameter
we'll do the same in the share text
tweet we're going to add reply to
replied to and I think we've not added
that over here so let's quickly grab it
and paste it
we also need to mention replied to over
here so we'll pass that in
and also here
also here we have to pass in the reply
to so everywhere we need to pass and
reply to and take it from the parameter
now we're getting this error in Twitter
reply view so we need to go there and we
need to tell it that this share tweet
has a reply to correct we are in the
Twitter reply view so definitely it has
a reply to and what is it reply to well
I said it is going to be the Tweet ID so
we'll just use tweet dot ID don't use
tweet.uid used tweet.id this is a tweets
ID tweet.uid is the person
ID who posted this tweet
in the create wheat view also we have to
go here we have to add reply to property
but this is going to be empty because
you're not replying to anyone this is a
create tweet View and we are going to
reply
to no one
this is our original tweet
just like that
so this looks good now I can just tweet
my reply I'll just say
how are you doing
and I'll click on enter you can see
invalid document structure unknown
attribute ID
there is one problem here in the tweets
we need to add a new attribute called
reply to don't forget that
string
255 required create
and just so that there is no confusion
I'll just delete every document that's
present
now everything is gone I'll just type
hey guys and let me just beautify this
further
and I'll click on tweet here you can see
invalid document structure unknown
attribute ID
so this is a problem with our
tweet model
we have sent to map but we don't want to
map to be there the ID of two map so
remove that that's a mistake I made now
let's restart the application and see so
I'll just say hey guys again and it
should work this time so we'll go on
tweet and here it is now I'll go over
here I want to reply so I can just type
doing
good and then click on enter
now just to verify if this is working
I'll do Ctrl R and we are having doing
good aware but let's see if it replied
to it's working and yep it does work now
let's just compare the IDS of these two
tweets
so this was the ID and let's see the ID
of this one
it's the exact same thing so we have
successfully achieved what we wanted to
achieve
now the next part is displaying all of
those tweets that are in reply to this
particular tweet
so we'll go back to the Tweet API
and here we are going to add a new
future and we are going to call this
future
list of document and since we have used
future you know what's coming future
provider and we want to get replies to a
certain tweet so we'll just have get
replies to tweet
and here we are also going to ask for
the Tweet information because you want
the tweets ID
so what tweets replies do we want to get
that's what we are asking here
we can do that by doing final document
is equal to await so we need this to be
asynchronous
and then underscore DB dot less
documents we have already seen if you
want to get a bunch of documents
we can just list them and then we'll
mention the database ID so we have
upright constants dot database ID app
right constants
dot tweet collection because you want to
go in the Tweet collection now
and now
it will just list all the tweets that
are present in the database correct but
we don't want that we want all the
tweets
which are in reply to this particular
tweet and if you go to some other tweet
we want all the tweets and reply to that
tweet
so if we have to think about it in
programming terms
if this is a tweet we want to get reply
to
tweets which have their reply to
property as this
because earlier if you saw if we go to
the
tweet controller you can see the reply
to property year was the tweets ID so we
want to get all the
tweets which have the ID
the same as the replied to property so
here how can we do that well let's see
if there is anything there's nothing
except queries so your queries is going
to help us
queries will may help us select certain
documents from here here we use queries
because we wanted our data to be
behaving differently we wanted certain
data but we did not have access to them
based on this we had certain
limitations through which we had to do
this or you can think about it like
filters we had certain filters According
to which we wanted to have our data
presented to us
so here we are going to use queries and
here our query is going to be query dot
equal
so we want to get
all the queries or all the documents
where the reply to property is equal to
the Tweet dot ID simple
so here we are just saying list all the
documents where query is equal to the
replied to property and the reply to
property is equal to tweet.id
I hope that's simple enough to digest
I'll repeat it once more we want to list
all the documents in the tweets
collection
where they replied to property is equal
to the tweet.id property
okay now we can just return this
document so we have a return document
dot documents
so this will give us a list of documents
now we can go in the Tweet controller we
can create
a future list of tweet document or
return data type of the function and we
are going to say get replies to tweet
and here we just want to get tweet from
the parameter
and here the job is very simple we just
want to convert let's just put this
function up here
so I'll put it right over here
and now the task is very simple we just
want to
get something so we have final document
is equal to await so this will be
asynchronous
underscore tweet API dot get replies to
tweets okay now we have gotten replies
and the documents
now we just need to convert it in a
format of tweet
and we've covered this logic earlier we
have done this before for
get tweets function
get tweets is basically like get replies
to tweets only difference is that it
gets all the tweets and get replies to
tweet filters something and gets us the
tweets
so we can just put it here I can do
documents.map tweet and convert it to a
list all of this
I hope this logic is clear to you if
it's not let me know in the comment
section I'll make sure to answer you now
I can just go up right at the top and
create another future provider which is
very similar to get weeds provider
so I'll just copy it and we have get
replies
to
tweets provider then we have future
provider dot family we need a tweet so
we have tweet to eat
and whenever we use family we want the
data type to be present here as
immutable so let's go right here this is
immutable ready God
and here we will watch the Tweet
controller provider and we'll get get
replies to tweets and then we'll pass on
this tweet if you remember what family
is we are going to accept this from our
UI file
so we can go to our Twitter reply View
right here and let's just copy all of
the logic that we had in the Tweet list
let's just remove the print calls
let's copy everything that's mentioned
here
it's the exact same thing we are going
to need
let's import the common dot dot file
save it most of our errors are gone
import apparite constants even more
error are gone
now let's make some modifications here
we are doing ref.watch get tweets
provider we don't want all the tweets
over here right we want get replies to
tweets provider and it's giving us an
error because this is a future provider
family whenever it's family we have to
treat this like a function
and then pass in what it's requiring a
tweet so let's pass in the tweet and the
Tweet is exactly this thing
okay
now we have got replied to tweet dot
when data and whenever we get the tweets
we have to show this in a format of
tweet card in a list view Builder
perfect exactly what we want and all of
this is real time all of the logic to
make it real time if you remove this it
will still work but it will not be real
time we want everything to be real time
so all of this is now done let's restart
the application
I'll go over here
not aware over here and it's giving us
the exception index not formed whenever
there's no index no found exception you
have to go to the indexes you have to
create a new index and what is this for
well this is for getting replies so I
can just type replies then I'll have key
the attribute here is
replied to let's just say ascending or
descending order whatever you want
I'll just type descending and click on
create
now I can restart the application go to
hey guys and nothing shows up
but our error now goes away
and now if you open the terminal you see
this is the error this is UI related
error basically we have a list view
Builder over here and we are also having
a tweet card in a column list view
Builder has a tendency of taking the
entire screen it's not getting the
entire screen so together the entire
screen we have to wrap it with the
expanded widget it doesn't give you the
exactly you know the entire screen but
it gives you all the available space
and this should work so let's restart
our application
go to hey guys
and if you open the terminal it's still
giving us an error because we are at the
loading part if we are at the loading
part you have to wrap here also with
expanded widget because basically this
widget is now returning list view
Builder
from here it's not expanded so our UI
doesn't know
anyways let's restart the application go
to hey guys and we are having doing good
over here just to test the logic if it's
correct or wrong let's tweet another
thing publicly so we have high I'll just
do this much click on tweet and we are
having the surveyor but if I go to hey
guys hi shows up here as well why is
that so
so if I refresh the upright console and
go to documents you'll see hi is there
replied to is still empty but even then
it's showing up over here that's a weird
Behavior right now if I go back go to
doing good I have high showing up here
as well and if I go to over here it's
showing up here as well
that's the thing this is how apprite
works
this data now has some value in it
so if you try to print data it will
print you the data every time you go to
a new screen you can see right now it
has two highs now if I refresh this it
has three highs so it's continuously
rebuilding and giving you new Highs but
if you restart your entire app and then
go to hey guys hi doesn't show up
so we need to do something that we check
that if the Tweet here is already
mentioned in this part we don't have to
add it and we also have to check if this
replied to of this is equal to the ID of
this tweet
then we should only put it why am I
saying these two conditions
this is because every time we create a
widget new tweet appears whenever we
click over here the Tweet keeps on
appearing here
even though it's not replied a part of
the reply to
right
so you want to check
if the replied to of this tweet
is equal to the ID of this tweet so if
replied two of this tweet is equal to
the ID of this tweet that means
it belongs here
and if it doesn't then it doesn't belong
here
right
so let's add that logic your
before the if condition over here we are
just going to check okay first we need
to convert it to a tweet model so we'll
have latest tweet final latest tweet
don't name a tweet otherwise you'll get
confused with what's mentioned in the
Constructor final latest tweet is equal
to tweet
Dot from map and we have to pass in
data.payload if we do this we get the
latest tweet in a tweet model format
then I check if latest tweet dot reply
to is equally equal to tweet
dot ID that means the reply two of the
latest tweet that means this ID
this replied to of this tweet is equal
to the ID of this main tweet
only then do we have to run all of this
logic so you can just put all of this
logic inside this
and if it doesn't equal then don't
execute any of this logic don't have to
insert anything don't have to do
anything
okay now if I restart my application and
try to see if it's working I'll go to
the hey guys I'll type this
hello and click on done I'm getting
that's good
I'm getting hello over here as well now
if I still try to do
um and then click on tweet I'm getting
hum um and if I go to Hello it doesn't
show up
Let's test it one more time if I do nice
over here
I get nice I'll go back come back over
here I get nice two times if I go back
come back
I get nice one more time
so basically this logic is working the
reply to is equal to tweet ID so right
now my data consists of
nice and
if it consists of nice tweet
latest tweet dot reply to is equal to
tweet.id so it's equal right so it's
again re-running this entire thing so
it's seeing that yeah if all of this is
done then I can just you know have my
nice tweet again here now to avoid this
many nice coming over here what I can do
is add one more condition I want to
check if the nice tweet already exists
over here or not if it already exists
over here
then I don't want to add it again but if
it does not exist then I want to add it
so here we are going to be running a
very simple for Loop so we are going to
have Boolean is tweet already present
so if the Tweet is already present then
we don't have to execute all of this
initially it will be false and then we
are going to run a for each Loop or a
foreign Loop
we are going to have four final tweet
model in tweet
tweets not tweet tweet model I've named
it because tweet is already there latest
tweet is over here so this is tweet
model
then I want to check if tweet model
dot ID is equal to latest tweet model
dot ID so I'm comparing both of their
IDs I'm just seeing if the latest tweet
has the
Loops tweet model already present so if
their ID is match that means it is
already present so is tweet already
present is equal to true and then I want
to break it so that it doesn't Loop
through more and more elements we've
already found our answer
okay so we are just checking
through every tweet and tweets
so it we are checking through every
reply if the Tweet is already present
and if the Tweet is present we are
checking that by that ID
we are just doing if tweet already
present is equal to true and then break
off
because we have already found our answer
that yeah it is present
so why should we run more for Loops or
more iterations
and here we are checking
if if tweet is already present
and and latest V Dot reply to is equal
to tweet ID right no
if tweet is not already present
then we want to execute all of this if
tweet is already present why would we
execute it
it's the same thing as what we are
seeing over here we don't want this so
if tweet is not present and latest
tweet.replied to is equal to tweet ID
then we want to execute all of this now
it should get rid of all of the errors
so if I now type your nice
go back
and you know come back
knife is there
only one time
this is good now if I come over here
this has no comments this has no
comments even this has no comments that
means the applied to feature is also
over
but yeah there is one thing left
whenever we are applying to someone we
wanted to show in the Tweet so we can go
to our tweet card
and we'll scroll down
right below the text result the replied
to we have added a comment and here we
are going to check if tweet.reply to dot
is not empty so if it is not empty then
we want to display
that we are applying to this particular
user
so we are going to return a rich text
and the text is going to contain a text
pan because we want to show a white or a
gray
along with a blue one
right the username of the user should be
colored in blue now in the text pan we
are going to have
text which is going to say replying to
then a style of constant textile you can
select white or gray I think gray would
be better because we don't want to focus
on
this text as much as the main text
then the font size should be 16. then in
the children we need another tech span
so we have text pan
and here we are going to add
the rate
and the name of the user now how do we
get the name of the user we don't have
access to it if you try to do it let's
see if you get it you know tweet dot
reply to this is the Tweet ID that we
are applying to it this is not the name
of the user so how do we get the name of
the user for that we need the uid of the
user that is also not mentioned where
the reply to user ID is not there
so what else can we do well we have to
create a new provider which is basically
getting tweet by ID so we get that
particular tweet
then we take its uid and then use the
user details provider and then we can
get the name of the user so let's do
that we are going to go to the Tweet API
now
right at the top we are going to Define
future
document get tweet
by ID and obviously since you are
getting by ID we need a string ID
now we can create one missing override
we can have async over here
and we want to return underscore DB dot
get document we want a single document
because getting a tweet by ID a tweet is
only going to have one document or one
ID so we will get one particular ID and
we are going to use apprite constants
dot database ID app right constants Dot
ID
or tweets collection
and the document ID document ID is the
ID that we are getting from the
parameter
okay now we can go to the Tweet
controller
here we are going to Define our get
tweet by ID function
so
let's do that over here we're going to
have future tweet
get tweet by ID
then we are going to get if sync over
here then we are going to get ID from
the UI file itself so we are going to
have this then we are going to have
final to eat is equal to
underscore tweet API Dot
get tweet by ID then pass in the ID then
we are going to have return
tweet Dot from map and this is going to
be tweet Dot
and there's nothing like it so you want
to do await
now we have document earlier it was
future document
and now we want to get tweet.data
so we have converted it into a model and
returned it and now finally we just need
a simple future provider so we can just
have future provider
and we'll name this get
tweet by ID provider we're not going to
have anything else other than family
because we want a string ID
we also need the Tweet controller so
we're just copy pasting stuff now we've
covered a lot so just get a hang of this
we are getting 3D controller we are
converting it to a models we are sending
data to app right we are getting data
from upright all of the same stuff
and now we want to get Tweed by ID and
we'll pass in the particular ID
now we can go to the Tweet card and here
we are going to wrap everything by ref
so we are going to have ref.watch
get Tweed by ID provider we'll pass in
the ID the ID is tweet dot reply to
so we want to get the tweet ID or the
Tweet by ID of tweet.reply to which is
the ID of the tweet that we are replying
to
dot when and whenever we get the data we
have to do something so when there's
data you have to do something when you
have to do error or St we have to do
something and if you have loading we
have to do something
so in case of the loading we just want
to show a size box
so we can a sized box
in case of error we want to show the
error text so
let's have error text and we'll have
error.2 string
now I'll take the rich text
and here we are going to return that
rich text
and here we are getting this error we
just need to add a parenthesis here
before the
bracket
so yes now we have the data but what is
this data this is the
replied
to data
or applied to tweet this is not our
original tweet this is a reply to Tweet
now based on this we want to get the
name of the user right now we get the
uid of the user to whom we are replying
by this so how do we get the name of the
user
so to get that what we are going to do
is final replying
to user which is equal to ref dot watch
replied to tweet.uid
or not this sorry
what is the provider that we want to
have we are going to have user details
provider then we are going to have
replied to tweet.uid
so basically we have rev dot watch we
pass in the user details provided the
reusable provider we created remember
right here
you have used that in the current user
account provider as well
not aware sorry we have used it in
current user details provider
now that we have replying to user with
us now we can get their name but before
that we need to have value because right
here this thing
is a user model now earlier if we didn't
use value it would be a future provider
thing an async value
okay so let's get replying to user put
it right here replying to user dot name
make sure to use question mark over here
instead of exclamation mark because when
you use exclamation mark you're saying
that this value cannot be null but for
some time for even a second this value
can be null when it's trying to get the
user details okay
so save this restart your app come over
here and you see replying to at the rate
test this is good
now here I want to change the color to
blue color
and I want to leave some space so that
this sticking doesn't happen I'll save
it and yeah we get it replying to at the
rate test
so you can see everything is replying to
test over here
this looks good
now let's just try to retweet replying
to and we get all of the features in one
single tweet retweet replying to like
and if we try to comment on this we can
also comment okay
great now I think all the features
related to tweet are now completed now
the next step is to go away or Implement
a search screen basically we want a text
field over here and whenever we search
over here we want to get a list of user
profiles so let's get started with it
right now so what I'm going to do here
is just close all the save files close
the Tweet folder and create a new folder
called explore
and here I'm going to create a new view
called exploreview.dot
and after I've created it I'm just going
to import material dot create a
stateful consumer widget I've created
State full consumer because my app bar
is going to have a search field and
we'll be requiring text field controller
for it
so let's have explore view right here
import flutter riverpod
we are going to return a scaffold and
here I'm just going to exp take explore
view go to UI constants pass it right
here
and I think this should show up yep it
does now what I want to do is add an app
bar over here but if I add an app bar it
will be right below this so I want to
eliminate this app bar which is present
in the home screen so in the home view
if you see
we are adding an app bar over here what
I want to do is if underscore page is
equal equal to 0 then I want it to be
app bar otherwise null so only for the
page 0 will this app bar show up
otherwise it will not be there so if you
go there there's Abba but if you go over
here there's no app bar easy
now we can go to the explore page have
app bar pass in the app bar
which will have a title and the title is
going to be sized box of height 50.
then we need a child
for text feed we have passed the size
box of height 50 because text field
might exceed this length
so we are restraining or constraining it
to just a particular height of 50.
now in the text field I'm going to pass
in my controller so I have to create my
controller
I'll create it right here final search
controller is equal to
text editing controller let's have text
editing controller now I want to dispose
the source so I'll have search
controller dot dispose
and I'll take the search controller and
put it right here
now if I see your way up here is my
search field but I want to style this
even more so I'm just going to pass in a
decoration of input decoration
and here I'm just going to have first of
all a fill color and my fill color is
going to be palette dot search bar color
with field set to true so I'll just have
filled true
after I have this underneath I go here
this is colored which is pretty good now
I want to enable borders so that I can
move this border and add my own border
so here I'm going to have enabled border
so in the enabled border I want outline
input border
with border radius and Border radius is
going to be border radius dot circular
50.
after that we need a Border Side
and Border Side will be constant Border
Side basically
we want
the normal text field to be a bit
rounded should have no outline underline
border
so I'll just pass this as color palette
dot search bar color and of course for
the Border radius we have this now we
won't be able to see over here because
this is focused so I'll do the same for
focused border
and now it's going to be the exact same
thing so I can just extract this out put
it here and call this app bar text field
border which is equal to this thing now
I can copy it
paste it right over here paste it for
the focus border as well save it and
here you can see this is curved exactly
like the Twitter thing now I want hint
text to show up so in the hand text wire
I'm going to pass in search Twitter
save it again here it is now I want
content padding to be there because I
want to shift my text from here to
somewhere a little bit down
and to a little bit more right
so in the decoration I'm going to have
content padding constant Edge in such
dot all 10 dot copy web
left 20. basically from the top I want
10 padding and from the left hand side I
want 20 so that I can go to the right
hand side and here it is looks great
so this was about designing the search
field now we want to be able to search
for users
so for that we are going to go to the
explore explore folder create a
controller
and call this explore controller dot dot
then I'll have a state Notifier and a
state Notifier provider
so the state Notifier is going to be
explore controller let's remove Notifier
from here then we will need a straight
Notifier a Boolean value and false
because this shows it's loading so it's
loading as initially it falls and here
we are just going to have a future list
of user model to show up
for search user of course we are going
to create their API but right now I'm
just giving you a clue of what's going
to happen we're going to get the name of
the user
whatever the user types in here we get
the name and based on that we search in
app right and the list we get we have to
display it in a future provider
okay so now let's go ahead in the user
API
because this is related to user user
searching so we're going to go to the
user API and add our
new function which is
going to return a list of documents
and we're going to call this
search user
by name
and here we'll get access to the name of
the user now I'll create one missing
override
I'm going to have async over here
then I'm going to copy all of this
paste it down and go into say list
document
actually I'm not going to return this
I'm just going to save it in documents
just like we have done before for other
things so we are going to list the
documents we are going to go to the user
collection and here we are going to add
our queries you remember the queries and
here we are basically going to search
and there is an inbuilt query search
provided to us which is query dot search
so if we use this we should be able to
search for a specific value
and was it what is it that we are trying
to search which is name and we'll pass
in the name through the parameter
now we just need to be able to return it
so we'll have return documents dot
documents
we don't have that option we are getting
this because you're not awaited this so
let's await it
take these documents and return it
documents dot documents
now we can go to the explore controller
again
and here we have to import the user API
so we have final user API underscore
user API
let's require this so we have required
user API user API
and then we have underscore user API is
equal to user API
now we can take this and have user API
dot search user by name we'll pass in
the name
and this should be equal to final users
is equal to await this
so now that we have list of document
with us we need to map through it and
convert it into a user model so that we
can return a list of user models so we
have returned users dot map now we have
e the
help of this we are going to return user
model
Dot from map
e.data dot to list
we have already looked at this logic
before in the Tweet controller we have
done this for get tweets and get replies
to tweets functions mapping through all
the users returning one particular user
model and converting it to a list and
this happens for literally all the users
that we find
now we need to create
two things a state notify a provider for
our explore controller so we have
explore controller provider
and now we want to return explore
controller and here we need to pass in
the user API which is ref.watch user API
provider
and the next thing we want to create is
future provider and the future provider
is going to be called
search user provider because you want to
search the user
dot family and here we are going to get
the query from the UI file so basically
whatever you don't find a way or you can
just take it from family but in the
family you can just import one thing you
cannot have two or three things okay
now we can return this but before that
we need explore controller so we have
explore controller final Explorer
controller equal to
ref.watch explore controller provider
dot Notifier
now we can use this explore controller
and return it so we have returned
explore controller Dot search user pass
in the name from the parameter here
and return it now to display the correct
thing we can
go in the scaffold in the outside the
app bar in the body
outside that but I said so body
and here we are going to use the future
provider now we know the syntax search
user provider then we'll pass in since
it's a family future provider we have to
use this as a function and then we can
do search controller dot text this is
the search controller that we have as a
text editing controller and is bound to
the text field so we are getting text
from it dot when and whenever we get the
data we get users in case of error we
know already what to do
error St will return something in case
of loading you have to load a loader so
we have constant loaders showing up here
next thing is error St
so here I want to return an error text
and then I'll have error.2 string
so here I have users list of user model
and then I want to return a list view
Builder okay so I can just return list
view Builder because this is a list I
want to return it and then I can have
users.link
now finally I want final user equal to
users at a particular index
I can take this user return it in a
search Style
which I'll have to create basically this
search style is going to consist of
everything about the user like their
Avatar their number of followers
following all of that but we only want
to return an avatar the username their
bio their
at the rate username okay so we can go
here in the explore create a new folder
for it called widgets and here we are
going to have search
I'll import material dot I'll create a
stateless widget and call this search
tile
will be requiring the user model so we
have final user model user model and
then we're going to require this through
the user model Constructor now we have
to return a list tile
so we can have return list file
then we are going to have leading which
is circle Avatar
and then we need a background image
which will be Network image
and we'll pass in the user model dot
profile picture okay
then we need a radius of 30 so that it
looks big now just to see how it's
looking we can return it over here so we
have searched tile we'll pass in the
user model which is the user we have
extracted all of this pretty similar to
what we have done earlier
now we can restart our entire
application
now we can restart the entire
application go to the search bar here
you can see we are getting error because
we are not finding uh
an index so let's create an index here
in the tweets not in the tweets actually
we have to go to the users collection
because we are having a query on users
collection not the tweets collection
so we'll create index let's call this
search user name
then this is going to be of the type
full text since we are searching the
user it's going to be of the type full
text
even if you mess things up it will give
you an upright exception over here
that this cannot be of the type this you
have to use full text or whatever and
then you can change it accordingly or
you can just read the docs to get a
clearer idea
so I'll pass a name I'll pass in
descending I'll click on create
so I've passed in an invalid key I want
to pass in searching that's it nothing
else
and then I'll have full text I'll pass
in
name ascending or descending whatever
then click on create index has been
created restart the application
go to the search no error
now I'll just have hi click on enter
nothing shows up if I do test click on
enter nothing shows up that's weird
because my email Steps either at
gmail.com
so now
to make this work we need one last thing
over here
in the explore screen there is a
possibility of many API calls going over
here in the body so what I want to do is
is show users should be false so as long
as it is false we should not be able to
show the users list only when
it show users is true we should show
this otherwise we should only show a
constant size box okay
and this issue size box will be true
whenever on submitted is set to true so
whenever on submitted is clicked on we
can do such state
is show users is equal to true
great now we can restart the app
we can search for a user with test click
on done and here it is here shows up the
user with their profile picture now
let's add more things to this
so we can go to the search tile and here
after the leading we need a title where
we want to show the user's name so we
have user
model dot name
then we need a style so that you know
this looks bigger and we have textile
where the font size should be bigger
than original font weight should be
a bit Bolder not exactly bold so we love
font weight dot w
we'll save it and here it shows up
in the subtitle we have a column and in
the column we have children
in the children we have a text so the
text is going to be this we'll paste it
right here
it will be usermodel.name we'll put add
the read before it
and we have to interpolate this so
basically adding add the rate
dollar so that this is a variable name
with other rate before it
then the font size can be 16
and we can remove the Bolding part
and since it's a subtitle it's going to
be of the gray color
now we need another text just like this
one
so we'll paste it in and we'll have
usermodel dot bio
and here the color should be palette dot
white color the bio should show up in
the white column
because the subtitle color is usually
gray and here you can see we are getting
at the rate test right here we don't
want it here we want it to be here so in
the column we can have cross access
alignment as cross access alignment dot
start
and here it is now if there is any bio
of the user it will show up here and if
there is no bio it will not show up
or like it is there but you cannot see
it obviously because it's empty
now
the searching feature is also complete
now the next feature here is going to be
whenever we click on this
user tile we should be able to go to the
user's profile
and there we get the option to see the
user's Banner image their profile
picture their followers following their
recent tweets all of that cool stuff
so let's close all of the save files
close all of the features
and gets
and let's get ready for another feature
which is the user underscore profile now
we'll start off this user profile
by
creating a view of it like how it should
look there are a lot of levels to use
because
in Twitter if you see there it is not
just you know simple scrolling it has a
weird scrolling effect so you want to
give that effect
so we are going to do exactly that so
here we are going to create a views
folder
create user profile view
import material Dot and now create a
widget for it and now we are going to
create a stateless widget for it and we
are going to call this user profile view
actually we need a consumer widget for
it not stateless widgets so let's read
rename it and here we are going to need
a widget ref
and we also need to return a scaffold
and in the scaffold let me retype it we
are going to have a body no app bar
directly a body and in this body we are
going to get
the user data so directly we are going
to return a user profile how are we
going to return that because we are
going to ask for that user model right
over here so we're going to get the user
model from here
and display it accordingly so I can just
have user model user model
Now to create a route for this I'm just
going to go to some view file let's say
home view I'll copy this route I'll go
to the user profile view and just post
it over here and then I'm going to
return a user profile view but it's not
going to be constant we have to return a
user model so pass in the user model
user model and we're going to take this
from the parameter
simple
now based on this we are going to return
the body as User it's not going to be
user profile view sorry it's going to be
a new widget that we are going to create
in this folder itself which is user
profile just user profile it contains
the main code for our user profile
design so we are going to have import
material Dot
then we are going to have a stateless
consumer widget called user profile
then we are going to import consumer
widget
and then we are going to return a nested
scroll View
now we need a header sliver Builder we
need a header
body sorry not a header body just a
header sliver bar Builder and a body
so here we're going to get two things
context and is in a box scrolled so
after we get both of them
we have to return something
and in the case of body we also need to
return something again
so in case of heady header board self
sliver Builder
that you um you had you you would you
could you do you would you want you you
you could do so you you do you could you
you want you want thank you if I've
heard of liver Builder we are going to
have sliver well we have to return first
and this requires a list of widgets to
be returned so you're going to have a
list of your return and then we're going
to have sliver app bar and here I want
to have an expanded height of let's say
floating should be true this means that
the app bar is floating
or the app bar should become visible as
soon as the user Scrolls towards the app
bar
snap should be true this means that
the floating app bar will snap into view
and both of them should be true together
or false together
and then we need flexible Space by a
flexible space because now this app bar
is going to be used to show the banner
picture of the user so we need a
flexible spacebar
and now we are going to have stack
because
I want the user's profile picture to
also be shown right above right on the
top of this banner picture so first of
all let's have banner picture and we are
going to have positioned
dot fill that means it takes the entire
space and then in the child we are going
to check if user Dot not user
so we want to get the user picture here
as well so you want to get final user
model user model
require it through the Constructor
here when we return user
profile will pass in the user which is
the user model
so here we have child as the user dot
banner picture and we want to check if
user.banner picture is empty so if it is
empty then I want a container of blue
color to shop that's what Twitter does
if the user hasn't selected any banner
picture it will just give a color of
blue so we have palette dot blue color
but if the container is not empty then
what do I want to do well in that case I
want to use image
dot Network and here I'm going to return
the banner picture so it's going to be
user dot banner picture
okay now we are getting this error
because we have not specified children
in the stack
so let's pass that in take position dot
fill and paste it over here
and for the time being the Border body
is going to be a simple container now we
want to see this in action so what can
we do
we can go back to our search tile
in the on top of this search tile we can
just say navigator
dot push context and user profile view
dot route and then we'll pass in the
user model
okay so we're getting this user model
based on the search screen whatever the
user searches if you're getting that you
user model we are passing it through the
list Style on the on tap now we are here
from here we pass it to the user profile
over here
okay so now if I just click over here
you can see this shows up very nice now
what I want here is at the top over here
I want the user Avatar to show up and
here the profile picture not profile
picture sorry
your is the profile picture going to be
here is a follow button this is going to
have the name of the user at the rate
name of the user followers following all
of that stuff the bio of the user and
then all the latest tweets done by the
user
so to do that well first of all I'll
need your in the
stack a circle Avatar I'll have a
background image and the background
image is going to be Network image
and then I'll pass in user.profile
picture
I'll save it now I also need a radius
and the radius is going to be let's say
I'll save it and here it is looks very
weird I know
now I can wrap this circle Avatar with a
position widget so that it goes right
below so we have bottom
and here it is
so it has gone to the bottom of this
flexible space right here that's exactly
where we want it to be
now next thing we need is a follow
button which should show up right here
so to do that we are going to have
an outlined button because well we need
an outline button
and the child is going to be text which
says follow now this text is going to
depend if it's the user himself then
it's going to be added profile but if
it's other user is going to be follow
and if it's not the same person
and if we are following the user then
it's going to be the unfollow button but
one thing is going to remain constant
the textile which is going to have a
color and the color is going to be
palette dot white color
and now when I put this button you can
see again we get the similar design now
to avoid this what we can do is wrap the
outline button with a widget called
container
and here we are going to specify the
alignment so the alignment is going to
be alignment dot bottom right so if we
do bottom
right it will shift right to the bottom
and I also need some padding basically
margin so we can imagine or padding both
will work in this case and then we are
going to have agencies.all 20. now if we
do this you can see it went
away from the edges of the mobile so
it's not going to be constant now you
need to check if we want to show edit uh
you know if the user is
themselves so edit profile or someone
else so we are going to get current user
which is equal to ref.watch
current user details provider
dot value
now if current user is null so return
current user is equal equal to null then
we want a constant loader otherwise a
nested scroll View
and now we are going to take this
current user put it over here and check
if current user dot uid is equal to the
user.uid current user is our user
user.uid is what we have taken from the
Constructor
if both of them are equal then we want
edit profile to be there otherwise the
follow button
okay so we get the edit profile because
it's our own User it's us now to add a
different border to this to our outline
button we can have Style
elevated button dot style from
and the shape will be
shape
rounded rectangle border
where the Border radius is going to be
border radius dot circular 20 and the
padding is going to be constant Edge in
such dot symmetric
let's say in the horizontal Direction 25
basically
we are going to add a little bit of
padding from the sides and have a
circular border radius and to change its
color we can just do
side Border Side
color palette dot white color
now if I go over here
I have this button showing up which is
pretty cool
and it is rounded as well
now to increase the width we can just go
ahead and type with let's say 1.5
10 but I don't want any wet so I'll
remove it
so here is our edit profile button now
we need to get out of this this is all
that we needed in this app bar
on the banner pick I needed to show this
profile picture and the edit profile
button now below this we need to show
the username of the user and all of that
stuff so I'll just go to the sliver
padding
in the custom scroll view so after the
sliver app bar gets over I'm going to
come here and have sliver padding
basically I want to add a padding from
all sides of eight
and now the sliver is going to be sliver
list
and this list is going to have a
delegate and the delegate is sliver
child list delegate
and what is it that we need over here
the positional argument the children so
the children is going to be a list
and the first thing we need is a row
so you're in the sliver childless
delegate I want a simple text to show up
which is user.mame
and then I need a style of constant
textile
where the font size should be 25 a
little bit bigger than usual and font
weight should be font weight dot bold
so here it shows up my name now after
this is done the next thing that I need
is down below the same thing but with
other eight so I'm going to have text
like this with
dollar and other it so at the rate
user.name the font size should be
smaller 17 and it shouldn't be bold but
the color should be palette dot gray
color okay
here it is
now the next thing I need is the user's
bio
so we have text user dot bio I'll just
remove all the string
and here the gray color should be
removed the font size should match this
at the rate sign
and here it is this looks good but bio
is not showing up of course when we work
on the edit profile feature you'll get
to see it
now later on we need a constant size box
of height 10.
because now I want to show in a row
format the number of followers the user
has the number of following the user has
so to do that what am I going to do
I'm going to create a separate widget
here which is going to be follow
underscore count dot dot
I'm going to import material dot I'm
going to create a stateless widget and
call it follow count
and here we are going to return a row
because you want to show the number of
followers the user has and with the tag
that this is followers and this is
following okay
so now we'll have final string count so
like the counter
and final string text
then I'll require this through the
Constructor
in the children now I'll have a text
that basically says the count so we have
zero followers or five followers like
that
and we are having dollar count because
this will be in an end format not a
string format sorry
okay now in the style we are going to
have not stretch style style and we'll
have constant textile because we want to
have a color and the color should be
palette dot white color
the font size should be 18
and font weight should be font weight
dot bull because I want to bold it right
I mean this
count should be bolded because there is
more emphasis on this yeah this guy has
17 followers so like there should be an
emphasis on this
and we are going to copy this text paste
it again with some width here so let's
say a width of
three you can also add you know a
padding from the right side or from the
left side depending on where you add the
padding but I'm adding a size box
and this will show the text so what is
like it followers following what
and this will have a gray color
font size should be 18 the same size as
this okay so you can create a separate
variable for it here called and font
size which is equal to 18 because both
of them should maintain the same font
size every single time
so let's remove the constant
and obviously this is a double so we can
make this double font size okay
now I can take this follow count and put
it here but I want it again in a row
over here we had a row because I wanted
to show the counter alongside
the tag that this is following
but over here we want the followers
entire row
showing beside the following entire row
so for that I'm going to create another
row I have children and the first child
is going to be follow count
and here the count is going to be user
dot followers dot link don't use current
user here this is user.followers.link
and this will be follow us
now we are going to have something
similar
but above it which should be following
and this should be users dot following
dot link okay
now let's see what we are getting we're
getting one following one followers
that shouldn't be the case
but that's how apprite is functioning
right now because we are directly
getting the user's follower dot link so
if you want to change this you can just
have minus one because this happens for
literally every user so you can just
have minus one
and there is 0 follow 0 following also
to leave some gap between them we can
have constant size works of width 15.
let's have constant
and yep
this looks much better
now I'll exit out of this row leave some
space so I have height of let's say 2
and then I want to have a divider
after I have the divider
which doesn't show up so I'll just have
a color color with palette dot white
color
come over here we have the divider
showing up
now below all of this divider I want
a list of the tweets made by the user
himself so if you are on this user we
want to see all the tweets the user has
made
so I can come to the body and here we
need to do that but even before doing
that we have another step
because we have to go to the user API
and create an API or a function so that
we can use it but we are not going to do
that in user API we'll go to the Tweet
API because at the end of the day this
is tweet related we want to get the
tweets made by the user so you can have
future list of document
get user tweets and then we are going to
supply to it the user's ID
we'll add the missing override
implementation for it
let's create async over
and now this is very similar
to the get tweets functionality so we
are just going to have that let's go up
copy this
paste it away up we want to list the
documents in this database ID this
tweets collection but the query is going
to be different because here we want to
check if the query is equal we want to
get all the user streets correct so you
want to check if the uid
is equal to the uid simple the Tweet
collection has a uid property there we
are checking if it is equal to the uid
supplied by the parameter
and then we are returning this now we
can go to the user profile view
your create
a controller and this will be user
profile controller
dot dot and I don't want to write all
the boilerplate code again and again so
what I'm going to do is copy this
controller from here paste it here and
I'm going to make changes over here only
so I'm going to remove the search user
provider
here I'm going to press option and
select everything that has explore in it
except this one
so lab explore
remove all of this
then I'm going to have user profile
controller
also over here we are going to have
small user profile controller
and we don't need user API we need tweet
API underscore
tweet API
then underscore tweet API should be
equal to
8 API so let's have tweet API
okay
and this function is going to be get
user tweets we are going to supply it
the uid of the user
well
this uid is not to be confused with the
uid of the current user if we do the
current user's uid we'll get the tweets
of the current user we don't want
current user we want the tweets of the
user on Whose profile we are
and here we'll just do underscore tweet
API this will be tweets
Dot
get
user tweets we'll pass in the correct
uid then we'll map through the tweets
we'll do we'll return tweet
Dot from map and also the return data
type over your should be tweet so we
have fixed everything of course we need
to pass and tweet API provider over here
and
I think we are almost done over here
let's remove the unused Imports now we
just need to create a future provider
and then only displaying part is left
so we have
get user tweets provider
dot family and we want to get the uid of
the user which is string uid
then we want to have final
user profile controller which is equal
to ref dot watch
user profilecontroller provider.modifier
and then finally we are going to return
user profilecontroller dot get user
tweets and then we are going to return
with the uid of the user that we are
going to get from the UI
so we can go to the UI
here we are going to have ref.watch get
user tweets provider
then we need the uid of the user which
is user dot uid not the current user uid
Make sure
and then we need when now in case of
data we have to do something error will
give us s error and ST which we will
return as error text
where we have to convert it to a string
and return and then a loading where I
just have to show a normal loader and
here we are getting tweets so I have
tweets and what I want to do is return a
list view Builder so that I can show
that yeah this is all the you know
things that I have
and actually instead of writing all of
this code why can I not just go to the
Tweet list
just copy everything from here
not everything just this part and paste
it over here of course if you want your
user profile to be you know
real time working for example if someone
likes a tweet or something you want them
to
see that in real time of course you
should
copy all of this but first what I want
to do is just display the tweets as it
is and we're getting this error of
course because of the index so we'll go
to the tweets
indexes and what is this index well this
is the uid equal part so I'll just do
uid equal and we have said that these
should be equal so this should be a key
uid
defending create
I'll restart the app
go to the user so we have test
go where and all the tweets from test
show up over here and you can see we
have a little bit of weird scrolling
effect as well so if you just go over
here and come back you can see there is
not the normal scrolling you can see it
in this part
sorry this part
okay
so if you want to see it again you can
see it if we come back yep here it is
now whenever we click over here it's not
going to be real time of course there's
no real time logic in r
user profile can
use a profile over here
so even if we try to retweet it happens
it retweets but
it's not real time it doesn't show the
one upgraded counter so for that you can
of course add all of this logic
by adding all of this so I'll just copy
all of this
and paste it to the user profile but I'm
not going to do that you can do it on
your own and if you face the same bug
that we had faced earlier you should
copy everything from the
reply view screen so this part you can
copy everything from here
or let me just do it so I'll just copy
this
entire thing
I'll come over here to the user profile
where is it yeah
and I'm going to return this thing
now I'm going to import the Tweet model
I'm going to have upright constants
we are going to have get latest tweet
provider
and we don't need to add this logic over
here
so we only add this logic okay
so now if we try to do retweet it shows
up real time
but just to make this look very simple
what I'm doing here is just returning
listview Builder so if you want to check
out my GitHub repository this will not
be mentioned I've just showed it to you
I can type a comment that make it real
time
or can make it real time
byte
copying code from
Twitter reply view okay so you can do
that if you want but I'm not going to do
that
so now tweets are showing up over here
now what will be the next step so the
next step is obviously to edit the
previews or profile so if the user
clicks on edit profile we go to the edit
profile screen and there we get the
option to
select a profile picture select a banner
picture
select uh you know the name changing bio
changing all of that so let's get into
that so for the edit profile screen we
are just going to go in the view and add
edit profile view over here and after
adding that we are going to import
material dot we are going to create a
state full widget
and this will be stateful consumer and
we are just going to have edit profiles
View
now I'm just going to import flutter
overpod Library I'm going to return a
scaffold and here let's decide what we
want well first of all in the body
I want a column and in that column I
want children and the first child that's
going to be there is going to be exactly
what we are put in the user profile so
we are just going to go up and copy this
thing the stack portion and I'm just
going to copy it till here
paste it in then close the stack and now
we need the current user so
we can get the current user which is
final
user is equal to ref dot watch
current user details provider dot value
and while we are getting that if it is
null then we just want to show loader
otherwise we'll get null check operator
used on a null value and after getting
this obviously let's just import theming
and this looks good
now let's see how this is coming about
so when we click on the edit profile we
should see the screen
so here let's just put in the route so
to get the route we can just go to one
view file let's say home view copy it
paste it here and then we have edit
profile view router
okay so now the next thing that's needed
is
whenever the edit profile button is
clicked we want to go there so
we'll go to the user profile and on this
outlined
button we'll check if
current user dot uid is equal to
user.uid so if both of them are equal
we want to edit the profile so we are
just going to use Navigator dot push
and we're going to go to the edit
profile view dot route
save it now whenever I click over here I
go to the edit profile view but I don't
see anything
and I'm getting this error over here so
let's try to resolve this error first of
all we want to give our stack a specific
height
so that it doesn't exceed the given
portion so here the stack can hide have
a height of size box height let's say
200 it should not exceed that
and here we have it our
stack looks good over here
next thing I want to do over here is not
use position dot fill instead just wrap
it with a container and in the container
add width as double dot Infinity so the
maximum amount of space height will be
150 so we'll save it
the height is bit reduced so
the profile picture shows up here
but since the stacks height is this much
you know 200
the profile picture seems to be on top
of two screens like this
then we need a decoration and the
decoration will be box decoration we'll
pass in Border radius such as border
radius dot circular and we'll pass in 10
as a border radius cool
so this is a bit rounded you won't be
able to see it right now but yeah it is
after this container let's position this
we don't want it here we want it to go a
little right
and from bottom we wanted to go a little
up so what we are going to do here is
from bottom we want 20 and from the left
because we want to go in right we want
20. so we'll save it and here it is this
looks good now we'll reduce the radius
so we'll keep at 40 and this looks
better
now the next thing
is outside of this stack after the size
box we need some text editing
controllers because we want the name
controller the bio controller so that we
can change it so we have text editing
controller final bio controller which is
equal to text editing controller
then we have dispose functions for it
and then we are going to have name
controller dot dispose
biocontroller dot dispose
so after this we can go down and here we
are not going to have any styling for
our text field actually because that's
how Twitter looks it there is nothing no
that doesn't feel to be any styling so
we can just pass in the controller as
name controller decoration can be
constant input decoration
the hint text let's put hint text as
name
save it and here you can see this looks
better already but let's add a bit of
padding so we have content padding of
edge insets dot all
80.
and this looks much better
now we can copy this text field
and paste it over here
now you can see we have two text Fields
let's put some height between these two
text Fields so we have constant size box
height 20. save it and here it is looks
better
now we'll put this as bio bio controller
and save it
also in the bio the bio can be longer so
we want Max lines property to be let's
say 4.
and here it is the Bible is much bigger
this looks good so we're going to keep
it this way now the last thing that we
need is the app bar so where you're
right at the top you're going to have an
app bar
with a title and the title is going to
be text edit profile now we can const it
and save it here you see we have our
edit profiles showing up
we don't want the center title so we can
remove that so it shifts to the left
hand side similar to Twitter and now we
finally need an actions button basically
a button over here so we are going to
use actions and have text button over
there
now on pressed is going to be an empty
function the child is going to be
constant text of save basically save all
the details here
we save it and here we see the save
button showing up this is cool
now what I want to do is whenever the
user clicks on this profile picture
banner picture sorry or this profile
picture
we should be able to see open the image
picker we have already created a
function for picking multi images we're
going to create a similar function but
to pick just one image
and also this typo is there so let's
edit that and actually edit that and go
to
utils.create our function which is
similar to this but this time we are
just going to return one file which is
Future
file
and this can be nullable
we'll remove the list of images we have
a match picker we will remove all of
this
we get the image file over here because
we are not going to pick multi match we
are picking just one image and the
source will be image source dot gallery
so from the gallery we want to pick our
image and now we can return a file
saying
MH file Dot
path obviously we need to put a check if
image file dot is not equal to null so
if it is not equal to null then we want
to return
a file but if it is not null then we
want to return null
I think I said it already I think I said
it differently
so this should be pick image
so if image file is not null that means
the user actually picked some image
we're going to return the file with the
path similar logic to what we had here
otherwise you're just going to return
null that the user has not selected any
picture
so now we can go to the user edit
profile picture and now create two
functions one for selecting the banner
image
let's work on that first so this is
going to be asynchronous and then we are
going to get the banner so we have
Banner equal to await pick image not
pick images
and now we are going to check if Banner
is not equal to null so Banner is not
null what do we want to do well we are
going to create Global variables here
which are nullable and make sure that
this is not apprite models.dot
I've already told you that file also
exists in apprite models what we want is
import dot IO
so we are going to import that and then
we are going to have let's say Banner
fight
so this is null basically the point of
this variable is that we want to display
the banner file if it's selected
on the screen so if we have it globally
we can display it and we've done similar
things for the edit profile not edit
profile sorry we have done it for the
create tweet screen as well
the similar thing we are going to do
here we have file question mark we're
just going to have
globally created and if Banner your the
image selected is not null then we want
to set States so that the build function
rebuilds and then we have Banner file
equal to Banner so basically This Global
variable is equal to the banner that we
have selected
okay now what we want to do is just bind
this function
to whenever we click here so we want to
wrap our
entire size box which contains a stack
not the stack let's just contain this
one so you're going to wrap it with a
gesture detector and we're going to have
an on tap and in the on Tab we are just
going to mention
select Banner image
here let's also add the property that if
Banner file is not equal to null so a
banner file is not equal to null then we
want image dot file and we'll pass in
the banner file
otherwise we'll just check that the unit
binary is empty if it's empty then we
want palette dot blue color otherwise
image.network
now let's try to see if it works I'll
click over here
I'm going to select a image
keep current selection
okay this feels good I can select this
image also but I wanted to take the
entire space possible so I'm going to
have fit as box fit
dot contain
or cover
fit with sorry
so you're going to unbox fit dot fit
with we do it for your and also for year
so we have box fit dot Fitbit so that it
fits the entire width
great now you want to do the same thing
for the profile picture as well so we'll
copy this have void select
put a file
image then we want profile image if
profile image is not equal to null then
we want this so we'll have file
profile file
and then profile file should be equal to
profile image great now we can copy this
go down in the circle Avatar wrap it
with the gesture detector we're not
going to wrap the position widget we're
going to add the circle Avatar and we
have on tap
and pass in the select profile image
now when we click over here we can
select another image so we have leaf
it doesn't show up so to show it we can
do it right here but when you do it over
here it doesn't fit for example if I
just show it to you we have profile file
not equal to null then I want to show
file image right our image is a file so
you want to show file image profile file
okay but this is giving us this error
the argument type file cannot be
assigned to the parameter type file
so if I just do this it shows another
the argument type object cannot be
assigned to the parameter Type image
provider object okay so we cannot do it
this way
we'll have to find another way another
way is to wrap this
so profile file is not equal to null
then I'm going to have a circle Avatar
widget
that's right but here I'm going to have
file image and I'm going to use the file
as profile file
so since we cannot do it in the
background image we had to do it in the
child property of gesture detector
and now if we come over here you can see
Leaf is showing up
this is pretty cool now
last thing is whenever we do all of
these changes and click on Save we want
to save all of this data in the users
document so to do that we are going to
close all the save files for now we're
going to the user API and creating a
function for it in the abstract class
so we are going to create a function
called future either void we are not
going to return anything from this
function we are just going to update the
user data and that's it
and while updating the user data we
obviously need the user model because we
don't know what has changed
now I'm going to create one missing
override
and obviously I need all the try catch
block so I'm just going to copy this
paste all the boilerplate code have
async over here
and see what I want to change well over
here I want to update the document
that's first change database ID is
correct collection ID is indeed users
collection the document IDs
usermodel.uid the data is usermodel.2map
that means everything else is just fine
so I can use this now I just want to go
to the user profile controller and
create my function
what is my function well
void update user model
or user profile
and here I'm going to get certain things
so I'll just
put required since there are many
arguments to be taken from
this function I am putting it in a named
Constructor Whenever there are more than
you know two or three just put it in the
name Constructor so that it's much
easier
first thing I require is the user model
so I've user model then I want the build
context so that I can display errors
because a lot of stuff is going to go
into this I want to upload images right
then I need file
and this file should not be apprite file
it should be dot IO
make sure it's not even dot HTML okay
and now we can have Banner file and
similarly we are going to have profile
file
why are these variables null because
these variables can be none
when the user doesn't select anything
these are null so we don't want to
change them correct
cool now we just want to check if Banner
file is not equal to null so if Banner
file is not null what do I want to do
well I want to upload the data or the
upload the file to the storage get the
download URL and add it to my user model
simple enough we already have a function
for it already created so I'll just
import storage API where I've already
implemented this so that it can be
reused
I'm going to require this through the
Constructor
and have underscore storage API equal to
storage API
now what I'm going to do is final Banner
URL is equal to a weight so we'll put
async over here
underscore storageapi Dot
upload image and what is the image that
we are trying to upload well it's going
to be in a list format and it's the
banner file
and now once we get the banner URL
it's going to be in a list format
because we are uploading a list but it's
just going to have one thing one element
in its list
because you have uploaded only one file
right and according to our logic and
upload image we run through every file
and add it to image links we are going
to run only one time so it will have
only one image and now
I can just do user model equal to
usermodel dot copyright and I'm going to
replace the banner URL so we have Banner
pick as Banner URL
add 0 because I want to grab the first
element
if you do first
you know 0 add to 1
then it will give us an error because it
is index out of range the list length is
only one how can you access one when the
numbering starts from zero
similar logic is going to go in the
profile file as well so if profile file
is not equal to null
then we are going to upload the profile
file and then we are going to have
profile picture as
let's rename this to profile URL and we
have profile URL at zero
and then we are going to have final
result is equal to await underscore user
so we don't have access to user API we
also want to get user API
because we are going to call the user
API so that we can store the data
correct now we have user API and we can
do required
user API user API
and underscore user API should be user
API
now I'll take this underscore user API
put it here and call
update user data function on it don't
use the save user data if you use Save
user data it will again create a
document and it will override the
existing document so that means your
followers and everything
might just go away
so we have this done now we just fold it
so that we know if it's a success or a
failure in case of failure we show
l dot failure you know l dot message
failure and in case of success what do
we want to do well
we just want to pop because I want to
get out of the screen
so I can pop it right here
now I'll go up at the top I'll add
storage API which is ref.watch storage
API provider I'll add user API which is
ref.watch to user API provider
and save it
now all of the update user profile work
is done let's go to our edit profile
view
add everything to this save button so we
have ref dot read
user profilecontroller dot Notifier
Dot and what do we want to do well we
want to update the user profile so we
can update user profile pass in the user
model which is user
and this cannot be null
because the user will only click on the
save button after this user is equal to
null all of these validations have
happened
then we have context Banner file profile
picture already passed in and everything
is now done
also one important thing that I want to
add
is state so if state is true I want to
add this
and
state is false I want to add here
so basically
is loading so it's loading has started
is loaded as ending so here now I just
want to share if it's loading then I
want to watch
the user profile controller provider
if I hover over this this is object so
I'll go up at the top in place of State
Notifier provider add the type so it's
user profile controller and Boolean
after you add this you'll notice
this is now the type Boolean and that is
five for every state Notifier provider
we created I mentioned the type but not
for future provider or state or your
stream provider
now I can take this as loading and put
it here so if it's loading or the user
is null then we are going to show the
loader otherwise our widget tree now I'm
just going to restart my application I'm
going to go to the user profile so I'll
just have test
I'll click on edit user profile let's
select an image this one looks nice
saitama also looks good I'm just going
to rename myself as Revan
and my bio will be hello there
how are you
and then click on Save we saw loading
indicator for some time but no problem
and if you see this has not updated but
if I just restart my application
go to the test user again
you can see I'm seeing the banner
picture but this is not quite correct so
I can go to my profile view
the user profile
and here in the image.network I can have
fit as box fit dot fit with
after I do this this looks much much
better
but other thing that did not change is
the
name of the user and the buyer of the
user why was that well that's because if
we go back to the user profile
here we have passed in
the save sorry the edit profile if we go
there you see we have just passed in the
user we have not updated the user anyway
basically this is the same user that was
there we have not updated that bio so we
don't know if we want to update the bio
of the user or not so here what I want
to do is user.copy with and I'm going to
update the bio as
biocontroller dot text and
the name of the user will be name
controller dot text
but what if I just come over here and
click on Save after changing these
profile pictures it's just going to take
the biocontroller.txt right now it's an
empty string it will just take that I
don't want that to happen so what I'm
going to do here is provide with a
default name in the NH state
so what I mean by that is I'm going to
have text editing controller
let's call this late text editing
controller
also this will be late
text editing controller bio controller
remove that
and in the init State method
I'm going to specify this so name
controller is equal to
text editing controller
and here we want to provide the text
what is the initial text that needs to
be filled in so the initial text is ref
dot read since we're using outside of
the build function in some in its state
or dispose like methods the widget life
cycle methods
we are going to use ref.read and we are
just going to copy all of this
so let's paste it in I want ref.trade
and we want
the name of the user to be there
but you can see this value is empty uh
null right so if it's null then I just
want to do if it is null
then I want there to be an empty string
otherwise nothing
the same thing will go for the
biocontroller as well we are going to
have bio controller
ref dot read but this will be bio
and none
now if we come from edit profile over
here you can see test is there bio let's
write it again hello there how are you
and my name right now is going to be
let's say whatever I'll click on Save
nothing gets changed but if I again
try to restart my thing so if I just
restart my application like this
I can just have test
there's no user with the name test let's
find Revan here there is and here is the
bio hello there how are you this looks
great the edit profile feature is now
complete
the next feature is the follow feature
so that we can increase account but even
before that I want this to happen
basically I want everything to happen in
real time you saw when I edited the
profile and came here it was not real
time update I want that to happen so how
can I do that with the help of
real time so I'm going to do exactly
that first and then go to the follow
section because even while following
when the user clicks on follow we want
this numbers to update automatically so
real time will help there as well so
let's get started with real time first
configure it for the profile screen and
then we can
go to the follow button so there are two
approaches with real time you can take
your first approach is not what I'm
going to show you is the second approach
basically we can go to the user API and
here obviously the normal real time we
are going to use so we are going to have
final real time underscore real time
and we are going to have required real
time real time I'll show you the second
approach
but first let me just have underscore
real time equal to real time
when we get to the second part I'll let
you know here let's just have real time
as ref dot watch real time
provider
and here we are going to have stream of
real-time message just like we had for
our tweet we're going to have that and
we are going to have get latest user
profile data
we have profile data and that's it
now we are going to create one missing
override we are going to have here and
now we are going to return underscore
realtime dot subscribe now we need to
provide a list of channels to subscribe
to dot stream
and what is the channel well we are just
going to copy from the Tweet API so we
have underscore
real time
dot subscribe let me just find
here it is I'm just going to copy this
and paste it over here
so you have databases dot app right
constant database ID but the collection
here should be users collection
dot documents and
what I was talking about this is the
first approach this is the first channel
you can subscribe to the second channel
that you can subscribe to is
getting the uid of the user from here
updated accordingly in the abstract
class and just use that uid over here so
we have collections of user collections
dot documents dot dollar uid
but this is not the approach you are
going to take you can take this also
there's no doubt about it
now we can just go to the
profile
controller
and we're going to have it created over
here right at the top stream provider
remember we did this for the Tweet
controller as well
we are not going to create anything and
use a profile controller we're going to
go
in the Stream provider directly so here
we're going to have get latest user
profile data provider
so let me just copy this
we don't need anything from stream
provider let's just remove it and here
we are going to have final user API is
equal to ref.watch user API provider
let me have user API provider and we are
going to return user API Dot
get latest user profile data okay now I
can copy this go to my profile user
profile view right here and now I can
use my ref
this is why we had used consumer widget
right
so in the body we are going to have ref
dot watch
get latest user profile data provider
dot when and then we want to handle the
error and the loading States first so we
have error
text and then we pass in error.2 string
then we need loading loading is just
going to be constant loader
now I can copy this
and
in the data I can paste it right there
so I have this
so we're going to return the user
profile
now in the user profile we get the
latest user profile data all of that now
we are just going to check if
latest
or if data dot events dot contains just
like we did for tweet
we are just going to check if it
contains the update property because we
have updated the user profile right so
if it contains this channel
then we have to make some changes so
what is it that we want to see well
let's just copy everything from the user
API first
so we'll copy this thing
and we're going to replace everything
with upright constants with star so that
you know it can be anything
also remove this make sure this is
correct
and here you need to make sure that the
documents after documents there is user
ID so we'll just do dollar user
model Dot uid
dot update
okay now even before that we have some
other thing to do so databases dot star
dot collections dot star so this
collections.star is not going to be star
because we don't want to see if tweets
collection has an update no we just want
to see if the user's collection has any
update so we're just going to have
upright
constants
dot users collection
let's import upright constants
then we have documents then we have uid
and then we have update and now what I
want to do is basically if there is any
update I just want to take the user data
convert it to user model and send it to
user profile
so we can send the same user model but
only problem is we have used final over
here
if your views final we cannot reassign
it so what can we do instead well we can
just make another user model we can call
this copy of user which will be equal to
the user model that we get from The
Constructor now we can take this copy of
user pass it over here pass it to this
as well copy of user.uid
and even here because this is not final
and then we can say copy of user is user
model Dot from map data dot payload
okay so if any changes happen so if
update is create called copy of user is
usermodel Dot from map so we give it an
instance of another user model
and return the user profile with copy of
user so if this changes this will return
again
having understood this let's restart
also
I think the loader is constantly going
to load but before that what I want to
happen is whenever I click over here I
want to go to the user's profile right
so to go to the user's profile
I can go to the Tweet card
and go to the circle Avatar this part
right here I can
wrap this with a gesture detector and
have on tap
Navigator
dot push context and the route is where
do you want to go user profile view
dot route and then we want to pass in
the user model the user model is user
not the current user don't pass that in
even by mistake it should be the user
that we're getting from here
okay good now if I click over here you
can see constant loading this is the
real time problem that I discussed in
the Tweet section as well basically we
are not getting any error we are not
getting any data so it's thinking that
we are in the loading state so it's
continuously loading so you basically
want to return user profile here
and it should fix a problem now if I try
to change the bio let's say how are you
how are you
two more times and save it you can see
it is real time updated that's pretty
cool now if I want to change the banner
image to say waterfalls I'll click on
Save and it shows up real time this is
pretty cool right now the next feature
is the follow button so whenever the
user clicks on follow
we want to be able to show the users
followers to increase but I cannot do it
from here
because I'm on this account only
so what I'm going to do is open up pixel
the Android emulator and run it over
there
I'll see you when it starts working I'll
also log in and do all of the
authentication processes and then see
you so for the follow I'm just going to
close all the save files I'm going to go
to the user profile controller and here
I'm going to create a function called
void follow user and here we're going to
require some things the user model
I'll explain all of this so why do we
need all of this then we need build
context
and then we need the current user
so what is the difference between the
user and the current user well the user
user is the person we are trying to
follow
the current user is us so we need both
of them why because we want to check
certain things
so we want to check if the current user
contains the user's ID so if so Suppose
there are two users this is Revan user
the iOS simulator user and this is Naman
the Android emulator user now when the
user Revan tries to follow Naman what
should happen well first of all there
should be a check so does everyone
already follow Naman so if driven
already follows Naman then there should
be an unfollow button here not a follow
button
but if the user Revan does not have
Naman in this following list then you
can click on follow but when follow if
clicked what should happen so if follow
is clicked the following of Revan should
increase and the followers of Naman
should increase
but if the user clicks on unfollow
button
that means that the
user already follows
Naman
then the following of Revan should
decrease and the followers of Naman
should increase this is similar to the
like concept basically if the user is
already like the post should we add it
and if
the user has not liked it then we should
add it
like that only so here what we are
trying to do is getting both the user
and the current user and then we will
check if the current user dot following
so if we are the current user we want
is my following containing the uid of
the
user we are trying to follow so if we
are trying to follow
that means you have already followed
this means
already following so if we are already
following what do we want to do well
there's an unfollow the button that's
showing up so you want to remove the
user from the followers list so we have
user.followers so you want to remove
ourselves from the user's followers list
so we can just have user.followers dot
remove
current user Dot uid
and one more thing should happen the
current user's following should also
remove
the user's uid
so it should decrease both the places
the user's followers
and the current users following
else we are not already following the
user then what do we want to do well the
exact process opposite process that's
followed here we want to add the
follower and we want to add the uid over
here okay
now what we want to do is user equal to
user.copy with followers will be
user.followers
we have made that changes over here
and then we want to do current user is
equal to current user.copy with
followers will be current users dot
followers actually we need to do
following because we are updating the
current users following right
and then we can have following
if you didn't understand this process
don't worry I'm going to give a dry run
after this
when we try to follow a user and
everything works fine
now we are going to have final result is
equal to await underscore user API Dot
what do we want to do well we want to
follow our user
so we have to create those functions in
the user API so let's go over there
so let's go to the user API here we are
going to add certain things the first
thing is
follow user and it's going to be future
either void
follow user
and we just want to get the user model
okay
this user model is going to be the user
model of the
user
because we are trying to update their
follow count right that's what we are
trying to do over here
of course you're going to have that
normal try catch all of those blocks
also put an async over here
put try catch block after copying it and
here we are just going to have user.uid
the data here will be a bit different
the data will be followers
and it will be user dot follows so we
are just updating the document
of user.uid which is the user we are
trying to follow
and we are just updating the
user.followers because we have done that
over here right
now another function that we need is add
to following function basically similar
to follow user we are going to have add
to following but this time we are going
to pass the current user because we want
to increase their following right
so we can create one missing override
we're going to copy this exact same
thing
paste it over here
put async
but this time when we update the
document it should be following and user
Dot
following
that's it this is pretty much it this is
the two functions that we need after
creating these two functions we can just
call follow user we'll pass in the user
Make sure to pass in user because we are
incrementing the user we are changing
the user's followers over here
and now we do res dot fold in case of
error show snack bar
l dot message in case of success we'll
have to do one more thing
what is another thing that we want to do
well
the same thing the same function that we
created obviously this is going to be
async but add to following but this time
it's not going to be User it's going to
be current user because we have updated
the following of the current user you
can see that over here
now we are just going to have rest 2 dot
fold in case of error again show snack
bar l dot message and in case of success
as of now nothing
we are not going to have state is equal
to true and all of that is loading part
because whenever we click on the follow
user button all of that doesn't show up
right
now I can go to the user profile view
actually
the user profile
and here we can just call the method
in the else of on pressed basically if
current user.uid is user ID then this is
the edit profile right
but if that's not the case else we're
going to have ref dot read
user profilecontroller provider.nodifier
Dot
follow user so we're getting just one
epi exposed but inside of this one
function there's a lot of stuff
happening you can see that that's the
main point of this architecture
abstraction
now after having and passing all of
these three things inside of it
so I'll just restart both the
applications
also I just got to know that here I've
just added a follow
thing so what I want to show here is is
if current user Dot
not current user sorry
we can just have current user Dot
following dot contains the user.uid
so that means the same logic that we
have applied to the user profile
controller then we want follow unfollow
button to show otherwise the follow
button
okay
now we'll just restart everything
I'll just go to the naman's profile so
let's go Naman
and here if I click on follow button I
get unfollow immediately I get one
followers now if I go to my profile
now there's two following and one
follower over here because
I've changed this back to
users dot following dot length and
user.followers.link because if we go to
the noman's profile so if we just go
over there Naman
you'll see there's zero following and
one follower because I just followed
so this works fine on naman's following
count but it doesn't work fine on drives
following count that's why I haven't
I've changed it back to normal okay
so the follow also works now are
here there are zero followers because I
unfollowed
now you see I'll just go
through the dry run so now we are
checking if current user dot following
so this is the current user it does my
following contain naman's uid no it
doesn't so we get the following button
now if I click on follow what should
happen
according to my logic
user.followers.addcurrentuser.uid that
means this guy should get one follower
and my following should increase so if I
click over here one follower
I'll go where I'll go to Revan one
follower and two following my following
increased now if I unfollow
you can see according to the logic if it
contains then we should remove the user
follower so this should become 0 and my
following should decrease by one so if I
unfollow and go back to my user profile
one following and one follower that
means this works well so the following
logic now works well now the next thing
that we need to work on is the
notifications feature basically this tab
over here whenever the user likes a
photo retweets a photo replies to a
photo or follows you we want all of them
to show up in the notification screen so
let's get into the notification part
we are very close to closing on our app
of complete Twitter clone so let's get
to the next section so for notifications
I'm just going to close all the save
files I am going to the API and here I'm
going to add notification underscore API
dot dot and now I'm just going to create
the abstract class just like we had
before I notification
API then I'm going to have
future either void
create notification and this create
notification is going to be based on
notification model so we'll have to go
down
create a notification model so we have
notification underscore model dot dot
and then we have notification
and let's think of the properties we
need to have first is the text so what
is a text
final string post ID
final string ID
the post ID is like suppose if the user
likes to post a retweets a post you need
the post ID so that when you click on it
you can go to that certain post then you
need the ID of that ID of the
notification
then the ID of the user who has
who's who we need to send to so
basically if I follow another person
another person should get the
notification
and then we need the type of the
notification so what was the type of the
notification was it retweet user
or the following user part or the liking
user what was it so for that we'll have
to create an enum so we'll go to the
enums folder and here we're going to
create notification
type
enum dot dot now this is going to be
simple very straightforward we'll copy
it paste it here and add our own Fields
first one is notification type
I'll replace this over here and over
here
then what are the notification enums
that we are going to have well whenever
the user likes so we have like
whenever the user replies so we have
reply
whenever the user decides to follow so
we have follow
and whenever the user decides to retweet
so we have retweet
and now we want the same thing over here
so we can copy this retweet have
notification type dot retweet
if the user decides to follow
notification type dot follow
if the user decides to reply then you
have case reply
and this will return notification type
dot reply
and
if it's none of them then it's going to
be like so we can just have notification
type dot like
okay now we can come to the notification
model and have notification
type
notification type
and generate a data class based on this
now obviously we'll remove dot convert
we'll have to make some changes in the
to map from map but first let's remove
these two
now in the from map what we need
well here basically we have added a
extension on string so let's rename the
extension also here
this should be two tweet
type so it should be two notification
type enum then I can copy it and paste
it here so we'll treat this as string
dot notification type in this is very
similar to what we did in the
tweet model so make sure you understand
this by going through that section again
if you want to
now we can have notification type DOT
type let's remove this
the ID here should be removed
because we don't want that ID and here
it should be map slash dollar ID
okay now having all of this done we need
to create a notification based on this
notification model
now I can have my class notification API
implementing I notification API
now I can create one missing override
also
here we might require some things first
is databases so we have underscore DB
then we have notification API then we'll
require it so we have data basis DB
with underscore DB equal to DB
and now to create a notification we are
going to have async and we are going to
go to the user API to copy everything
you know the try and catch block
everything let's just copy it
and paste it in the notification API
now what do we have to do here we have
to create a document correct so we'll
just go here and call create
document
now we'll import app right constants
then we will have database ID
now we need collection ID also but it
can't be users collection it has to be
notifications collection
right because we stored all the users in
users collection we stored all the
tweets and tweets collection so all the
notifications should go in the
notifications collection so let's open
our app right database
let's create a new collection here call
it notifications
copy The Collection ID go to Upright
constants add that here so we have one
more
which is
notifications collection
copy The Collection ID of notifications
and paste it over here
now we can have notifications collection
as a collection ID
now what should be the document ID over
here
so the document ID should be ID dot uni
right
because every notification should have
its own ID and data here should be
notification
dot to Mac
now we will return write null and if
there's any exception we'll just throw
it across
sweet now
this notification the create
notification is going to be used in
several other controllers for example in
the Tweet controller when we like a
tweet
we'll have to create a notification
saying that this user has liked your
Tweet
so this should happen so for now we will
just make sure that whenever the user
clicks on like button they get the
notification over here and then we will
work on the displaying part and making
it real time
and then we can work on the retweet
replying and follow part
okay
so now I'll just close all the save
files I'll just go to the Tweet
controller where I have my like
tweet here after the like tweet has been
completed and it's a success in the
right what do we have to do we have to
create a notification so we'll have
final notification API underscore
notification API
we are going to require this through the
Constructor so we have notification
API
and then underscore notification API is
equal to notification API what we are
doing is basically just storing data on
the
app right database and getting it that's
all
so right here after we like a tweet
what happens is whenever the user likes
a tweet
the counter and all of that increases
but we also send a notification to app
right that yeah the user has liked your
Tweet right now so it should show up in
this tab as well
okay
so here I'm just going to have
notification API
dot create notification and
here I'll have to pass in my
notification API related notification
model but instead of doing all of this
can be simplified even further
what we can do is just create a new
feature here called notifications
then we are going to have a controller
and it's going to be called notification
controller
so this controller will basically modify
everything
it will create a notification model so
that we don't have to create it again
and again and will handle the error
processes that we have to face
so here we are just going to create a
state Notifier
called notification controller we'll
remove the Notifier from here then we
have state node file
Boolean
false
and then a state Notifier provider and
then we are going to have notification
controller provider
controller Boolean
and then we should have final
notification controller is equal to ref
dot watch
okay not this sorry
we'll have to return notification
controller only my bad
so here we are going to have final
notification API underscore notification
API
we are going to require this through the
Constructor notification API
notification API underscore notification
API is equal to notification API okay
that's pretty cool now we'll pass a
notification API as ref.watch
notification API provider but we haven't
created a provider for that API so let's
just go right at the top and create a
provider for it so we'll have
notification API provider I'm running
through this because we have already
covered it many many times
and we'll pass in notification API and
for the DB it's ref.watch
app right database provider
easy enough now let's go to the
controller and we have notification API
provider
now we are going to create a very simple
function of void create
notification where we are going to
require
the text we are going to require the
post ID
so what post was liked or what post was
you know commented on
then the notification type
and then the uid so we have required
string uid
so what is the user Rider okay now we
will just create a notification based on
the notification model so we have
notification
we pass in the text post ID the ID is an
empty string no uid notification type
and that's it
we're not passing anything in the ID
because we don't have to save an ID
upright will automatically generate it
now we just need to call it so we have
await underscore notification let's put
async over
await notification API dot create
notification pass in the notification
model and we are done
now we'll go to the Tweet controller and
here instead of having notification API
we will have notification
controller notification controller
so here it will be notification
controller
just change it in all the places
and after the change has been made aware
let's just go down take this create a
notification so we pass in Dot create
notification pass in the text which is
tweet dot text the post ID
should be tweet.id
the notification type should be
notification type dot like
and uid should be tweet.uid basically we
the uid is going to be the user to whom
we are sending the notification so if
it's tweet.id then it's going to be the
ID of the Tweet if it's tweet.uid to the
uid of the person to whom the Tweet is
being sent and if we use user.uid then
it will be sent to us only and that
makes no sense
okay
so after this notification has been made
I think
we should only display it so before
going there we just need to pass a
notification controller to get
notification controller we need to
create a state notify provider which
we've already created
so just copy it
come over here and have ref.watch
notification controller provider dot
note F5
now I think we can restart the app
on both the devices also
let's add some attributes here so we'll
go to our notification model
see what all fields are there text is
there so we'll add text which is going
to be a string and the size is going to
be 255 required
now the next attribute is going to be
post ID
which is also going to be a string
required 255 then we need uid the uid of
the user to whom this should be sent
create
the notification type
string and create
so now we have created the notification
model now let's try to like some post
after liking one post let's
restart
we're not seeing anything
so let's try to print it out here why we
are not seeing that so we'll go to like
tweet
and here we'll just try to print l dot
message
now if we try to like some post no error
shows up but if we refresh nothing shows
up over here as well
so there's no error over here but we
forgot to handle the error in this case
so let's have a
handle over here so basically whenever
we have some this done so we have final
result is equal to await this done and
then we fold it and in case of failure
we just want to do l dot message
okay
now let's try to like something
here you can see the current user is not
authorized obviously so we need to go to
the settings
we need to get to the role all the users
can create or read the notifications but
they cannot update and delete
okay
now let me try to like another post
I'll refresh it and here we can see the
document
the text is showing up as hello but this
is not the text we want the notification
type uid and post ID seem correct
so now let's give another message here
the Tweet text should not be tweet.text
it should actually be that
the user dot name liked your Tweet so
basically dollar user dot name like
your
Twee
this should be the text now if I like
some other post
you see it should get added over here
Revan liked your Tweet
now if I try to cover and like some post
you can see the liking feature is not
really working
it's not working because of some logic
error that we have made
so let's take a gap from notifications
part and see why we are getting this
error as of now
and after a bit of debugging I found out
that this problem occurred because here
we have passed in the user it should not
be user but the current user
now we made this error I should have
rectified it earlier and that's my fault
I'm sorry but
why do we have to pass in the current
user because if you go to the like tweet
if tweet dot likes dot contains user ID
so it should contain the current user's
ID right
so if it contains the user ID then we
don't have to like it and all of that
stuff so you need to pass in the current
user not the user okay
now if you try to like any post you can
see we get to like it
and it works properly
so this was the problem now after fixing
this problem now the next thing we need
to do is go to the Tweet controller we
are also getting the notifications
correctly now we just want to display
them so to display them in the
notifications
folder
we are going to have views and it's just
going to be notification views so we
have notification underscore view dot
dot now we can import material dot we
can create a stateless
and it can be stateless consumer so we
have notification View
then we can have consumer widget
and here we are going to return a
scaffold with an app bar saying this is
the notifications and
section so we have title constant
text notifications
save it and
to see it we can go over here
we cannot see it so we'll copy this go
to the UI constants
paste it over here
and we should be able to see
notification stuff pretty cool
now what we want to do is get all the
notifications now this is similar to the
Tweet functionality so in the tweet
API will go we are going to go here and
have get tweets so we're just going to
copy this exact thing and paste it in
the notification API
so we can paste it over here but here
the name is going to be a bit different
so let's copy it
paste it over here but it's not going to
be called get tweets first of all let's
also get document from upright models
it's not going to be called get notif
get tweets it's going to be called get
notifications
and we'll be needing the uid of the user
so what users notifications do we have
to get
and exactly this is going to be the
function name
and this is going to be string uid final
documents list documents database ID
tweets collection is not going to be
there notifications collector but what
is the filter that we need to apply we
don't need to get all the documents that
are available in the notifications
collection right we only want to get the
notifications which match the uid so
it's going to be query dot equal uid uid
so you want to get
all the notifications from a particular
user ID
and then we return it
and since I'm feeling confident about
this what I'm going to do is also copy
get latest tweet
so that we can make it real time and
work it without you know jumping through
each and everything and here it's going
to be called get latest notification
if you don't feel comfortable with it I
would recommend you to try it on your
own
you know first implement the future
provider with this get notifications and
then add stream provider but for me it's
a lot of copy paste code so I can just
have real time passed in directly
so we have required
real time real time
and this should be underscore
real time is equal to real time
also this needs to be get latest
notification so I can just go right at
the top and have stream
real time message
and get latest notification
and your
The Collection should be notifications
collection dot documents okay
now at the top we are having real time
which will be ref.watch real upright
real-time provider
and we are done now we just need to go
to the notifications controller
right here
and we'll be having stream provider over
here
and in the Stream provider what are we
going to have well get latest
notification provider we want to get the
latest notification
so we'll remove the async star
then we have final notification
controller or notification API in this
case
which is equal to ref dot watch
notification API provider
and then we are going to return
notification API dot get latest
notification
after having this we are going to have
future provider
and this is going to be
get notifications provider
then we are going to have future
provider
dot family and then we are going to have
the uid of the user that we'll be asking
from the parameter now here let's remove
the print call
we are going to create a model
conversion thing so as we have done it
before multiple times we're going to
have future notification model
or just notification
get notifications
we'll take in a string uid async
I know I'm rushing through this but if
you don't understand let me know in the
comment section and I'll help you out
with it we're just going to have await
notification API dot get notifications
we'll pass in the particular uid and
then map through all the notifications
get one particular notification
and then just have notification Dot from
map e dot data and convert it to a list
let's also import the notification model
so let's import it we don't have to
import it from dot HTML or anything
it's from the notification model
and now you can see we are getting this
error because it's defined this
notification is defined in two places so
what we can do is prefix this or just
rename notification model I'm just going
to prefix this as model and have
model dot notification model dot
notification
model.notification Dot from map
and this will be future list of model
dot notification
okay
now finally I'm just going to create
final
notification controller which is equal
to
ref.watch notification controller
provider and then going to return
notification controller Dot
and I don't have access to anything so I
can just use dot Notifier to get access
to my method of get notification
easy enough now I'll go to my
notification view in the body I'm going
to
have ref.watch and all of that stuff but
before I get into that part what I want
to do
is just get the current user so that I
can get the uid so we have final current
user equal to ref dot watch
current user details provider dot value
this cannot be null here we need to
check if current user is equal to null
then we want to show a loader otherwise
no loader is required and we want to
show the latest notifications now this
is going to be very similar to what we
have done earlier
what earlier well just the user profile
view
so we can go over there
not user profile view sorry to wait to
eat
View
the Twitter reply View
I can just copy all of this code from
here
including all the error loading all of
those stuff
and paste it over here now we have to
resolve all of these errors so let's
resolve first let's import the common
dot dot so that we have error text and
loader
now in the loading we don't have to show
anything like a tweet card in fact we
need to show notification tile so for
now let's just put a text of let's say
tweet and this is not even a tweet this
is notification
and
you're going to get notifications index
so to resolve this let's go directly at
the top and here it's not going to be
get replaced on tweet it's going to be
get notifications provider and then
we'll pass in the user's ID so we have
user
the current user
Dot uid
then we keep track of get latest
notification provider
we get some data then
we just check over here so we don't have
to put the if condition so we'll go down
remove the shift condition
and here we are going to check for
upright constants so we'll add that but
not tweets collection the notifications
collection
and we are looking for a create Command
right we are not looking for any update
command because it's never going to
update so let's remove all of those
update logic
and it's not going to be notification or
tweets it's going to be notifications so
I can insert that
this can be notification
Dot from map obviously we'll again have
to
import notification as model just like
we did in our
notification controller so if we go
there just like this we'll have to copy
it
and paste it
so we can go in the notification view
paste it
and now we'll have
model dot notification not from map
okay now this should be notifications
dot length
notifications at index and this is one
notification
and now we'll just return a text which
just says notification
dot to string
even here it's going to be notifications
dot link we'll get one particular
notification and two string
simple and good
I'll remove the loading page from here
I'll come back over here and you see
apprite exception index not found we
basically want to create a new index
here saying uid
equal
so it's going to be a key and your ID
should be in descending order created
rerun the application
go to the notification section and we
get this error so we are getting this
error here basically because we are not
removed expanded there's no need of
expanded because we are going to get the
entire body there's no column or
anything even in the loading part we'll
just remove it and we'll restart the app
go via and you can see the notifications
showing up but do we want to show all
the notifications that are present over
here not really
we only want to show the notification
which matches the current user's uid so
here what we want to do is get the
latest notification right so you have
latest notification in a model format so
we'll cut and paste it over here and
here I'll check if latest notification
dot uid is equally equal to current
user.uid
then what do I want to do only then do I
want to insert it
right at the top so we have latest
notification
if it does not match then I don't want
to add it why would I add other person's
notification
to my notifications tab you can see over
here we are listening to all the
documents being created right
this was the second approach I was
talking about
you remember when we were doing tweets
part a user profile part there were two
here we could add the document ID or we
could just do this if condition over
here
anyways now that it's done
we can restart the app
underwear let's see this a guy has some
things and for our pixel let's rebuild
and over here if we see there are some
notifications here as well
now we just need to display them in a
good format
so to display them we are going to
create a new widget here
call notification tile
import material dot create a stateless
widget called notification tile
and then we are going to have final
notification
and require it through the Constructor
but not the notification from
material.dot no not that one we want it
from this one
right you can just name your
notification and notification model
so that you have to avoid this prefix
every single time
so now we'll have required this dot
notification
now here we are going to return a list
Style and if you've seen Twitter you'll
know that in the leading icon it really
depends on the notification type so if
notification type is follow it will give
you some other icon if it's like it will
give you a like icon like that so here
in the leading part we are going to
check that so if notification dot
notification type is equal to
notification
type which is the enum
is equal to follow if it's followed then
I want constant I can as icons dot
person
and I want color to be palette dot blue
color
otherwise we are going to have
another logic
basically if notification dot
notification type is equal to
notification type dot like
save the user has liked it what do you
want to show well
in that case I want to show SVG
picture.asset via 3G picture.asset
because I have an SVG file for it
why not use it
so it will be like filled icon
the color will be palette dot red color
and height will be
20.
you know just so that it remains at the
same size as that of a follow button or
the person icon that's being shown when
the user tries to follow someone
otherwise
the notification dot notification type
is equal to notification type dot
retweet and if it's retweet then what do
you want to show
well it's going to be an SVG picture dot
asset again
so we'll have that but it's not going to
be like field icon it's going to be the
normal retweet icon with white color in
it
and if it's none of these we just don't
want to return anything
so this is the big logic that we had
let's go through it again if
notification type is follow so if the
user has followed we want a person icon
like this to show up
if it's like then we want a like filled
icon
and if the user has decided to retweet
then we want a retweet icon
and if it's none of them we don't want
any icon to show up next is the title
and the title is going to be the text
which is notification dot text simple
enough now I can take this notification
tile and use it in the notification View
and return it so we return notification
tile
and return notification
now we'll copy this notification tile
and paste it over here
now we'll restart both of them
and see what we get
so here if I just see everything is
related to like what I'm going to do now
is you know just restart everything
because I want to delete everything
I'll delete everything
and then I'll get back to you because I
want to test it out fresh
so I'm finally done deleting everything
I'll just restart my applications
and here when I try to like a post
that's given by let's say
Revan
let's find a post given by Revan let's
say hi hey guys one
and click over here and you see no one
liked your tweet this is good
now if I try to like a post given by
Naman so I'll just give hey
and then click on tweet
you can see hey showing up I'll just go
at the top here it is
I'll stay here to show you that it's
real time I'll click on heart icon and
you can see Revan liked your Tweet
this is awesome that means the entire
notification process is now working now
let's just get it done working for
literally all the features retweet
comment icon
when the user replies to someone so all
we need to do is basically
close all the save files go to tweet
controller
copy this and paste it everywhere so
when you re-share a tweet and it's a
success
before you say retweeted what you need
to push
is this thing notification dot create
notification
is going to be current
user dot name liked your Tweet so that
means we have liked your Tweet
and the uid should be tweet.uid tweet.id
tweet.retweeted by is the user who
retweeted tweet.uid is the user whom
will send the notification to okay
now let's try it for something so if I
try to retweet naman's retweeted you
know I'll just come over here and see
and this should not be light your Tweet
sorry this should be reshared your Tweet
that's why we couldn't see the like part
it should be retweeted now if I retweet
naman's retweet you can see re-shared
your tweet this shows up pretty cool
now the next part is whenever the user
decides to comment on other user so I
can copy the same thing
I'll go down where there's
reply so I'll just go reply
and there's no reply over here it's in
the Twitter reply View
and here down below we have the on
submitted property we have passed in the
reply to so here we also need to pass in
another thing replied to user ID
so basically we don't in the share tweet
we don't have access to a field called
reply to user ID so whom are we trying
to reply to what is the
user ID of the user to whom we are
replying to
right so we need that so we have replied
to user ID and this should be tweet.uid
okay so if we come back over here
reply to user ID is exactly what we need
to send out notification
because it's at the end of the day
tweet.uid and everywhere we have used
tweet.uid to send to the notification to
a person because we have replied to
their tweet right we're going to get it
through tweet.uid and we have accepted
that over here
so now what we need to do is just take
reply to user ID share it literally
everywhere share text to it
and share image tweet both of them
accept them in both of these functions
so we'll just have required
replied to user ID string
and
required string reply to user ID
and here after the success we're just
going to check
also put a bracket here
if replied to user ID dot is not empty
so if it is not empty that means I
replied to user's ID is not empty that
means there is some ID and if there is
some ID
we want to send a notification so let's
just copy this go down below and paste
it over here and here we just want to
say
reply to your Tweet
so the user.name the current user
replied to your Tweet and this is reply
the post ID will not be tweet.id don't
make this mistake basically
tweet.id is this tweet's ID
right and here the ID is empty string so
if you try to put post ID it will give
you an empty string over here and your
notification won't get sent what you
need instead is this this
RS ID because this R is basically the
tweet that you get after uploading it to
Upright when you upload it to app right
you get a particular ID because we have
used id.unique while sharing the Tweet
so here we get R and we're going to use
this R to get the ID and we get that
using r dot dollar ID
so the post ID should be r dot dollar ID
and the uid should not be tweet.uid
because tweet.uid is user.uid we do not
want that the uid should be replied to
user ID okay
the same thing is going to be there in
the share image tweet as well right here
we're just going to have
R and we're just going to have this
simple and easy
the state is equal to false will also
come over here
after all of this
even for the share text tweet
let's go over there the state is equal
to false will be done only after the
notification is sent
now in the create wheat view let's see
what's the error we need to provide the
reply to user ID
it's going to be empty over here and
since it's empty we are not replying to
anyone if you are not replying to anyone
the notification does not get sent to
anyone that makes sense
now let's rerun it let's reply to
someone so let's say I want to reply to
Naman so I just say hey what's
up
and then click on done now if you come
to the notification section you see
Revan replied to your Tweet
and for the reply we did not have any
icon so I did not have any icon
for 10 over here even according to our
logic so if you have an icon do share it
in the comment section or you can just
have it in the leading icon widget okay
now the last part is The Following part
so whenever we try to follow a user
it should show up in the notification
section there as well so I'm just going
to copy this go to the user
profile controller
and if it's a success at the end this
always gets sent in the end basically
after all the logic process has done we
want notification to be sent
and here we are going to require
notification controller so we have
notification
controller underscore notification
controller required notification
controller notification controller
underscore notification controller is
equal to notification controller
that has a lot of stuff
but at the top we can resolve the error
by passing a notification controller as
ref.watch notification controller
provider dot Notifier
and over here what are things that we
need well we are going to create a
notification saying user.name
followed you
but is it going to be user.name no it's
going to be current user.name right
because it's us who has followed the
other person what is the post ID going
to be well we can find that
but there's no finding it out because a
follow cannot have a post ID because we
are not
doing anything related to tweet right so
it's going to be empty
what is the notification type going to
be well it's just going to be follow
and the uid is going to be user.uid not
the current user.uid the user.uid so we
have added this now let's try to follow
one user so let's say I try to follow
from here Revan
so I can just see
I'll click on follow
it doesn't really get sent
you can see Naman followed you shows up
so that means the entire notification
section now works you can retweet you
can do anything and it will work
now the left next section is basically
listing out everything that
one hashtag has basically if I have one
tweet that has hashtag rivon this is
nice and then I tweet it and then I have
another tweet that has hashtag rivan
not at the rate
#rivan hashtag nice hashtag
wow and you then click on tweet
and even this person has hashtag rivan
in some of their comments so they have a
hashtag
haha hashtag
oof and then click on tweet you see
there are three Hashtags with ravan and
when one of this hashtag is clicked
you know this hashtag should open up in
a different screen the hashtag screen
and it should show you all the posts
from that particular hashtag
okay so this is what we are trying to
achieve so this is what we'll do we want
to get all the posts from one particular
hashtag and if you see our database
structure it's well suited for that we
had made this for this purpose only
if you go to the tweets not
notifications
and see aware
the hashtags have rivan haha and open it
right
so we just want to check if the array
contains hashtag Raymond or not if it
contains hashtag rivon
or whatever you click on hashtag nice
hashtag wow
any of this is clicked
you just want to check in the ira that
it's there if it's there then
we just display everything
so this is what we are trying to achieve
and this should be very simple this is
can actually be a challenge for you you
can try to do it on your own if you are
able to do so then you've properly
understood app right till now
so try it on your own it should give you
confidence but if you can't then we can
do it together right now so let's start
we'll go to the vs code so what we are
going to do is close all the save files
and we are directly going to go in the
Tweet API and create a recent tweet so
what is the last function of this tweet
API it's going to be future list of
document this exact same thing because
we are going to get all the user tweets
not the user tweets but get the tweets
by hashtag and here we are going to get
a hashtag
right so the implementation
is very similar to get user Tweets we're
just going to copy this
paste it away
it's going to be asynchronous
we are going to list all the documents
in the tweets collection where
the hashtags should be equal to not
really because hashtags is a list we
cannot equate it here we want to search
so in the hashtags array we want to
search that the hashtag is present and
if the hashtag is found then we want to
return all of those documents right
so we will use query.search hashtags and
then find a particular hashtag
and then we'll return the document now
all we need to do is go to the Tweet
controller create
a function very similar to get user
tweets or get replies to tweets
something like that we're going to get
the documents but here the name will be
get
tweets by hashtag
we'll mention the hashtag from the UI so
the future provider is also going to be
family and here we're going to have
tweet API dot get
tweets by hashtag we'll pass in the
particular hashtag and all of those
conversions will take place now we just
need to go to the Future provider
we'll have to create one and this will
be very similar to rest of the things
that we have get
tweets by hashtag provider
future provider and this time we are
going to get a string of
hashtag
and then we are just going to pass that
to the get tweet by hashtag function
simple enough now we can just go to the
view create one view which is hashtag
view dot dot
and here we need to import material dot
we want to create a stateless consumer
widget called hashtag View
you're going to import flutter riverpod
Library
we are going to return a scaffold
here we are also going to accept a
string hashtag so basically this hashtag
is whatever the user clicked on so if
the user clicks on this hashtag we will
navigate to a new screen where hashtag
will be written in the title and all the
posts from this particular hashtag will
be seen so let's require it through the
Constructor so we have required this Dot
hashtag
let's put this inside of
the name Constructor
now in the app bar we are going to have
Abba and the title is going to be text
hashtag
okay
and now we are also going to go to the
home view copy this route
put it in hashtag View and return
hashtag view from here just like we've
done multiple times before
but this time we're going to take it
from the parameter so we have a hashtag
and we pass that in to the particular
hashtag
now what do we want to do well whenever
the user clicks on this hashtag which is
identified so how do we identify and
where do we identify the hashtag we do
that
in the widget your hashtag text so what
we can do is
whenever we identify a hashtag over here
we can just have something known as
recognize the year and we can pass in
tab gesture recognizer this is a Syntax
for it we create an object of capture
it's just a recognizer and we give it a
property of ontap and the on tap
property is equal to
an anonymous function
and here we can write whatever we want
so we basically want to have Navigator
dot push
and we want to push to the hashtag view
so we have hashtag
View
Dot
route and we pass in the particular
hashtag what is a particular hashtag
element
this is what we had right element dot
starts with hashtag we just push it to
hashtag view.rout after we've completed
this we can go to the
View
restart our application on iPhone and
Android
click on driven let's say and we get
hashtag Revan now the thing that's left
is just to display everything now to
display everything VR
scholars in it now we can just go to the
body
and
you know again instead of typing so much
we can just go to the Tweet list
copy everything from there
and see what all stuff we need so I'm
just going to copy it
paste it here
import the loader save common
import tweet card survive tweet card
and I don't think we need any of this
I'm not making it real time of course if
you want to make it to real time go
ahead but I'm not making it so again
I'll have to remove all of this
all of this part
I also have to remove this returning
part
all I need is get hashtag tweets by
hashtag provider and pass in the
particular hashtag and when there's data
we'll get tweets and we can display that
and now we can remove this bracket this
is an extra bracket it seems
even this one
and now we don't have any error we're
basically returning a list view Builder
with all the tweets if you want to make
it real time you can go ahead and make
it there's no problem with it I just
removed it so that that's complete no
complexity you already know how to make
it real time we just remove the real
time code
and now you can see we are getting this
error index not found hashtags when we
get this error we go to app right
then we go to our tweets indexes create
index and here let's just say search
by hash tag and this is going to be
let's say full text because it's search
and then we are going to have the
attribute
so what is the attribute we are
searching by hashtags order descending
create
refresh the app
and then click on driven you see all the
tweets which has driven in it
that means this is working our app is
now working even to show the latest
hashtags this was very simple right
you just need to understand the logic
for one thing and you'll get everything
else
now the next thing is to close all the
save files we have completed all the
features except one which is Twitter
blue
so let's get into it to get into Twitter
blue what we need to do is go to the
home View and your basically whenever we
click over here we want a drawer to
appear and in that drawer we should get
my profile so that when I click on it I
can go to my profile and the option to
convert to Twitter blue and the logout
option so these three things are the
things we need to work on and you're
done with the application
so you're in the home folder we are
going to get widgets
and the widget is going to be side draw
dot dot
so let's import material dot let's
create a stateless widget called this
side drawer
and actually this will be a consumer
widget so let's import that add in a
widget ref
and now let's have a safe area
so that you know our drawer doesn't
merge with the top no notches over here
and then we have drawer
then we have a child a column and in
that column we have children and what
are the children that we need well first
of all is a list Style
and in the list style we have a leading
icon
which is const icon icons dot person
then a title which is constant text
my profile
and an on tap to it
now what I'm going to do is just attach
this drawer to the home view so here I'm
just going to add a drawer property and
pass side drawer to it
let's have constant over here save it
and whenever I click over here my
profile shows up but this is not good
because this is not black in color I
just wanted pure black so I'll just pass
in the background color property AS
Palette dot background color if I save
this much and go back you can see this
is black but I want the font size to be
increased now so I can just go ahead
and have style as textile
with font size as let's say 22
much bigger and looks much better
you can also increase the size of this
icon so let's say size of the icon is
now
this looks good but maybe 30 might look
better
and yep it does
now you can copy these list styles two
more times
another one is for Twitter blue
and for Twitter blue
the icon is going to be payment
because well you're going to take money
from them
Twitter blue and if you don't want this
to happen what you can do is just use
SVG picture.asset and then you can use
the Twitter blue verified icon that I've
added in the svgs but since I just want
to troll I'm just going to use the
payment one
and the last one is the logout option so
you can just scroll down and have
log out over here and this is going to
be icons dot logout
save it and here we have it
now I just want to leave some space from
the top so I can just have let's say a
constant sized box of
height 50 if I do this much and come
this looks better
all right now the next thing is whenever
I click over here I want to navigate to
my profile page so to do that what I'm
going to do is Navigator dot push
and I want to go to the profile page so
I'll just say user
profile
View
and then I have to pass in the user
model to get the user model now I'll
just do final current user is equal to
ref.watch
current user details provider dot value
and then I'll check if current user is
equal equal to null then I want to
return
a constant loader otherwise
everything else is going to work
now I can just pass in the current user
not over here dot route and I'll pass in
the current user over here
great now if I just click over here I
should be able to go to my profile and
this works pretty good
next thing is when I click on Twitter
blue I should get a verified badge next
to my name so to do this you'll have to
go to the user API
scroll up
create and actually if you see over here
in the user API we have something known
as user update user data so I don't
think we have to create a separate
function for is Twitter blue to update
the s3w of course
so what I'm going to do is close all of
them
go to my site draw
and here I'm directly going to say
ref dot read
user profile controller
provider.modifier dot update user
profile then I have to pass in the user
model the user model is going to be
current user Dot
copy with
and now I want to copy with what
if Twitter blue should now be true this
is the updated user data that should be
there
the banner file is not there null and
the profile file is not there so it
should be null
so obviously if we go to the update user
profile this is updated user model since
both of them are null these two
functions won't run or the if blocks
won't run and then we call update user
data it passes in the user model which
is
s2w is now true
okay
and now the last thing that I need to do
is just go to my tweet card and here I
just want to display my
verified icon so what we are going to do
is scroll up
right here you can see we have container
in the container where we have margin
here we are going to check if tweet dot
is not tweet sorry if the user dot is 20
blue so if the user is Twitter blue then
we want a margin of 1 otherwise a margin
of 5 from the right hand side now we'll
remove the constant as well
why is this logic there because if the
user is straight or blue then we will
have a Twitter batch beside it right so
we want a very less margin to be present
but if there's if the user is not
Twitter blue it's fine if the margin is
little bit more to the right
and now we are just going to have after
the container if condition so if user is
Twitter blue
then we want to have an SVG picture dot
asset of asset constants Dot
verified icon now we'll save it nothing
shows up because no user is to a w as of
now
so now let's try to convert one user so
I'll click on Twitter blue here nothing
happens but if I refresh my application
on both the devices
I see the Twitter blue icon
great but this Twitter icon if you zoom
it in it's very close to this username
so I want there to be a margin from the
right hand side so for that I can either
wrap it with container or a padding and
here have dot only and from the right
hand side I want five so from the right
hand side I have a padding of 5 and this
looks much better and less congested you
know
so if the user is Twitter blue it shows
up now we also want to show it on the
user's profile right beside their name
over here so now we can just have this
user.s2w we'll go to use a profile view
in the user profile just below where
they mention their name right here we're
going to wrap it with a
row widget and have
something like if user is Twitter blue
then we want this thing where is it
this padding to be present
with the icon so I can import flutter
SVG I can import asset constants
and save it
after I do that you can see I get my
Twitter blue icon over here but I don't
I don't want the padding to be from the
right hand side I want it to be left
hand side so I have it
and this looks so good
maybe we can do two
whatever way you prefer three whatever
so I'll just keep it three and we get
the verified symbol over here and if the
user is not Twitter blue we can see that
over here that they are not Veda blue
and of course Twitter blue is eight
dollars so if you want to implement
payment integration I'll create a
separate tutorial for it
you can check it out
I'll mention it in the cards above when
I created
but if you already have an idea or if
you want to use Google or Appleway which
I've used in my other tutorials what you
can do is
you can implement it
here before the side drawer when you
click on tap over here you can create a
method and
create a separate controller so that you
can add your own you know Twitter blue
thing
your payment integration so you can add
it in the on tap over here and then only
update the user profile so if the
payment is Success you can update the
user profile else you will not
so now the last feature we are left with
is the logout feature so for that we are
going to go to the auth API we're just
going to have future
either
void logout
I'm just going to have create one
missing override
we are going to have async
we're going to have our simple try and
catch blocks
and here we don't want anything we'll
just have if await account dot delete
session
or if you want to delete multiple
sessions so you want to delete sessions
from all the
phones so you can do delete sessions and
just do this so it will log you out from
all the devices but I only want to
delete session from this part and I have
to mention the session ID so what is the
session ID
well the session ID is basically the
login session that it gives us that ID
but since I don't have it what I can do
is current
when I use current aware it will delete
this current session ID
app right identifies it and does it for
me now I'll just do return right null
meaning that is a success
and in case of failures yes all of this
is done now we can go to the auth
controller we can create avoid function
for logout so we avoid logout and then
we can have
underscore auth API dot logout
log out
and we can await this final result is
equal to this
also async now result.fold if you want
to handle it some way you can do it but
in my case if it's a success what I want
to do is just
do Navigator dot push
and remove until
then pass in the build context the new
route will be
the sign up screen
sign
up view dot route
false so basically this will pop off
push and remove the screen until we get
to the signup view dot route and then
we'll pass in the build context
now to use this what we want to do is
just go to my side drawer
just use your ref dot read auth
controller provider dot Notifier Dot
log out pass in the required build
context and done so we'll restart the
entire app
and now if I try to log the user out
let's log out we've logged out
now if I try to restart and see if I'm
on the login screen now yes I am on the
login screen now because account is now
null we have deleted the session so we
have developed an entire application an
entire Twitter clone where you are able
to like retweet comment on a profile
put hashtags identify links click on
links to go on a new link
you know in a browser
search for users follow a particular
user
unfollow a particular user see the
notifications here
even if it's replied e-share like
anything
and also able to add Carousel images to
your application
and obviously the most important feature
that is Twitter blue so I hope you
learned enough from this application
if you did make sure to leave a
subscribe to this channel this was it
for this tutorial thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video